[Musique]
Messieurs, bonsoir.
Bonsoir. Bonsoir. Pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Sinkerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Jean-Marc Jeancov ici.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ?
Alors, le nom c'est bon. Euh je suis
président d'une association qui
s'appelle de Chief Project en bon
français dans le texte. Je suis
également associé d'une société qui
s'appelle Carbon 4 et enfin je suis
enseignant au mine de Paris.
Philippe Wix.
Et ben bonsoir. Moi je suis Philippe
Bwix, ingénieur. Je m'intéresse à
question des ressources non
renouvelables depuis une vingtaine
d'années. J'ai écris quelques quelques
bouquins là-dessus. Et puis dans la
vraie vie, je suis dirigeant,
codirigeant dans une société qui fait
euh de l'architecture, de de
l'environnement, de l'urbanisme, du
design, de la construction et une
filiale de la SNCF qui s'appelle AREP,
le groupe AREP. On est très content de
vous recevoir ce soir. On va faire un
débrief élection de Trump,
Elion Musk, le projet d'aller dans
l'espace, la satellisation de
d'astéroïdes pour l'exploitation minière
que ce soit autour de chez nous, sur la
Lune habité, colonisé Mars, les
répercussions que ça peut avoir sur
notre biotop, notre environnement. On
parlera fonction exponentielle de
consommation et tous ces délires de
d'intelligence artificielle, de
nucléaire et tout ce qui va avec.
Jean-Marc Jeankovici, comment vous
sentez l'élection de Trump ?
Alors, beaucoup de gens ont l'impression
que l'élection du nouveau ou de la
nouvelle parce que ça aurait pu être
Camala Haris,
président président non mais je veux
dire tant qu'il y avait que des
candidats et candidates, c'était l'un ou
l'autre euh allait faire une très grande
différence sur le comportement de
l'ensemble du pays. Personnellement, je
n'y crois pas.
Vous savez pourquoi ? Euh je vais
essayer de l'expliquer.
Le train de vie le train de vie des
Américains est innégociable.
Alors, je ne pense pas que Camala Haris
avait l'intention de négocier quoi que
ce soit sur le train de vie des
Américains. Et je suis très sensible au
comment dire à la façon d'expliquer les
choses de quelqu'un comme Jarette
Diamond qui donne des déterminants très
géographiques
à la manière dont les civilisations se
forment. Alors, quand on regarde la
façon dont les États-Unis se sont formés
comme pays, euh c'est des gens qui euh
ont construit un pays dans la violence
euh parce que ils sont quand même battus
entre eux, battus avec les Indiens
qu'ils ont zigouillé et cetera. C'est un
pays qui est né dans l'immensité des
ressources. Euh il faut bien voir que ce
pays croule depuis l'origine sous le
charbon, le pétrole, le gaz, les
ressources minérales, l'espace, le bois.
Enfin, il y a absolument tout ce qu'on
veut chez eux.
Et c'est donc un pays où la notion de
limite globale n'a pas de sens. On le
voit bien du reste, ça fait partie de ce
qu'on appelle les pays vide. Quand on
parle d'environnement, la Russie est un
peu comme eux, l'Australie est un peu
comme eux, c'est-à-dire c'est des pays
où il y a une très faible densité de
population, énormément de ressources
disponibles et le fait de s'imposer une
limite est quelque chose qui est
culturellement absent de la civilisation
américaine.
Et donc c'est un pays qui ne produit pas
spontanément qui ne va pas spontanément
produire une élite qui va aller à
l'encontre de ce qu'est le pays dans
dans dans sa chair, j'ai envie de dire.
Et quand on regarde ce que Biden ou
Obama ont fait pendant leur mandat sur
la question énergétique par exemple, ils
ont fait des choses qui étaient
parfaitement dans la continuité de ce
qu'on fait Bush ou Trump 1. Euh Biden a
accordé des tas d'autorisation de
forage. La production de pétrole a
augmenté de 80 % aux États-Unis sous le
mandat d'Obama. La production de gaz a
augmenté de 30 %. Camala Haris dans son
débat avec Trump c'est vanté d'avoir
gagné euh c'est le le vice-président ou
la vice-présidente quand il y a égalité
des voix au Sénat peut apporter la voix
qui va faire le tiebre break enfin qui
va qui va faire pencher la balance. Et
Camala Haris dans son débat avec Trump
s'est venté d'avoir fait pencher la
balance en faveur de l'ouverture de
nouveaux espaces pour l'exploitation du
pétrole de Rochem aux États-Unis. Donc
en fait sur le terrain, j'ai envie de
dire énergétique et sur le terrain
environnemental, il y avait pas
énormément de différence entre enfin
comment dire l'électorat lui-même ne
fait pas énormément de différence. La
deuxième chose qu'il faut voir aux
États-Unis, c'est que c'est un état
fédéral. Alors pour beaucoup de Français
qui vivent dans un état très centralisé
et qui n'est pas fédéral, on a du mal à
comprendre ce que ça veut dire. Mais en
fait, aux États-Unis, c'est les États
fédérés qui ont la main sur l'essentiel
des initiatives. Et ce qui vient de se
passer avec l'élection de Trump ne va
pas changer grand-chose au comportement
de la Californie, de l'Oregon, du
Massachusetts ou du Main. Voilà. Et
symétriquement, ça ne va pas non plus
changer grand-chose au comportement
du Montana ou du Nouveau-Mexique. Voilà.
Donc il va y avoir une forme de
continuité de la politique locale. Alors
Trump va faire un certain nombre de
choses quand même. Il va nommer des
juges à sa main parce que ça avec le
Sénat il peut changer il peut changer
une partie des gens. Et dans un pays
très judiciarisé comme les États-Unis,
ça compte.
Il peut changer les dirigeants d'agence
fédéral mais enfin les agences fédérales
font pas la politique de l'ensemble des
États-Unis. Et avant Trump, il y avait
pas de loi fédérale par exemple
encadrant les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre. euh il y en avait pas avant
lui, il y en aura pas après lui, mais
les États-Unis vivent sans depuis très
longtemps. Je dis pas que ce soit une
bonne nouvelle, je pense pas que ça
aurait changé euh avec euh l'élection de
quelqu'un d'autre. Euh donc le le et aux
États-Unis, pour finir, c'est un régime
qui est extrêmement parlementaire,
c'est-à-dire qu'à la différence de la
France où c'est le gouvernement qui a la
main normalement sur l'agenda du
Parlement et du reste en ce moment, on
est en train de voir ce qui se passe
quand les deux sont plus du tout
raccord, euh et bien aux États-Unis,
chaque chambre gère son propre agenda.
La notion de décret d'application
n'existe pas vraiment. Ce qui veut dire
que les lois font 800 pages parce
qu'elles comportent toutes leurs
décrets, elles comportent les décrets
d'application qui vont avec. Et les lois
doivent être votées dans les mêmes
termes dans les deux assemblées. Il y a
pas de préséance d'une assemblée sur
l'autre comme il y a en France avec le
l'Assemblée nationale qui a le pas sur
le Sénat. Donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle en fait les nouvelles lois aux
États-Unis quand on regarde combien un
président arrive à faire passer de
nouvelles lois pendant sa mandature, ça
se compte sur les doigts d'une main.
C'est pas on est on n'est pas du tout
comme en France où quand un président
arrive avec un parlement à sa main enfin
qui qui est de la même couleur, il va
faire voter des centaines de lois
pendant son mandat. Alors pas du tout ça
qui se passe aux États-Unis. Donc pour
moi, il y a pas de l'élection de Trump.
On peut en discuter sur le personnage,
on peut avoir un avis sur le personnage,
on peut en discuter sur les valeurs
qu'il véhicule. Ce type estrancié dans
son comportement, sexiste, raciste,
enfin bon tout ce qu'on veut. Totalement
fantas.
Oui. Totalement fantasque et cetera.
Mais là, on parle du personnage. La
question c'est est-ce que la le le
comportement fondamental des États-Unis
vient de changer avec ce qui va avec
avec son élection ? Personnellement, je
ne le pense pas. Euh voilà. et Deaul
disait euh "Les États euh n'ont pas
d'amis, ils n'ont des intérêts. Je ne
pense pas que les intérêts des
États-Unis viennent de changer
fondamentalement euh avec la nouvelle
élection.
Philippe, mes de question.
Ouais. Alors, je je nuancerai un petit
peu bien sûr, je je je te rejoins
Jean-Marc sur le fait que
bah que c'est un pays à frontière
ouverte. Donc historiquement
effectivement, il y a eu une profusion
de de de ressources et ils ont enchaîné
finalement des bonnes nouvelles. Alors
il y a d'abord eu le bois, les grandes
plaines effectivement le le charbon des
appalaches et puis après ils sont tombés
sur les filons d'or en Californie et
puis ensuite le comstock qui était de
l'argent et de l'or au Nevada et cetera
et que il y a eu il y a eu cette grande
richesse. Je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord sur le fait que les
et puis bien sûr oui passer le pétrole
et du coup le revival incroyable du
pétrole de non conventionnel
même avant
et l'Alaska avant il y a toujours eu des
des effets comme ça de de boss qu'ils
ont réussi à passer
mais par contre je pense qu'il y a quand
même eu euh des moments de l'histoire
des États-Unis où les les élites se sont
posées des questions et euh et
aujourd'hui si tu regardes euh ce qu'est
leur extraction euh minérale par exemple
donc effectivement hors gaz euh pétrole
ou charbon où là effectivement c'est
profusion. Bah sur le reste des
ressources minérales, dès les années 50
en fait, il y a des gens qui se posent
des questions. Il y a notamment, je
crois que c'est une commission qui
s'appelle la commission palais PE Y pour
ceux qui veulent checker, qui dans début
des années 50 va produire un ép rapport
sur la question des ressources minérales
aux États-Unis et la question de de de
comment est-ce que on ces ressources
minérales vont réussir à nourrir ou pas
l'industrie américaine qui est
évidemment encore très forte. Et voilà.
Et donc il se pose des questions et
presque les mêmes questions qu'on
pourrait se poser aujourd'hui à
l'échelle mondiale, c'est-à-dire est-ce
qu'on va avoir assez de ressources ?
Est-ce que ça peut nourrir la croissance
qui à l'époque est de 5 6 7 8 10 % par
an ? Et il y a des vraies questions
comme ça. Et tu pourrais aussi rajouter
Jimmy Carter qui installe des trois
panneaux photovoltaïques sur le sur la
Maison Blanche au moment de au moment à
la fois de de de la crise donc de
l'énergie au début des années 70 et à
l'arrivée d'ailleurs des petites
bagnoles japonaises qui vont avoir un
certain succès sur le marché américain
parce que justement elle consomme moins
et donc il y a un petit moment comme ça
de flottement et aujourd'hui on pourrait
dire que peut-être je suis d'accord que
c'est pas ça apparaît pas dans le débat
démocratique mais de toute façon le
niveau du débat démocratique fait qu'il
y a quand même pas beaucoup d'idées
effectivement qui sont qui émergent à
part des punchlines et de trois de trois
postures. Mais je pense que dans la
question de la diplomatie américaine euh
ça peut changer des choses qui je
soutien qui je soutiens pas. Et puis
surtout je pense que il y a quand même
des gens, je sais pas si c'est à
Washington ou ailleurs, mais qui se
posent des questions sur les limites et
sur aussi bah la croissance de la Chine,
de l'Inde et le retour en 2048 de de la
Chine au niveau de deux siècles après
cette fait un petit peu cogné dessus.
Non, pas de siècles, un siècle et demi.
Euh voilà. Donc il y a la question par
exemple du Pacifique, la question
justement de l'Australie effectivement
qui va être un terrain de jeu de
ressources minérales au 21e siècle et où
aujourd'hui bah où la Nouvelle-Caédonie
a un petit peu à côté. Donc il y a il y
a je pense que voilà c'est cette cette
idée quand même alors c'est peut-être
pas ils sont pas confrontés à la
finitude comme on peut l'être nous dans
notre vieille Europe où on est là en
disant merde quand on artificialise un
hectare de terre agricole en bordure
d'une métropole on se 18 il faut faire
zéro artificialisation nette il faut
arrêter et cetera parce qu'on voit bien
que nous on est un petit peu coincé eux
si si on va parler de de
d'artificialisation aux États-Unis je
crois qu'ils sont ils s'en foutent un
peu au milieu de dans dans la banlieue
de Phenniix mais par contre quand même
sur cette question de de finitude de la
planète il y Il y a des questions et un
truc assez moi j'adore une vidéo de de
2019 de Jeff Bessos où il
qui quand il lance le enfin il il
dévoile en fait le module Blue Origin,
donc le module lunaire Blue Origin et
bon pour mettre le truc en scène en
expliquant qu'il va falloir aller dans
l'espace faire la conquête et cetera, il
commence exactement par finalement une
notion de limite en disant la croissance
euh on consomme alors il prend l'énergie
mais ça ça serait la même chose avec les
ressources. Il dit, on consomme 2 3 % de
d'énergie de plus par an malgré
l'efficacité, hein, malgré l'efficience
euh à cause un peu de d'effets rebonds
et puis de développement, et bien en
fait dans quelques siècles, il faudra
couvrir la terre de planeau solaire.
Donc c'est pas possible. Donc on va
aller dans l'espace. Donc il y a quand
même un peu cette idée, il joue un peu
de cette idée de l'affinité. Oui, mais
tu vois bien que la réponse est pas du
tout la même. C'est-à-dire que les
Français disent il y a pas assez, donc
on va faire de la sobriété. Les
États-Unis disent il y a pas assez, on
va les chercher chez les autres. C'est
c'est c'est en ça que je dis euh la
notion de limite globale est quelque
chose qui sur laquelle ils ont pas du
tout la même approche que les Européens.
Euh il y a pas assez chez nous, on va
aller se servir chez les autres et s'il
y a pas assez sur terre, on va les
servir sur Mars. C'est c'est c'est pas
du tout la même réponse.
Après les Européens, ils vont chercher
chez les autres. Je regarde aujourd'hui
les ressources critiques de l'Union
européenne. De toute façon, il y a 90%
qui arrivent, ils aimeraient bien mais
ça leur ça leur parle aussi de dire on
va aussi gérer le problème par des
économies globales. C'est c'est un truc
qui est quand même beaucoup plus proche
de la culture européenne et d'une
manière générale beaucoup plus proche de
la culture des vieux pays dépourvus de
ressources. C'est également quelque
chose qui peut avoir du sens au Japon.
Euh c'est également voilà le le les
États-Unis, ils ont ils ont pas cette
approche là. Donc c'est pour ça que je
disais, je vois pas l'élection de Trump
comme l'avènement d'une catastrophe qui
n'aurait pas existé avant. Je pense que
le comportement des États-Unis est d'une
façon générale une catastrophe et que
l'élection l'électure de Trump ne change
pas grand chose à cette étatsunis, c'est
les carnivores et l'Europe, c'est les
herbivores.
Euh, on pourrait dire que les
États-Unis, c'est ceux qui sont tombés
du côté du Manche et nous un peu moins
quoi. Voilà. Enfin, nous on l'était du
côté du Manche il y a deux siècles. Il y
a un siècle et demi et puis ça y est, on
a bouffé notre pain blanc. Le pic de
production du charbon en
Grande-Bretagne, c'est 1913. Dans dans
l'Europe, c'est décennies récent, c'est
1980. Euh
voilà. Donc nous nous on est dans une
phase dans laquelle les ressources
disponibles sur le sol européen sont
plutôt globalement en déclin. Quelques
exceptions métalliques près peut-être
que Philippe pour évoquer, mais
globalement, on est plutôt on est plutôt
en en déclin. Euh alors que les
États-Unis, ils ont commencé leur
ascension après nous dans en tapant dans
un stock qui est beaucoup plus
important. Donc elle eux quelque part si
à jouer au jeu du plus, ils en ont
encore un peu sous le pied.
Question.
Comment vous percevez la réaction des
politiques européennes et françaises par
rapport au côté prédateur américain ?
Alors, je trouve que les Européens sont
globalement un peu naïfs euh dans cette
histoire, mais euh c'est pas tellement
les réactions des politiques que je
commente euh en disant ça. Euh c'est
plutôt les réactions euh de la de la de
la politique publique euh qui peut être
faite en en Europe.
Par exemple, je pense que la question du
marché ouvert sur laquelle les auquel
les Européens ont été très longtemps
très attachés
est en fait un quelque chose qui marche
bien quand on a les armes de la
puissance chez soi. Ça marche moins bien
quand on a moins les armes de la
puissance chez soi. Et donc les ni les
Chinois ni les États-Unis ne sont dans
un marché totalement ouvert. C'est pas
leur mode de fonctionnement. Donc, ils
sont pas du tout contre le commerce
international, mais ils sont pas non
plus euh en à en faire l'alpha et
l'oméga euh de l'ensemble de leur
politique publique. Et de temps en
temps, il y a un certain nombre de trucs
sur lesquels ils disent "Là patouche."
Alors nous, on trouve pas ça bien, mais
leur intérêt est de le faire. Euh je
trouve que les Européens ils ont ils ont
mis le temps euh ça commence à changer
mais ils ont mis le temps avant de se
rendre compte que c'était pas
nécessairement la meilleure manière
d'aborder l'avenir.
Mais c'est un virage qui qui sont qui
semble prendre parce que effectivement
la question par exle des mécanismes
d'ajustement aux frontières donc il va
concerner que quelques matières d'imper
la taxation de ceci ou cela. Voilà,
c'est c'est des choses, c'était presque
des gros mots il y a il y a 10 ans et
aujourd'hui euh on se rend compte que
effectivement c'est difficile de faire
une transition tout en se faisant casser
les reins potentiellement par des des
endroits où la production va pas avoir
du tout la même manière de compter les
externalités environnementales et
sociales quoi. Franç
vous y cro vous y croyez à la
réindustrialisation de la France et de
l'Europe
où c'est du wishful thinking de
politique
en en supportation de vote en
réclamation de vote en
ça dépend ce qu'on veut ré ça dépense ce
qu'on veut réindustrialiser
si on veut réindustrialiser chez nous de
la fabrication de vélo, j'y crois. Si on
veut réindustrialiser chez nous la même
fabrication de voiture que toutes celles
qu'on importe, ça va être plus
compliqué. Euh tout simplement parce que
quand on regarde l'histoire industrielle
des nations, en fait, l'histoire
industrielle a toujours démarré avec la
la gestion enfin ou avec la possession
plus exactement sur son territoire de ce
qui permet d'alimenter l'industrie
lourde, c'est-à-dire l'industrie des
matériaux de base. C'est comme ça que
l'Europe a démarré son
industrialisation, c'est comme ça que
les États-Unis ont démarré leur
industrialisation, c'est comme ça que la
Russie a démarré son industrialisation.
Alors si même si maintenant on pourrait
dire oui, mais avec la mondialisation,
on peut tout transporter partout et tout
le temps, c'est quand même pas si
simple. Et donc pour se réindustrialiser
sur des gros volumes, il faut avoir chez
soi de quoi faire de la métallurgie, de
la chibie de base et cetera. Et en
Europe, il y a une partie de ces
ressources qu'on a plus. On a vidé, on a
vidé de charbon, on a vidé les puits de
pétrole et cetera. Donc tout dépend de
ce qu'on appelle réindustrialisation. On
a du C de chiste.
Euh c'est pas sûr. Euh Pouyané a dit il
y a pas très longtemps, je crois que
c'était public, euh s'il y avait
vraiment eu du gaz de chiste en France,
vous nous auriez entendu protester un
peu plus fort quand il a été question
d'interdire la fracturation hydraulique.
Euh donc c'est pas du tout sûr. Il y a
des rochemers en France, ça c'est sûr.
Mais le plus vraisemblable c'est
qu'elles ont cessé de contenir du
pétrole et du gaz parce que c'est celui
qui est allé dans les gisements de la
Ber
qui est depuis sortie. En Pologne, il y
a eu une tentative d'exploitation
commerciale euh de gaz de de Rochem, de
gaz de chiste. Et en fait, la Roche-Mire
était trop peu était était pas assez
friable, elle était trop molle quelque
part et elle se laissait mal fracturer.
Donc il y a eu quelques tentatives de
fracturation, ça a pas marché, ils ont
plié, ils sont repartis. Euh voilà, donc
c'est pas sûr qu'il y en aurait eu, même
si on avait voulu en faire sortir.
En fait, c'est la question, c'est ce
qu'on cherche dans la dans la
réindustrialisation. Euh pendant
longtemps, bah c'était l'idée, c'était
les avantages comparatifs de Ricardo
quoi, finalement. Donc chacun se
spécialise là où il est plus fort. Et
puis nous bah du coup c'était le French
Cancan, le Mont-Sain-Michel, le musée du
Louvre, le musée d'Orsais et puis on
allait accueillir des touristes je sais
pas quoi. Alors il restait quand même de
l'aérospatiale et quelques trucs comme
ça. Mais du coup voilà, il y avait c'est
un peu le le l'idée he de ce truc de
d'Alcatel, la seru qui avait sorti
d'ailleurs maintenant il se fait un peu
casser du sucre sur le dos histoire de
de voilà de dans de multinational sans
usine et cetera. Et du coup, bon, on
s'est aperçu que c'était quand même un
peu un peu gênant tout ça et que ça
fonctionne pas tout à fait comme ça.
Donc un peu l'idée de de dire bah il
faut rééquilibrer un peu les forces.
Mais si la retérritorisation c'est se
dire on est capable de tout produire ou
de produire une grande partie de ce dont
on a besoin au moins pour remplir des
des des besoins de base quoi qui peuvent
être alors des besoins médicaux, des
besoins de se déplacer, des besoins de
communiquer et cetera, en fait ça va
être sûr que ça va être très très très
compliqué et qu'on maîtrise jamais
finalement l'ensemble d'une chaîne de
valeur. Moi, j'avais beaucoup aimé quand
il y avait eu enfin c'est toujours un
peu le cas avec les les grands fondeurs
comme TSMC à Taïwan qui donc grav à
quelques nanomètres les les puces
diverses et variées qu'on a. Puis il y
avait eu cette crise en 2021 22 de à la
fois la reprise après Covid et puis on
diverses pour diverses raisons ça avait
bloqué des usines des de montage de
voiture hein. Je crois que même il y en
a des fois un endroit ils remontaient
des compteurs analogiques au lieu de
mettre parce qu'ils avaient pas les les
bonnes puces et les bons équipements
électroniques. Donc c'était un vrai
sujet. Et donc il y avait eu beaucoup de
discussions sur ça avec un peu l'idée
qui à mon avis un partiellement un
fantasme de dire que que Taiïwan
finalement c'est un peu son ticket de
sort enfin son ticket de protection de
dire moi je fonds je je grave pour le
monde entier donc de toute façon vous me
laisserez pas tomber face à un
envahissement possible enfin une
invasion chinois et moi je pense que
c'est c'est pas tout à fait ça et puis
en fait quand on
c'est surtout au mauvais paris
oui et puis de toute façon enfin les
capitaux sont chinois enf un moment bon
tu vois tout ça est quand même très très
lié mais en fait tu quand tu regardes un
peu le le truc il y avait des beaux
articles d'ailleurs qui qui étaient
sortis à l'époque. En fait, les
meilleures machines, celles qu'ils
achetaient pour équiper leurs usines à
plusieurs centaines de millions de
dollars, elles étaient elles arrivaient
de Hollande. Euh les profs, les pontes
qui designaaient la nouvelle génération,
c'était l'université de Louvavin. Et
après quand tu creuses un peu l'optique
qui permet en fait de guider le rayon
laser pour graver à quelques nanomètres
près, c'est du précis c'était Suisse,
les lentilles qui permettent de
d'alimenter le truc, c'était des
Américains. Donc à un moment tout est
très lié et plus ton projet plus ton
produit est complexe techniquement, plus
tout est imbriqué de manière un peu
incroyable. Et donc la question en fait
c'est plutôt de dire qu'est-ce que j'ai
comme monnaie d'échange ? Parce que
finalement les civilisations, elles ont
toujours échangé. Elles échangaient déjà
sous l'Empire romain. Enfin voilà, il y
avait déjà des métaux parce qu'il y
avait pas tout partout. Il y avait des
la soie des produits diverses et variés
plus ou moins manufacturés, évidemment
moins complexe qu'aujourd'hui. Et là en
fait on a atteint un niveau où en fait
pour déboutiqu et tout ça c'est
littéralement impossible. Donc la
question c'est quand qu'est-ce qu'on
ramène ou pas ? Mais il y a une je
trouve que la manière dont on le fait
qui est un peu bah à coup de grande
subvention mais finalement avec une
politique industrielle qui est quand
même pas évidente parce que bah il faut
la coordonner à l'échelle européenne.
Donc là évidemment c'est presque
impossible parce que tout le monde veut
la Giga factory chez lui voilà. Voir
même il y a des compètes à gauche enfin
même dans des régions françaises. En
fait même quand tu remets une giga
factory de batterie de de de voiture là
il y en a quelques-unes qui sont en
construction maintenant. Bah ok, mais tu
as pas le cobalt, le nickel, je sais pas
quoi pour venir avec. Même si tu as le
lithium, bah il te faudra quand même des
engins miniers et la la maintenance et
les pièces détachées, les experts
mondiaux, bah ils sont dans plein de
pays différents. Donc tu es toujours un
peu dépendant de toute manière de de
part de t Jeanmarc euh ça ça merci
Philippe pour la transition pour pouvoir
parler de Musk. Jean-Marc, les Giga
Factory, qu'est-ce que tu en penses ?
C'est c'est bien, c'est pas bien. Le
tout électrique, les voitures
électriques, c'est bien, c'est pas bien.
C'est un rêve, c'est un doux rêve.
Je vais je vais rebondir sur ce que
vient de dire Philippe.
Je suis tout à fait d'accord avec lui.
Aujourd'hui, les objets qu'on fabrique
sont devenus trop complexes et trop
peintriqués pour queon puisse dire que
on va rapatrier sur son sol la totalité
de la chaîne de valeur allant de la mine
jusqu'au produit final. Ça n'aurait pas
de sens parce que c'est juste
impossible.
Euh par contre ce qui est possible c'est
d'essayer de se mettre dans une
meilleure position dans l'arbitrage
entre ce qui est fait chez soi et ce qui
est fait chez les autres. Et il y a
quand même à un moment la ressource
qu'on a soit qui va compter dans cette
histoire. Donc le fait que en Europe on
en est beaucoup moins qu'avant des
ressources. Alors il y a quand même des
pays qui arrivent à s'en sortir industri
industriellement en ayant très peu de
ressources sur le sol. Le Japon étant un
très bon exemple. Euh mais ça veut dire
queil faut qu'on choisse bien ces
combats. Euh on peut pas être bon
absolument partout. Et c'est voilà.
Alors la mobilité électrique, je fais
partie je pense que ça fait partie des
combats que euh sur lesquels il faut
qu'on arrive à être bon quelque part.
Euh parce que il y a quand même un petit
sujet dans cette histoire. Euh alors
c'est à l'interface de plusieurs enjeux.
Philippe a parlé de la complexité des
objets. La complexité des objets, ça
marche bien dans une économie qui reste
très mondialisée, mais une économie qui
reste très mondialisée est également une
économie dans laquelle on a besoin de
beaucoup de flux énergétique pour
soutenir cette mondialisation. Et si on
croit comme moi que l'énergie, il y a un
moment on va en avoir de moins en moins
et que voilà, ça va être comme ça, ça va
pas comme toi. Il y a des gens qui
pensent autrement
bien sûr
qui
bah il faut les inviter. J'en sais rien.
Enfin si bien sûr, il y a des gens qui
disent on aura jamais de problème de de
quantité d'énergie disponible. Euh soit
que soit que on ait tellement de
combustible fossil que c'est pas un
problème et le climat on s'en
accommodera toujours, soit que on va les
remplacer par des énergies renouvelables
et on en aura tellement que c'est ça
sera pas un problème non plus
d'abondance.
Quel regard tu portes sur eux ?
Bah je pense que les arbres montent pas
jusqu'au ciel. C'est-à-dire que dans un
système dans un système fini, on peut
pas avoir un flux physique qui croit
indéfiniment quel qu'il soit. Euh voilà.
Mais une fois que j'ai dit ça, j'ai pas
C'est très poli.
Pardon ?
Bah c'est pas très poli, c'est juste
factuel. Mais une fois que j'ai dit ça,
j'ai pas tout dit parce que entre dire
ça peut pas monter jusqu'au ciel mais ça
va quand même durer 3 siècles et ça peut
pas monter jusqu'au ciel et ça va durer
une semaine, on n'est pas en train de
parler de la même chose. Voilà donc il
faut être un peu plus circonstancié, ça
dépend des voilà donc là il faudrait
commencer à rentrer dans un débat sur
énergie par énergie parce que en plus
certaines sont plus régionales que
d'autres, certaines se transportent plus
facon par exemple se transporte moins
facilement que le pétrole. Donc le
pétrole est une énergie mondiale, le
charbon est une énergie beaucoup plus
régionale, domestique bon et cetera.
Donc enfin bon bref, mais sans rentrer
dans les détails,
euh personnellement je pense que ce qui
a fait la mondialisation, c'est le
pétrole parce que c'est la seule énergie
facile à transporter et très dense. Euh
voilà et que une fois qu'on aura de
moins en moins de pétrole, à un moment
ou à un autre, ça va freiner euh le le
degré de mondialisation qu'on a
aujourd'hui et on va partiellement
démondialiser. Incidemment, depuis le
pic de production du pétrole
conventionnel qui a eu lieu en 2008, la
mondialisation a un peu baissé. Alors
trop tôt pour savoir si c'est on est
vraiment en train de on est parti dans
le voilà mais ça a un peu baissé la part
freiné quoi a freiné
un peu baissé la la part du la part des
échanges commerciaux internationaux dans
le PIB mondial était de 60 % en 2008 et
elle est de 55 % aujourd'hui.
C'est quoi tes sources ? Euh mes
sources, c'est euh je ne sais plus trop
quel site de d'information économique.
Euh je sais plus, je suis allé piocher
ça mais enfin bon euh ça ça ça vient pas
du ça vient pas de chez mon fromager
quoi. Euh je sais plus je c ou un truc
comme ça ou un truc de enfin euh
crédible.
Oui oui oui oui. Enfin CDE ou je sais
plus ou ou la ou la ou la Fed ou
je peux couper ? Oui,
le fait que nos politiques euh sont en
train de se jeter sur les technologies
de mobilité électrique, est-ce que c'est
en anticipation
d'une chute du pétrole et on va se
reuter sur du nucléaire ?
Alors, c'est pas en anticipation, non,
ça a été fait en anticipation en fa
exactement en réponse à la question du
climat. Aujourd'hui, il faut bien voir
que la décarbonation de l'économie, elle
a comme moteur principal en Europe la
question climatique. La question du
goulet d'étranglement à l'amont sur les
ressources fossiles est un sujet mal
compris euh et qui intervient
extrêmement peu euh dans la politique
publique. Alors, ça intervient
extrêmement peu dans la politique
publique d'abord parce que ça oblige à
travailler sur des données qui sont pas
des données publiques.
Il se trouve que ce qui est public,
c'est les c'est les productions et les
consommations passées d'hydrocarbure.
Mais les projections de production, ça
c'est de la donnée privée.
Donc ça intervient très peu dans la
décision publique. La deuxième chose,
c'est que comme dans le la sphère de la
décision publique, il y a énormément,
c'est très imprégné de raisonnement
économique. Dans le raisonnement
économique, on est persuadé que quelle
que soit la denrée qu'on est en train de
regarder, il y a une élasticité prix
volume, c'est-à-dire s'il y en a moins,
c'est plus cher et s'il y en a plus,
c'est moins cher. Or, il se trouve que
ça ça marche très bien avec les biens
qui sont pas essentiels pour que
l'appareil économique fonctionne, mais
ça ne marche pas avec des biens qui sont
essentiels pour que l'appareil
économique fonctionne. Alors, je vais
prendre un exemple, les sacs à mains. Si
on produit moins de sac à main,
le tien d'ailleurs est très beau.
Oui, superbe sac à main. et bien ça ne
ça ne change rien à la performance
globale de l'économie. Donc la
solvabilité du comme la production
globale reste la même, la solvabilité du
consommateur reste la même. Donc on a
toujours autant d'argent pour acheter
moins de sac à main. Effectivement, à ce
moment le prix du sac à main monte. Sauf
que avec le pétrole, ça marche pas comme
ça parce que le pétrole est un bien
essentiel au fonctionnement de
l'économie. S'il y a moins de pétrole,
l'économie elle marche moins bien parce
qu'il y a moins de transport, il y a
moins de et cetera en volume. Et donc si
on a moins de pétrole, on a un PIB qui
baisse. Donc la solvabilité du
consommateur baisse. Donc à l'arrivée,
on se retrouve avec moins de pétrole
mais une solvabilité du consommateur qui
a changé et le nouveau prix du pétrole
n'a aucune raison d'être au-dessus ou en
dessous du prix précédent. Donc il y a
une très bonne raison pour que le
pétrole, mais ça vrai, c'est c'est vrai
également pour les commodités
essentielles que sont les métaux,
il y a pas d'élasticité prévolume sur
ces commoditésl
de spéculation. Ce qui veut dire que on
ne voit pas venir une raréfaction en
quantité par une hausse indéfinie du
prix. C'est pas comme ça que ça se voit
venir. Et comme tout le monde est
imprégné de ce raisonnement économique
en pensant que s'il y en a moins, c'est
plus cher et inversement, en fait la
sphère décisionnelle en Europe ne
comprend pas qu'on est déjà en train de
vivre un goulet d'étranglement à la sur
les combustibles fossiles mais qu'on ne
le voit pas par une hausse indéfinie des
prix. Voilà, c'est c'est ils comprennent
pas ça. Et de du coup euh bah il c'est
c'est juste ils sont pas idiots, c'est
juste ils ont pas regardé, ils ont pas
et voilà,
c'est sûr tout ça
qu'ils sont pas idiots. Ben évidemment
qu'ils sont pas idiots. Euh euh c'est
une affaire de formation à un moment il
faut juste avoir eu le temps de regarder
le temps de comprendre. Quand on leur
explique, il y a beaucoup de gens qui
disent "Ah bah oui, effectivement, je
comprends pas."
C'est pour ça que tu écris des BD.
C'est notamment pour ça que j'écris, je
coécris des BD parce que je dessine pas
moi. Très mal. Euh donc si j'en si j'en
si j'en reviens à la à la décision de la
voiture électrique, c'est pas une
réponse à la crainte de disposer de
moins de pétrole, c'est une réponse à il
faut faire notre part dans la baisse des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre. Alors
moi je pense que c'est une très bonne
idée de passer à la mobilité électrique
parce qu'effectivement dans un monde où
il y a que ce soit pour des raisons
climatiques ou pour des raisons
géologiques plus de pétrole, soyons
caricaturaux mais pour faire pour me
faire comprendre euh il va rester des
sources d'électricité décarbonées
dont on peut discuter de savoir lesquels
on arrive à faire vivre facilement dans
un monde sans pétrole précisément parce
que les énergies sont imbriquées
aujourd'hui. On a besoin
dans un monde sans pétrole et dans un
monde en guerre.
On a besoin de alors on va y venir après
une chose à une chose à la fois. Merci
bien, c'est très gentil. Quand tu auras
fini, tu donneras la parole à ton petit
voisin de gauche. D'accord. Ouais. Euh
mais euh c'est juste pour dire euh il va
rester de l'électricité décarbonée euh
probablement moins facile à obtenir que
l'idée qu'on s'en fait aujourd'hui, mais
c'est quand même ça qui va rester. Et
avec ça, on peut quand même faire de la
mobilité électrique. Mais comme je pense
que ça va être moins facile à obtenir
que l'idée qu'on s'en fait, je suis
personnellement favorable à de la petite
mobilité électrique. C'est-à-dire que ça
sera beaucoup plus facile de conserver
de la mobilité individuelle avec des
engins qui pèent pas lourds, des vélos
électriques, des petites voitures
électriques, des petits utilitaires
électriques et cetera, que à faire des
tanks électriques de 2 tonnes et demi.
Voilà, donc c'est une des raisons, je
pense que c'est un élément de sauvegarde
de stabilité sociale aujourd'hui que de
favoriser le déploiement de petits
véhicules électriques. Voilà.
Alors, petit complément sur la mobilité
du futur sans pétrole. Alors, c'est vrai
que ça nous projette assez loin parce
que entre-temps on pourrait
J'aimerais qu'on parle ensuite de
nucléaire. OK.
Faut passer par les data center et par
Elon Musk et tout ça. Exactement.
Euh le
moi je me dis quand même il y a un
moment même avec des voitures
électriques, on va quand même être un
peu embêté parce que plus de pétrole,
plus de bitum donc tuentretiens plus des
routes.
Bah VTT
euh plus de pétrole, plus de lubrifiant
ou alors va falloir lubrifier avec 150
faut trouver 150 millions de tonnes de
lubrifiant euh de l'huile de colza, je
ne sais pas de l'huile de palme pour
lubrifier les moteurs et toute la
machinerie industrielle.
Plus facile, c'est des vélos si des
voitur exactement.
Exactement.
C'est très vrai ce que tu dis. Tu sais
que on a une sonde qui est les commandes
industrielles de Grèce pour voir
l'indice de récession. Certes, il y a le
baril de pétrole mais on se renseigne
aussi sur les commandes de graisse.
Pas mal. Ouais. Ouais. Ça doit être un
précurseur intéressant et tu tout par du
Japon, c'est intéressant le la position
un peu de l'Allemagne du Japon
historiquement qui est où tu trouves ces
ces PME incroyable où il y a 300
personnes et qui ont 90 % de part de
marché de je sais pas quel truc qui
rentre dans je sais pas quelle machine
outil qui équipe je sais pas quel truc
de à la fin d'une Assyrie. Et c'est pour
ça que pendant des enfin jusqu'à
présent, ils arrivaient à à équiper, à
exporter bah dans les pays qui
s'industrialisaient, donc Chine d'abord
et puis Inde et puis quelques dragons
divers et variés et que aujourd'hui bah
ça façaille un peu parce que le taux
d'équipement aussi en usine et tout, il
est un peu en train de se calmer.
Peut-être on passe un peu à un pic aussi
de de croissance industrielle. Mais donc
du coup effectivement euh se dire que on
règleit le problème avec euh en ayant
les gig factory chez nous une ou deux
usines pour transformer ce qu'on appelle
les cames, pas la cam mais ça ressemble
un peu donc les cathodes trait d'
Matignon ou
les cathodes active materials donc non
mais c'est parce qu'en fait avant dans
il faut quand même mélanger des trucs
des sulfates de nickel de cobalt de
manganèise et tout
avec des des usines un peu ces et tout
et quand pour alimenter les g factory
parce qu'il y a pas que du lithium dans
les batteries lithium euh et se dire
Ensuite, on aurait en plus une
exploitation au milieu de l'allié et que
avec tout ça, on fait le ça fait la rue
Michel. Bah non, parce queen fait à un
moment faudra quand même entretenir nos
routes, refaire des pneus et même les
sièges de voiture et tout. Enfin, la
quantité de matériaux qu'embarque bah
les voitures et la manière dont on les
dont dont on les construit, dont on les
utilise et dont on les broie infiné. Et
bien c'est permis aussi par l'abondance
du du pétrole pas sous sa forme
énergétique mais aussi sous sa forme un
peu matérielle et des polymères qu'on
qu'on transforme un peu avant il finit
peut-être de les incinérer en toute fin
de vie. Et donc effectivement de se dire
moi j'arrive pas à comprendre comment on
passe juste à la voiture électrique sans
poser du tout de questions de modèle de
question par exemple de la propriété euh
et donc du partage de de ces de ces
véhicules. La question de leur durée de
vie un moteur thermique ça suse pas de
problème. Même malgré les les
lubrifiants, il y a des pièces qui
finissent par s'user et cetera. Donc au
bout d'un certain nombre de kilomètres,
bon plus ou moins selon que c'est
essence au diesel, il va il va il va
falloir le le le jeter. Un moteur
électrique, je vais pas dire que c'est
inusisable mais
c'est ça peut avoir une durée de vie
vraiment très très importante. Faut
pas qu'il a de choc pour la batterie.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'une bagnole Oui.
Alors pas les batteries ou parce que les
batteries elles dureront moins mais la
voiture elle-même, la carcasse entre
guillemets, le le enfin ça pourrait
durer. Pourquoi est-ce que les tramoins,
les trains ça dure 30 ans, 40 ans, les
avions et cetera et pourquoi les
voitures ça dure 10 quoi ou 10 ou 15.
Donc il y a plein de questions qui
pourraient se poser comme ça pour
finalement faire une sobriété
effectivement de matériaux et donc avec
des des objets bien plus petits parce
que effectivement 2 tonnes pour
transporter 150 kg ou 100 kg c'est quand
même pas génial génial
on voit que c'est pas que des ingénieurs
qui ont bossé là-dessus sinon ça serait
plus optimisé et puis effectivement la
la question énergétique évidemment qui
qui va avec donc
mais oui effectivement la la poussée
elle est bien réglementaire elle est pas
c'est pas le marché qui a voulu ses
voitures électriques.
Euh et puis voilà, il y a pas encore
tout à fait d'équilibre entre les
voitures thermiques, les voitures
électriques. Donc c'est bien c'est bien
une histoire de décarbonation, mais la
question c'est de se poser aucune
question euh sur la sobriété de de
l'objet mais même sur la sobriété des
kilomètres parcourus hein. Quand tu
prends la la stratégie nationale bas
carbone, alors la nouvelle mouture là,
j'ai l'impression qu'elle a du mal à
sortir parce que ça
bou elle est en consultation, ça y est.
Mais tu ça injecte très très peu de de
notions de sobriété un peu systémique
quoi. C'est-à-dire de dire est-ce qu'on
n pas un plan d'organisation du
territoire, un plan de de maillage
commercial, culturel, sportif, de la
question des des emplois versus là où on
habite et cetera pour pour freiner
quelque part le nombre de kilomètres
parcourus parce que ce nombre de il ne
baisse pas voir il augmente légèrement
et en plus bah dans des embouteillages
et avec tous les éléments sur la santé
et tout ça que ça peut créer. Et donc
ces questionsl on se les pose pas. Donc
on est juste effectivement dans un volet
technique de la décarbonation.
Jean-Marc, quand tu regardes le journal
télévisé, ça t'arrive ?
Oui.
Qu'est-ce qui te fait pesté quand ça
parle de ton sujet ?
Ah euh alors moi ce qui me fait pester
d'une
ensuite la même question.
Ce qui me fait pester le plus souvent en
fait c'est pas tel traitement de tel
point particulier, c'est problème de la
cohérence d'ensemble.
Euh c'est-à-dire que c'est absolument,
ça ne gêne aucun JT de parler à 10
minutes des problèmes qui se sont passé
à Valence et à 25 minutes de montrer des
Français qui sont partis regarder les
baleines à la Réunion avec de mer
évidemment en avion. Euh c'est-à-dire
que euh
on on parle de de on se lamente d'un
problème dont on enens la cause euh pas
plus tard que je crois qu'il y a une
citation célèbre de je crois de Bossuet
non où qui reprend exactement cette
voilà. Euh donc c'est plutôt ça moi qui
me ce qui me fait pester, c'est qu'on ne
donne pas à la personne qui regarde le
JT la clé de lecture pour essayer
d'avoir une vision cohérente du problème
dans lequel on comprend bien les
contreparties aux choses qu'on fait. Euh
voilà, c'est ça que c'est ça que j'ai
envie de dire qui me fait le plus qui
qui me chagrine le plus.
Philippe
al jeou je regarde pas beaucoup les les
JT. Alors je je regarde des commentaires
autour de de peut-être de de petites
apparitions ici et là dans les dans les
JT. Mais d'abord voilà, il y a quand
même une grande diversité de qualité de
rédaction, on pourrait dire de donc euh
grande diversité.
Oui. Bah
c'est pas un peu standardisé ?
Non, dans le sens bah tu vois tu as
quand même des endroits où il y a plus
souvent des climatosceptiques
qu'ailleurs. Tu as quand même voilà
hein. Bah je sais pas c'est news
ils font pas de git enfin c'est
oui alors c'est si vous appelez pas
c'est un GT. Ouais je sais pas. Ouais
oui c'est un G. Oui. Non mais alors si
on prend le standard, voilà un peu TF1
machin. Bon,
vous avez entendu les dernières
déclarations de Trump concernant ça ?
Concernant les truc dernières en rond de
des écologistes, des réchauffistes
et que en fait il ça les ennuie et que
il y a d'autres explications. Le côté
climatosceptique de Trump. Non, j'ai vu
que l'administration Biden faisait tout
pour rassurer les débuts de la COP 29 à
Bakou en disant "Messi, de toute façon,
vous inquiétez pas, on sortira pas de
l'accord euh euh des accords qu'on qu'on
a signé ou qu'on va signer.
Mais non, j'ai après bah oui, le
problème c'est que c'est c'est l'état du
débat démocratique. Et moi ce qui
m'inquiète le plus avec ce sujet des
États-Unis pour revenir encore un peu,
c'est que bah grosso modo l'Europe elle
suit quand même à peu près ce qui se
passe aux États-Unis avec quelques je
sais pas 5 à 10 ans de décalage quoi.
Cette espèce de règle là, elle continue
un peu à marcher et on a vu un peu bah
finalement cette cette alors je dis pas
que les débats politiques des années 80
ou des années 70 étaient parfait hein.
Je suis pas en train d'encenser le le
passé mais bon ça ça a atteint un niveau
quand même assez assez faiblard
aujourd'hui et et on est que dans la
petite phrase dans la punchline et c'est
difficile d'avoir ce qu'il a dit c'est
les oliennes ça sert pas à grand-chose
ça tue les oiseaux le solaire tous les
10 ans il faut changer les panneaux euh
al c'est vrai que ça tue les oiseaux he
alors effectivement les éoliennes les
les éoliennes oui les chauve-souris euh
les éoliennes malheureusement oui ça tue
des chauve-souris le coût du méga water
de l'éolienne coûte une fortune.
Alors, il y a un truc qui est
intéressant à regarder aux États-Unis,
c'est ce qui s'est passé au Texas. Le
Texas est un état pétrolier. Par
ailleurs, le Texas est un état
républicain, assez républicain et c'est
un des États où l'éolien s'est le plus
développé aux États-Unis. Donc, je pense
que c'est une très bonne illustration du
fait que
les grand les les punchlin du président
américain en fait n'ont pas beaucoup
d'importance
sur ce qui peut se passer. euh en
pratique euh dans un pays dans lequel
dollarisk King et donc en fait si jamais
il y a un intérêt économique à
développer les ENR, ils développeront
les ENR et cet intérêt économique il
peut exister soit chez eux pour leur
propre réseau, soit à l'exportation
parce que ils ont envie d'en fournir
d'autres et c'est avant tout ça qui va
guider les États-Unis. Euh beaucoup plus
que je pense quelques déclarations à
l'emporte-pièce de leur nouveaux
président devant un micro.
Mais d'ailleurs Exon Non mais c'est le
patron d'Xon là qui a fait une sortie
justement tour ou alors le patron d'on
il a dit un truc très marrant pas plus
tard que il y a 2 jours ou ou il a dit
je pense que ça serait une erreur de
sortir des accords de enfin de l'accord
de Paris le patron de Woods là le patron
d'XON et la raison pour laquelle il dit
ça c'est que l'administration Biden lui
a promis quelques dizaines de milliards
de dollars ou lui a facilité la vie plus
exactement pour qu'il puisse investir
quelques dizaines de milliards mil de
dollars dans un processus qu'on appelle
la capture et séquestration du CO2 et
également dans de la production
d'hydrogène. Et apparemment le patron de
Chevron
lui a emboîé le pas, c'est il a dit
exactement la même chose. Donc c'est
bien ce que je dis dollaris king quoi.
Donc à un moment euh il va y avoir une
forme de réal politique. Et Woods a
également dit le stop and go sur le le
le comment dire les orientations
politiques, c'est très mauvais pour le
business. Nous on a besoin de stabilité.
Donc en fait, je pense qu'il va se
passer aux États-Unis exactement ce qui
s'est passé en Europe sur la question de
la voiture électrique. Justement, dans
un premier temps, les constructeurs ont
beugler comme dévau en disant "Ah,
qu'est-ce que vous nous emmerdez à nous
obliger à à vendre autre chose ?" Et
puis une fois que on commence à faire
les investissements, qu'on cadre le
marché et cetera, s'il est question de
changer des règles encore une fois, là
pour le coup, il bugle comme dévau dans
l'autre sens en disant "Ah bah écoutez,
non maintenant c'est bon, le coût est
parti, vous allez pas maintenant nous
expliquer que il va falloir qu'on fasse
autre chose." Donc c'est et je pense
qu'aux États-Unis, il y a quelque chose
de même nature. C'est-à-dire qu'à un
moment les gens investissent, les gens
se mettent en ordre de bataille pour
faire des choses et si on leur dit tous
les quatre matins, "A ben non, mais
finalement paf, on rechange les règles."
C'est quelque chose qui les déstabilise
beaucoup plus que qu'autre chose. Sans
compter encore une fois qu'aucune des
deux administrations, ni celle de Biden,
ni celle de Trump, ni celle de Haïti et
cetera, ne fait de véritables misères
aux pétroliers sur leur métier primaire,
c'est-à-dire d'extraire du pétrole.
Philippe, les panneaux solaires qu'on
est obligé de changer tous les 10 ans,
de nettoyer avec des kilos de flotte,
des litre de flotte, qu'est-ce que tu en
penses ? C'est viable, c'est pas viable,
c'est un caprice, c'est pas un caprice,
c'est un bon complément au cas où ? Ça
fait partie d'un bon mix énergétique.
C'est bien.
Ah
oui, c'est je me suis peut-être retrouvé
à gauche ou à droite dans une ou deux
émissions où il y avait beaucoup de
scepticisme sur les éoliennes et les
panneaux solaires parce qu'effectivement
moi, comme je suis arrivé où a raison
euh moitié à tort dans le sens moitié
moitié à raison. Oui, parce que en fait
moi comme je suis arrivé à ces questions
là par la matérialité, par les par les
ressources, voilà et quand j'ai commencé
à écrire, on était par exemple sur des
panneaux multicouches avec de l'indium,
du galium, du sélénium, des trucs qui
permettaaient de récupérer, d'avoir un
rendement donc une un taux de
récupération de de l'énergie incidente
solaire bien plus élevé et cetera. Et
donc moi je racontais que toutes ces
ressources rares, ça allait pas le
faire. Alors aujourd'hui
arrêter de le mettre dans le shampoing
le sénium, c'est ça ?
Alors non mais aujourd' panneaux
solaires, tu as Oui. Alors on peut
parler de shampoing après. Je l'utilise
plus trop moi. Mais euh le dans les pan
solaires aujourd'hui c'est c'est des
panneaux un peu basiques. Donc c'est on
va dire c'est de l'acier, de
l'aluminium, du verre pour les parties
structurelles, du silicium. Le silicium,
si on simplifie, c'est 27 % de la croûte
terrestre mais en fait c'est très
simplifié parce qu'en réalité je crois
que c'est dans une seule mine des
États-Unis qu'on récupère le quartz
suffisamment pur pour faire du silicium
de qualité photovoldaïque ou
électronique. Non, c'est pas ça. Alors,
je crois que c'est pour je sais pas qui
appartient àis
il me semble que c'est pour faire les
creusées réfractaires dans lesquels on
coule les lingots de silicium le
les wiffers là les
il me semble je sais je
en tout cas il y a plein de trucs de
toute façon pour produire un truc tu vas
chercher des ressources de partout et
tout ça est déjà très très mondialisé et
avec de toute façon des des entreprises
qui sont soit soit nationales soit soit
soit très multinational
mais du coup le le pour moi le enfin si
tu prends de manière un peu brute si je
puis dire avec les rendements
aujourd'hui que tu as sur un panneau
solaire. D'une certaine manière, faut
mieux avoir un panneau solaire qu'un
arbre que tu vas brûler dans un four
pour faire de la biomasse, quoi.
Parce que bah la photosynthèse, ça doit
être entre 0 vir quelque chose et 1 %.
Ouais, c'est un peu moins de 1 %. Ouais.
Voilà. Solaire, c'est 22, c'est ça.
Et le panneau solaire ? Ouais. Non, en
commercial 15 20. Ouais. Non,
ça dépend où il est. En Allemagne, c'est
pas 22 hein.
Voilà.
Mais donc tuas tu as un peu dans habité,
mais c'est quand même beaucoup mieux. en
Arabie Saoudite. Oui, c'est même plus
que ça.
Moi ce que je trouve embêtant, ce que je
trouve embêtant dans le dans dans
l'approche qu'on a aujourd'hui, c'est
qu'en fait on a dans le dans les
énergies renouvelables la même approche
qu'on a dans dans le reste de de bah de
de toute l'industrie et des services.
C'est-à-dire, il faut gagner il faut
gagner sur les il faut avoir des trucs
avec des grosses des grosses échelles
pour gagner en productivité, pour
réduire la quantité de travail humain et
gagner et faire abaisser les coûts. Or,
du coup, qu'est-ce qui se passe avec des
des des éoliennes ou avec des des
panneaux solaires ? Les éoliennes, faut
aller les visiter de temps en temps,
hein, pour aller bah graisser peut-être,
je sais pas, réparer deux trois trucs,
vérifier que tout va bien, que
l'électronique de puissance fonctionne
comme il faut et puis les panneaux
solaires, bah ouais, il faut quand même
aller faire un peu la même chose aussi.
Il y a des onduleurs à les vérifier. Il
y a faut peut-être un peu les nettoyer.
Ouais, parce qu'il perdent peut-être un
peu en rendement. Tu as un peu de sable
du Sahara qui est tombé dessus avec la
dernière pluie, que sais-je ? Bon et et
ben quand tu te déplaces du coup voilà,
soit tu te déplaces pour aller voir 10
m² par 100 m² par là sur un hangar et je
sais pas quoi. Soit tu te déplaces et tu
dis tiens, je vais faire un truc qui va
faire 1000 hectares, c'est cool quoi.
Voilà. Et aujourd'hui, malheureusement
les projets qui sortent sont des projets
avec de la course. Enfin, il y a un peu
tout. Je pense qu'il y a il y a des
des petits propriétaires privés qui
finissent par s'équiper, qui sautent le
pas, qui écoutent Jean-Marc, qui disent
la BD machin et puis disent "Ouais, je
vais mettre des panneaux sur mon toit."
Bon, ça c'est OK. et puis ils font pas
chaleur dans le jardin et puis après
mais mais tu as surtout des des sujets
très industriels et où du coup on se
retrouve avec de la compétition quelque
part de d'usage des sols. Alors des fois
il y en a pas hein. Ça peut être couvrir
un couvrir un parking. Tu vois le
parking était déjà artificialisé. Tu vas
faire une ombrillage sur le parking.
C'est ça peut être quelques centaines de
mètres carrés quelques mètres carrés. Ça
intéresse des gens. C'est super. Euh
mais des fois ça va être sur une forêt
ou ça va être sur des terres agricoles.
On voit arriver c'est un peu cette cet
agroltaïme
qui dont on dit "Ah ben c'est super,
vous inquiétez pas, on va mettre des
moutons, à pêtre à côté et puis tout va
bien pour la biodiversité." Et je pense
qu'en fait non, ça vient perturber euh
euh des températures au sol, ça vient
perturber euh la manière dont l'eau
s'écoule. Je pense que c'est pas neutre
tout ça. Et et hélas voilà, on a cette
approche très économique, hein. Je je
comprends les acteurs qui le font, mais
à la fin c'est c'est c'est problématique
parce que les paramètres économiques
dans lesquels on on joue amènent à à ces
à ces énormes projets qui sont, je
trouve pas très pas résilients, pas très
territorialisé, même si on dit les
énergies renouvelables, c'est super,
c'est territorial. Bah non, c'est
territorial de rien du tout quoi. Tu as
trois qu multinationales mondiales qui
savent gérer ça. Euh euh les experts,
ils viennent de partout. Euh les pièces
détachées sont fabriquées par de PME à
l'autre bout du monde et puis à la fin,
tu as des espèces de d'énormes trucs
avec des zones logistiques portuaires et
puis euh trois gars qui viennent faire
la maintenance. Ça a rien de
territorialisé. Et donc c'est ça qui est
dommage je trouve, c'est qu'on a un peu
comme pour les voitures en fait, on n
pas on on exploite pas toute la gamme
possible de des réflexions qu'on devrait
avoir là-dessus en disant on commence
par équiper l'espace bâti, on commence
par un paquet de RD sur comment
faire des toits qui font à la fois
étanchéité et et et panneaux solaires,
enfin et l'intégration dans le bâti,
discuter avec les architectes des
bâtiments de France, euh voilà,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des trois parisiens
? Est-ce qu'on les remplace par des
panneaux photovoltaïques partout ?
Voilà, on n pas ces questions là et en
fait on est un peu à la vas-y que je te
pousse. Et donc voilà, on a des panneaux
qui sortent, c'est bien, il y a une
courbe d'apprentissage et de baisse des
coûts parce qu'évidemment maintenant
c'est comme ils sont tous produits en
Chine, bah ça a beaucoup baissé par
rapport à quand ils étaient produits à
Grenoble ou ailleurs et puis voilà et on
installe des milliers d'hectares mais
sans se poser tant que ça de questions
je trouve. Et puis avec la question
d'après, alors c'est pas 10 ans parce
que là Trump exagère un peu mais oui,
une éolienne offshore, je pense qu'au
bout de 20 25 ans elle a fait sa durée
de vie quoi. Donc donc l'effort
d'installation et de subvention qu'on
est en train de faire, bah il va falloir
la refaire tous les 25 ans. Le monde
s'arrête pas en 2045 parce que voilà et
non seulement faudra monter encore en
puissance et et en croissance de de ce
qui est équipé, enfin de ce qui est
installé, mais il faudra en plus
remplacer l'existant au fur et à mesure.
25 ans, c'est demain.
Oui. Bah oui. Voilà. avant de de vous
lancer sur l'uranium euh les fusées
Mars, Oui. Non, pour finir là-dessus,
euh j'aimerais quand même euh moi qui
est souvent qui suis souvent accusé
d'être un grand ennemi des énergies
renouvelables, j'aimerais quand même
rappeler que euh certes non, j'aimerais
quand même rappeler qu'on va pas avoir
de solutions faciles dans cette
histoire, hein. Donc, je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec Philippe sur le fait
que euh on on s'économise à tort de se
poser des questions un peu désagréables.
Mais il faut bien voir quand même qu'il
y a pas de baguette magique
euh dans cette histoire. Donc même si on
se posait les questions désagréables,
peut-être qu'on ferait presque la même
chose. Euh voilà. Mais il faut se les
poser de toute façon. Il faut se les
poser. Et quand on parle de durabilité,
on parle pas de durabilité sur 20 ans.
Euh si on construit un système
énergétique qui est durable, il faut que
ça dure des siècles. Euh voilà. Et
aujourd'hui, est-ce que ça va durer des
siècles ce qu'on est en train de faire ?
On s'est pas posé la question. Euh et
c'est il y a probablement des
sous-ensembles du système qu'on essaie
de construire. où la réponse est
probablement non.
J'en profite. Euh vos haters, vos
détracteurs euh il vous reprochent quoi
?
Bah moi, c'est public, il suffit d'aller
lire les commentaires sous les posts que
je fais sur LinkedIn ou faire gagner 5
minutes et 500 kW.
Non, parce que je je les lis pas. Je
l'ai alors les commentaires sous mes
posts à moi sur LinkedIn, j'essaie quand
même de les lire. Euh si j'ai le temps,
j'essaie d'y répondre. Après, les
commentaires qui sont faits sous les
postes des autres qui parleraient de
moi, ça je les vois pas toujours. Euh
voilà. Et les commentaires qui sont
faits sous les vidéos où je peux
apparaître, je les regarde pas tous. Euh
il y en a une partie que je regarde pas.
Résumer trivialement, c'est quoi ?
Résumer trivialement ou succintement,
c'est quoi ?
C'est tu es un ami, tu racontes
n'importe quoi, il y a d'autres
solutions.
Je t'écoute.
Bah, c'est toujours le contrepied de ce
qu'on peut dire. Donc il y a une partie
des gens pour lesquels ce qui leur pose
problème, c'est que je leur dise que je
crois pas à la croissance perpétuelle.
Il y a une partie des gens pour lesquels
ce qui leur pose problème, c'est que je
c'est c'est presque un sous-ensemble du
premier, c'est que je ne crois pas au
maintien de la civilisation industrielle
avec juste des renouvelables ou plus
exactement je ne crois pas à la
civilisation industrielle telle qu'elle
s'est présente à nous aujourd'hui.
D'accord ? On on on ne jettera pas bas
notre héritage de connaissance.
celui-là, on va le conserver. Même si
une partie de ses connaissances
aujourd'hui c'est des octa sur des
disques durs et qu'on n'est pas sûr de
conserver des disques durs, enfin ou les
mémoires flash ou whatever,
il y a quand même un acquis un acquis
technique dans la compréhension du
monde, dans la capacité à concevoir des
systèmes complexes et cetera que la que
la que l'énergie fossile nous a amené et
ça il y en a une partie pour un temps au
moins, on va ça va pas complètement
disparaître en en une semaine. Par
contre, un argument que je mets souvent
en avant, alors ça qui énerve beaucoup
de partisans dans le monde des
renouvelables, est de dire dans l'ancien
temps des génies, il y en a eu plein,
Mozart était un génie absolu. Je veux
dire, je sais pas s'il y a eu de nouveau
un musicien capable de composer des
symphonies à 5 ans depuis depuis Mozart.
Euh Archimède était un génie absolu,
Newton, enfin, je veux dire, on en a
plein des génies absolus et tous ces
génies absolus, donc avec nos ancêtres
qui étaient pas plus con que nous, ils
ont jamais été capables de faire émerger
une civilisation industrielle comme
l'actuelle dans un monde 100 %
renouvelable. Ils ont été capables de
faire de la protoindustrie euh parfois
très sophistiquée. Ils ont été capables
de faire des choses qui aujourd'hui
encore reste inexpliqué. Euh bah les
pyramides euh les acduc qui avaient 4 m
de chute sur 1 km d'ACduc. Enfin tout un
tas de trucs qui sur lesquels en fait
c'est des proesses techniques et des
proesses technologiques extraordinaires
qu'on tenu des moyens de l'époque. Euh
donc ils ont été capables de faire des
choses absolument extraordinaires et la
muraille de Chine a une époque où enfin
voilà. Donc il il y a vraiment eu des
choses mais ils ont pas fait la
civilisation industrielle où chacun a
une bagnole, où on a le chauffage
central partout, où on a des
smartphones, des ordinateurs et des
caméras pour Finkerview quoi. Tout ça
ils ont pas fait. Et donc la bonne
question à se poser, c'est est-ce qu'ils
ont pas fait parce qu'ils étaient cons
ou est-ce qu'ils ont pas fait parce que
c'est matériellement impossible de faire
dans un monde avec juste des
renouvelables ? Et personnellement, je
suis plutôt partisan de la deuxième
explication. C'estàd qu'on peut faire
des tas de choses très avancées, mais il
y a des trucs qu'on pourra vraiment pas
faire dans ce monde-là. Et aujourd'hui,
alors Philippe l'a dit d'une certaine
manière, moi je vais le rappeler d'une
autre manière. Aujourd'hui, une éolienne
ou un panneau solaire est un objet
industriel comme un autre.
Donc dans notre monde industriel dopé au
combustible fossile, quand on décide
d'en faire beaucoup, on fait baisser les
coûts et jusque- là, il y a rien
d'extraordinaire. La bonne question à
laquelle personne n'a la réponse,
j'insiste, personne n'a la réponse,
c'est dans un monde dans lequel il y
aurait plus que des éoliennes et des
panneaux solaires, combien on est
capable de produire en nombre
d'éoliennes et de panneaux solaires ?
Bon, et ça et et combien ça coûte ?
Personne n'a la réponse à cette
question. Les outils qu'on a à notre
disposition ne permettent pas de
répondre à cette question. Ils ne le
permettent pas. Et donc les gens qui
disent "Moi, je pense que c'est
possible, c'est la foi du charbonnier
contre la foi du charbonier de Jean
Covici qui dit "Moi, en regardant le
passé, je pense que c'est pas possible."
Voilà.
C'est quand même très problématique ce
que tu dis.
Bah, c'est comme ça.
Voilà. Donc ça c'est une deuxième
catégorie de gens avec lesquels il y a
parfois des frictions dans le débat
public, c'est-à-dire des gens qui
aimeraient bien ce que moi je crois
impossible, c'est-à-dire que on
maintienne une civilisation industrielle
dans un monde où il n'y aurait que des
énergies renouvelables à notre
disposition. Alors je dis pas que dans
cette civilisation là où on aurait que
des ENR, on pourrait plus rien faire. Je
sais pas si on aurait une espérance de
vie à la naissance de 30 ans comme
c'était le cas en 1800 ou si elle
resterait à 65 ou 70 ou 75 ans. J'en
sais rien tous ces trucs là. Je dis
juste ça ressemblerait pas à ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui. Voilà, c'est ça j'en suis
absolument persuadé.
Alors, je reviens à la question
d'origine qui était est-ce qu'on a des
haters et qu'est-ce qui nous reproche ?
He c'est ça. Bon, moi j'ai pas de haters
he je suis parce que comme on je pas
dans la même cours je suis moins connu
et donc il y a pas de gens qui ont
besoin de se faire de la promo sur mon
dos. Donc moi, j'ai éventuellement des
quelques détracteurs ou des gens qui
critiquent ou c'est plutôt pas sûr que
ce soit que des gens qui besoin de ce
soir. Je pense qu'il y a aussi des gens
qui sont sincèrement euh
Oui oui oui. Bon voilà ça.
Pardon. Ouais. Donc donc moi j'en fait
mo on se rejoint sur le diagnostic de la
de quelque part de la non soutenabilité
de de du système industriel dans lequel
on estime mais qui est effectivement
quand même extrêmement gâcheur aussi.
Moi c'est plutôt bah oui en fait si on
me reprochait des choses, je pensais
plutôt d'être un peu un douveur quoi.
c'est d'être un peu utopiste en fait
parce que bah moi je sur ce côté j'ai le
de dire que on va pouvoir faire une
civilisation où on va produire des
objets moins compliqués qu'on va les
faire durer qu'on va les réparer qu'on
va je sais pas quoi mieux partager
intensifier l'usage finalement de du
patrimoine bâti industriel et d'objets
qu'on a autour de nous un peu toutes ces
idées de de sobriété et puis que bah
finalement bah non ça marche pas parce
que pour 1000 raisons ça marchera pas ça
marchera pas parce qu'il y aura pas
d'anigement démocratique ça marchera pas
parce que d'un point de géopolitique que
c'est difficile parce que il y a des
questions d'échelle et cetera. Par
contre, moi je pense enfin moi je suis
peut-être plus pessimiste que toi. Je
remarque sur un truc, c'est bien sûr
qu'on va pas revenir à l'âge des
cavernes avec les décroissants, les
trucs, les pot de bête parce que
entre-temps, on a trouvé des trucs et je
pense même qu'on pourrait se dire assez
simplement euh que alors hors famine et
je sais pas quoi mais en on va dire en
en régime de croisière en l'an 3000, je
ne sais pas, imaginons qu'on est arrivé
à l'ance prochaine dans de la
science-fiction de de long terme pour se
pas se se se déconnecter peut-être du du
quotidien qui reste important évidemment
mais euh
tu crois vraiment qu'on va
la question non mais la question toi toi
Toi et nous non, ça c'est sûr. On verra
3000. Non, on verra pas 3000. Non non
non mais mais le le
je pense pas que tu tu enfin la question
de l'espérance de vie par exemple, tu
retombes pas à 30 ans parce qu'en fait
l'espérance de vie c'est c'est la notion
mathématique qui fait que tu as un gamin
sur deux en dessous de 4 ans qui meurt
euh de la variole ou d'autres choses et
et donc après une fois que tu as passé
ces 4 ans là tu vas à 40 50 60 quoi. Et
puis quand tu comptes ceux qu' on 25 ans
et qui partent parce que c'est le c'est
le puné, c'est le cadet qui a pas qui a
pas pu reprendre la petite activité
agricole de son père, bah lui il s'est
engagé pour les colonies ou pour les
trucs et puis al lui il a sur dans la
marine royale, il a il a 2 ans
d'espérance de vie. Donc si tu enlèves
un peu tous ces trucs là, tu tu reviens
quand même déjà un peu plus et il y a
quand même quelques trucs. On peut
espérer al les antibiotiques même si
effectivement maintenant il y a des
questions de résistance et notamment à
cause de de l'élevage intensif mais
voilà la question de des vaccins et
cetera, je pense qu'il y a quand même
quelques trucs de base de vie, on a
découvert des trucs, les microbes et
machins. Donc pas sûr qu'on viendrait à
30 ans. contre là où je suis hyper
pessimiste peut-être par rapport à toi,
c'est que on a une base de connaissance
un peu un peu dingue qui nous
permettrait même en abattant
effectivement assez fortement la
question énergétique ou de consommation
de ressources permettrait quand même de
continuer à faire un certain nombre de
choses. Voilà, parce qu'on a une
connaissance des matériaux, des des
transformations, de des rendements, des
machines, des moteurs, des machines
tournantes, de l'électronique. Voilà, il
y a pas mal de trucs qu'on qu'on
pourrait continuer à faire. Mais je
trouve que la la la connaissance, elle
est en fait hyper morcelée et elle est
pas facile du tout à maintenir. Et moi
ce qui me fait le plus délirer, on va
passer du côté aux États-Unis, c'est un
peu le côté survivaliste de des
milliardaires de la tech là qui il y
avait il y avait la mode, c'était de
s'acheter un ranch avec le plus
d'hectares possible en
Nouvelle-Zélélande. Alors c'est assez
marrant parce qu'à Nouvelle-Zélande,
c'est un endroit effectivement un peu
safe parce que il y a pas trop de de il
y a pas trop de monde effectivement.
Oui, c'est dans l'hémisphère sud. Donc
s'il y a une guerre atomique dans
l'hémisphère nord, ils seront pas
concernés.
Ils sont planqués. Mais il faut savoir
il faut savoir que que
il faut savoir que d'un point de vue
géologique sur le long terme, d'un point
de vue des sols sur le long terme, il y
a pas pire que la Nouvelle-Zélande en
fait. Il crevaient de faim les maoris et
c'est pour ça qu'il y avait d'ailleurs
des mécanismes de cannibalisme et tout
parce qu'en fait c'est c'est une terre
qui est très très pauvre, qui produit
très peu. Donc si tu as plus les
systèmes un peu bronnés par le par les
tu es pas génial génial quoi. Tu reviens
un peu au calib. Alors, j'aimerais voir
un peu les héritiers de l'an 3000 de de
Zuckerberg, de Mark Anderson et et
quelques autres en train de se bouffer
entre eux en Nouvelle-Zélande. Bon, mais
surtout alors maintenant là, ils sont
plus trop sur la Nouvelle-Zélande leur
nouveau truc, c'est les îles à Hawaï ou
ailleurs, chacun la sienne là, je crois
que donc avec bunker, machin, salle de
bain, réserve d'eau, puit et cetera.
Mais en fait, ce truc-là, ça ça marche
euh un mois et demi, quoi. Enfin, je
veux dire, dans un monde euh post euh je
sais pas quoi, postcroissance, post
pétrole, post que poste que ce qu'on
veut. Mais en fait, il y a un moment bah
tuas il faut aller déboucher les
toilettes, tu as la pompe de relevage
qui marche plus, tu as et là il te faut
des gens qui qui savent faire ça et tu
peux pas en fait concentrer. Alors tu
peux avoir un homme à tout faire, une
femme à tout faire qui sait faire
quelques trucs et qui est très bricolo,
je veux bien. Tu vois, tu peux en
employer 10, tu peux en employer 20, tu
peux en employer 50, mais après il faut
les nourrir effectivement sur ton île et
puis surtout il y a un moment où tu peux
pas transmettre. Qu'est-ce qui fait
aujourd'hui qu'ils peuvent se balader
avec des yautes, avec des hélicoptères
et cetera ? Il y a des ingénieurs qui
conçoivent des trucs, il y en a d'autres
qui sont spécialistes en traitement
thermique et cetera. Et tous ces
gens-là, qu'est-ce qu'ils ont ? Ils ont
des rêves, ils ont des envies, ils
veulent que leurs enfants fassent des
études et puis que ils aient une vie
agréable et cetera. Et en fait, du coup,
tout le système en fait, il faut une
pyramide de fonctionnement et une
pyramide de croissance avec plein de
gens qui chacun ont leur petite
carrière, leur petites vie, leur petit
truc. Je dis petite, je je ne méprise
pas en disant ça, j'en fais partie. Mais
et et que tout le savoir et la capacité
organisationnelle et bien elle est elle
est morcelée, elle fonctionne à travers
des organisations qui finalement alors
bah peuvent déposer le bilan et cetera.
Alors je suis je suis je suis je suis
reformulé autrement. Je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec toi sur le fait que
l'abondance énergétique condition le le
la la la dimension du flux énergétique
dimensionne la complexité et la taille
des organisations qu'on est capable de
maintenir. Ça je suis tout à fait
d'accord. Mais ce que je voulais dire
tout à l'heure c'est qu'on repassera pas
à zéro question acquis de connaissance.
Et donc il reste il restera des choses.
Voilà, c'était juste ça que Mais quel
quel est le talon qui reste ? Ça, j'en
sais rien. Mais il restera des choses.
Petite expérience de pensée là tous les
trois. Imaginez-vous que l'intelligence
artificielle alliée à des petits robots
ayant un pouce opposable,
ça va peut-être remplacer celui qui va
déboucher les toilettes, relever la
pompe de relevage ou des choses comme
ça. Maintenir le robot,
ça le remplacera si le robot est
connecté à un système de connaissance,
de gestion de la connaissance qui
lui-même suppose toujours une forme de
mondialisation et cetera. Donc en fait,
c'est ça s'inscrit. Il y a Cédric Vadi
qui est passé ici, je crois. Euh Vilan ?
Oui, il est passé plusieurs fois. Oui,
très
euh il a il a une définition de
l'intelligence artificielle que je
trouve très marrante et que je trouve
assez bonne. Euh il dit enfin en tout
cas je l'ai entendu dire ça dans une
conférence qu'il a faite. Il dit
l'intelligence artificielle c'est tous
les développements informatiques non
encore aboutis qui sont porteurs de
promesses qui peuvent permettre de faire
le buzz et d'alimenter tous les rêves.
Et je trouve que c'est pas mal comme
définition.
C'est pas un peu une can une canne
numérique pour politique ça ? Et il dit
non parce que il dit une fois que c'est
un il y a un truc qui fonctionne sur un
sujet précis, ça s'appelle une
application, ça s'appelle plus de
l'intelligence artificielle. Donc le
moteur de recherche par exemple
aujourd'hui ça s'appelle pas de
l'intelligence artificielle. C'est un
truc qui fonctionne auquel on est
habitué qui a un usage bien précis et
cetera et on nppelle pas ça de
l'intelligence artificielle. qu'on
pourrait très bien. C'est intelligent au
sens où ça trouve un truc,
ça trouve en général ce qu'on cherche.
Donc ça marche. Oh si, globalement ça
marche plutôt bien. Donc
moi quand je tape dans un moteur de
recherche que je veux des images de
chaîne, c'est rare que
de chaîne, oui, l'arbre de chaîne, c'est
rare que ça me sorte une image de
pantoufle ou un poisson rouge. Enfin, je
veux dire, le truc globalement marche
assez bien, quoi. Euh, mais ça s'appelle
une application, ça s'appelle plus
voilà. pour des applications précises.
Oui. Oui. Et donc et donc et donc je et
donc je trouve ça et maintenant un
logiciel de reconnaissance de quelque
chose, ça s'appelle pas de
l'intelligence artificielle, ça
s'appelle un logiciel de reconnaissance
de machin. Donc je trouve que sa
définition est assez bonne.
Qu'est-ce que tu utilises comme
intelligence artificielle ? Rien rien à
ma connaissance mais peut-être des
chosas déjà utilisé
mais peut-être des choses.
GPT ?
Non, j'ai jamais utilisé de chat GPT.
Crooc ?
Non.
Non plus.
Non. J'utilise des moteurs de recherche,
ça oui.
Lequel ?
Euh bon plusieurs, ça dépend. Voilà. Et
puis je fais pas de pub ici. Euh mais
euh pas besoin
euh mais par contre je je trouve que
cette définition encore une fois donc de
l'intelligence artificielle est est
assez bonne. Bon
Philippe le pouce oppos voulais revenir
sur Ouais, je voulais revenir sur le
pouce opposable avec évidemment le le le
buzz du du robot Optimus de Tesla et là
maintenant il te sert des cocktails dans
des barres. Alors on est tous en train
de se on réveille en fait les vieilles
lunes de l'humanité. En gros, c'est
l'abondance euh l'abondance dans
l'oisiveté tant qu'à faire l'immortalité
d'acquisition de connaissance. C'estd
que toi tu regardes les robots qui font
des cocktails dans les barres,
nous on regarde les robots avec prise de
décision pour aller tuer les gens à la
frontière.
Ah oui, mais oui, mais figure-toi
qu'évidemment c'est si l'un permet
l'autre en fait parce qu'évidemment
c'est le c'est le robot fantasin, c'est
c'est la silicone vallée, elle naît,
elle fonctionne et elle vit encore
aussi. Alors sur des apports de capitaux
euh effectivement des chalants qui sont
attirés par des belles promesses mais
aussi et surtout par des programmes
sonnants et trébucht
de du programme militaro industriel
américain. Enfin c'est c'est sûr. Donc
le le Boston Dynamics, c'est le robot
chien là qu'on qu'on voit dans Black
Mirror aussi, c'est pour porter le sac
des soldats avant tout. C'est pas pour
porter des colis de la poste, sinon il y
aurait pas eu euh il y aurait pas eu euh
forcément des moyens financiers pour
remplacer les soldats.
Oui, enfin de toute façon à la limite
oui, tu hybrides toujours, tu vois. Tu
peux c'est remplacer ou euh ou ou venir
aider. Mais mais sauf que quand tu as
ça, si tu veux, tu peux pas imaginer un
monde, je sais pas à la je sais pas
comment dire, à la Blade Runner ou tu
vois avec des la moitié des humains puis
l'autre moitié sont des esclaves qui
bossent et cetera. Il y a hélas hélas
hélas on tu fais face à l'érosion du
monde, tout s'use et s'abîme quoi en
fait. Et plus tu as un monde complexe et
cetera, plus il faut passer du temps sur
de la maintenance. Euh alors
aujourd'hui, on voit bien qu'on a fait
des des progrès, hein, sur euh tu tu
vois moins de euh tu sais pas, tu vois
moins de gens qui changent leur pneus
qui a éclaté sur le bord de la route. Tu
vois moins de gens qui sont en panne de
voiture parce que il y a il y a des
programmes de maintenance, de
changement. La voiture, elle clignote,
elle te dit "I faut que tu passes au
garage. Donc de toute façon, on va te
changer telle pièce, telle pièce
standard." Donc on a on a gagné quelque
part en en
taux Ouais. en robustesse, en taux de en
taux de défaillance. On peut le voir
d'ailleurs dans l'aérien he il y avait
une époque il y a 20 ans 30 ans, on
disait avec la croissance de l'aérien,
il y aura un accident par jour
avec les taux de Il y a pas un accident
aujourd'hui par jour hein, même si tu
prends Aéroflotte et je sais pas quoi.
Voilà donc il y a il y a eu un progrès.
Mais ce progrès il se fait au avec une
dépense de consommation et surtout avec
de la de la des questions humaines
derrière. Moi je donc de la même manière
que j'attends que Jean-Marc attend le le
panneau solaire qui permettra de
fabriquer l'éolienne et l'olienne qui
permettra de fabriquer le panneau
solaire ou le mix en tout cas
énergétique renouvelable qui permettra
de de maintenir des énergies
renouvelables sur le long terme et bien
de la même manière moi j'attends le
robot autorlicateur ou ou qui se se
fabrique ou s'entretient et là c'est une
autre paire de manche. Il y a eu un peu
ces fantasmes là dans Eric Drexler avec
les nanos, les nan robots et cetera.
L'idée qu'en fait des machines allaient
se répliquer comme comme la enfin comme
les cellules vivantes. Et aujourd'hui
voilà, si je peux me permettre, moi j'ai
l'impression je suis pas un spécialiste
de la robotique un petit gâteau
mais j'ai l'impression euh c'est c'est
c'est parce que on a parlé de chien que
chien de Robod dog.
Euh
qu'est-ce que tu penses de Doggy une à
la fois ? On pourrait en revenir à la
question de la de de des robots, moi
j'ai l'impression queon est dans un
continuum, encore une fois, je suis pas
un spécialiste, mais j'ai l'impression
qu'on est en fait, on a toujours été
dans un continuum de de prothèse
augmentée, quoi, quelque part, hein.
Parce que le robot qui sert le cocktail,
quelle différence de nature est-ce qu'il
a avec la presse à emboutir qui fait les
portières de voiture ? Bah pas, c'est il
y a pas une franche différence de nature
et avec le robot soudeur sur une chaîne
de montage de voiture
et le robot poète,
pas une franche. Alors, ça je le connais
mal celui-là, on n'a pas été présenté.
Euh mais il y a jamais demandé à une
intelligence artificielle de décrire un
poème
façon Bukovski.
Non puisque je n'utilise pas ce genre de
truc. Donc non mais j'ai j'ai j'ai un
problème moral moi avec ce genre de
truc.
Quel est ton problème moral ?
Bah je peux pas passer mes journées à
dire on est en train de divertir des
ressources et des cervelles sur des
conneries et m'en servir moi-même. Donc
c'est pour ça que tu fais trop de
kilomèt en vélo pour repartir chez toi
ce soir ? Euh non, ça n'a rien à voir.
Ça c'est pour avoir l'illusion de rester
jeune.
Là, tu peux répondre "Merci ma femme".
C'est ça.
Non non, c'est juste parce que je j'aime
bien ça et que ça voilà, je trouve ça
plutôt agréable de de pas être
complètement avachi. Mais ça c'est un
truc qui n'a rien à voir.
Reviens par rapport à ta cohérence de
valeur.
Donc donc sur donc sur la sur la
cohérence de valeur. Oui. Donc je moi je
me sers pas de ce genre de chos et pour
prendre une actualité récente là en ce
moment EDF dit on a trop d'électricité
euh ce qui est un ce qui est un sujet
parce que fin
trop d'électricité. Oui. Euh parce que
en fait on va on va produire énormément,
on va exporter énormément d'électricité
en 2024 et euh alors c'est une très
bonne nouvelle pour la balance
commerciale d'un côté, mais d'un autre
côté ça veut dire que euh s'il y a un
excès d'offre par rapport à la demande,
les prix sont plutôt bas. Du coup, du
coup ça rend ça rend pas rentable la
construction des nouvelles capacités.
Euh voilà. Et alors du coup pour avoir
du coup EDF est intéressé à avoir des
clients et dans les clients qu'ils
envisagent d'avoir, il y a des gens qui
veulent construire des gros data
centers,
des Bitcoin.
Oui, c'est c'est la même chose. Euh donc
en gros ça ça touche plus
de la grosse bah l'intelligence
artificielle. Il y a des gens aussi qui
entendent gagner de l'argent avec euh
avec des data center dont la puissance
absorbée serait de l'ordre du gigawatt,
c'estàd la puissance d'un réacteur
nucléaire. Donc, on est en train de
parler de trucs qui sont complètement
débants et personnellement, moi,
j'appelle ça des gadgets. C'est-à-dire
que je ne pense pas que ces trucs-là
vont régler le problème du changement
climatique. Je ne pense pas que ces
trucs-là vont régler le problème de
l'adaptation des cultures à la dérive
climatique. Je ne pense pas que ces
trucs là vont améliorer la l'harmonie
sociale au sein des sociétés. Euh je ne
pense pas que ces trucs-là en d'autres
termes, je pense que c'est du c'est
c'est ça ne nous aide en rien pour
régler les grands défis de ce monde. Euh
donc euh on a besoin de nos ressources
pour faire autre chose. On on est en
train d'en parler en ce moment, elles
sont contingentes nos ressources, on en
a pas autant qu'on veut, on a pas et
cetera. Je pense que de les divertir sur
des choses comme ça qui sont des choses
totalement anecdotiques euh dans les les
les dans la pyramide de Masselot, j'ai
envie de dire c'est quand même un truc
qui est c'est pas dans les besoins de
base quoi. Euh ça me gêne parce que je
pense que c'est une mauvaise gestion de
nos priorités et qu'on risque de s'en
mordre fortement les doigts dans pas si
longtemps que ça.
Sur la recherche médicale,
l'intelligence artificielle, c'est
peut-être intéressant, non ? Alors
aujourd'hui, ça s'appelle un logiciel de
reconnaissance de tumeur cancéreuse. Euh
oui, donc ces applications-là
effectivement, mais on pourrait aussi
dire, et je ne veux choquer personne en
disant ça, OK, on développe
l'intelligence artificielle pour mieux
détecter les cancers, mais on pourrait
aussi consacrer plus d'efforts à manger
moins de sucre, à moins fumer et à être
moins sédentaire. peut-être que le même
argent euh et du coup on aurait des gens
qui seraient toute l'année mieux dans
leur peau
et pas juste au mieux soigné en ayant le
jour où ils ont un cancer. Voilà. Donc
je pense
la tu n'irait pas dans la même poche mon
ami.
Non, la tune n'irait pas dans la même
poche et on aurait moins cette
fascination du gadget qui s'empare
incidemment de temps en temps d'une
partie du corps médical lui-même. Euh
bon donc voilà donc c'est on a on a on a
le le le débat sur les ressources
contingentes, il nous force aussi de
temps en temps à nous poser des
questions un peu fondamentales sur
qu'est-ce qu'on veut, quels sont nos
grands choix, comment est-ce qu'on pense
qu'on sera le plus heureux avec temps et
pas plus. Euh et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
on fonce un peu de tête baissée sans
trop réfléchir euh sur des choses qui
sont une solution pour des gens qui
n'ont pas d'autres problèmes. Euh je
vais je vais je vais finir tout à
l'heure Philippe parlait des des des
gens un peu déjantés de la Silicone
vallée. En fait c'est des gens qui sont
déjà immensément riches qui ont pas
faim, qui ont pas froid et cetera. Et
qu'est-ce qu'il leur reste ? La peur de
la mort, la peur qu'on les oublie. Fear
of missing out puis
la maladie du pouvoir.
Voilà. Donc voilà. Et donc et donc ça
fait sens pour eux d'investir des
milliards dans quelque chose qui va
combler le petit truc qui leur manque
encore. Mais c'est pas les besoins de
l'humanité dans son ensemble. Filou,
bah d'abord sur les data center là bah
justement tout à l'heure on parlait de
de l'hypersegmentation de la
connaissance et on peut pas tout tout
connaître partout mais enfin
effectivement les gens qui s'intéressent
à ça aujourd'hui ce sont des centaines
des centaines de projets de data center
hyperscale. Donc effectivement le
hyperscale c'est en quelques centaines
de mwaw. Alors, j'avais pas en tête que
ça allait jusqu'au gigaw mais après tout
il suffit de rajouter il suffit de
rajouter 3 qu m chien hein parce que
c'est juste une histoire surfassique.
Donc si tu as si tu mets les il y a pas
beaucoup d'emploi he dans une fois que
le truc est installé, il y a un peu de
maintenance mais pas tant que ça. Donc
on est vraiment sur un truc qui va
faire péter la facture électrique
mondiale hein. Ça ça commence à se voir
pour de vrai les data center
aujourd'hui. Je sais pas, j'ai pas les
derniers chiffres fa checker mais c'est
peut-être je sais pas 400 peut-être
terra à l'échelle mondiale. Donc la
France c'est 500.
Le digital c'est à peu près 10 % de
l'électricité mondial. Donc ça fait 3000
TW
parce que tu ajoutes la fabrication, tu
ajoutes les antennes.
Oui. Et làdedans le fonctionnement des
serveurs c'est 20 % euh
ça colle à peu près ou ça 500 TW donc
l'équivalent à peu près de la production
électrique française quoi pour
simplifier. Et ça va doubler ce machin
hein. Donc ça se voilà. Alors alors du
coup comme le le gâteau global grossit
en pourcentage, ça grossit aussi mais ça
se voit quand même un peu moins. Mais
c'est c'est dingue. Et effectivement
pour quels usages derrière ?
C'est là que qu'on ouvre plein de
questions. Alors effectivement alors les
radios,
la question médicale, elle a toujours
bondau. Donc faut toujours se méfier
quand même sur ça. Les faut pas arrêter
les jets privés parce que on transporte
des transplants cardiaques et des fois
et des reins. Puis après, on se rendre
compte que c'est peinuts dans le dans le
transport et puis que c'est quand même
un peu autre chose que transport les jet
privés. Donc là, c'est toujours un peu
l'idée. Bah ouais, intelligence
artificielle non seulement d'ailleurs ça
va aider au médical puis ça va même ça
va régler des problèmes, ça va aider à
faire des analyses climatique sur les
forêts, on va cap comment elle capte du
CO2, tout. On trouve toujours des super
cas d'usage, mais les 99 % des usages
sont des usages qui vont être soit des
trucs qui servent vraiment à rien. Donc
effectivement, faire la liste des
courses sur chat GPT avec le frigo qui
fait les courses tout seul pour le voilà
la liste des menus de la semaine pour
aider les mamans qui sont en charge
mentale. Mon exemple est un peu genré
mais voilà. Euh soit euh faire de la
productivité, essayer de faire de la
productivité, c'est encore avec du
remplacer du travail humain dans les
cabinets d'avocat par voilà des
graphistes, je sais pas quoi. Voilà.
Donc euh donc on est quand même sur un
truc effectivement qui qui sert pas à
grand-chose. Alors au passage sur la
médecine, ce qui c'est marrant ce que tu
dis parce que moi du coup j'étais un peu
approché sur des questions de médecine
lotche. Alors médecine lot, c'est
dire le rebouteux
marabou. Alors, c'est encore très
prospectif tout ça, mais en fait c'est
parti d'un truc de de de Luc Ferry qui
avait fait qui avait fait une tribune en
disant si on passe au lot, on va tous
mourir parce que et en disant bah oui
avec les progrès si on reste high tech,
on va tous mourir un jour. C'est juste
une question de temps.
Effectivement et du coup ça ça m'avait
amené à
ça m'avait amené un peu à répondre avec
la question bah d'abord la question de
lotex c'est la question de la prévention
versus curatif et cetera et en fait il y
a des trucs assez assez intéressants.
J'avais par exle j'avais le programme
Cadog qui était qui a été monté par
l'Institut Curry. Donc c'est des gens
très sérieux, c'était la détection
précoce du cancer du sein par des
chiens. Donc en fait au lieu d'aller
subir une biopsie à l'hôpital qui est
quand même un truc pas super sympa en
terme d'expérience et tout ça, on dort
avec un coussin sous l'aissell, on met
son coussin dans une enveloppe, on
envoie ça et les chiens ils détectaient
100 % de de cancer.
100 % ?
Ouais. Enfin après il y avait 10 chien
l'Institut Curry le programme K dog K
comme un K avec chien.
Donc je sais pas où il en est, si ça a
été interrompu, pourquoi comment il y a
Covid qui est passé là-dessus ? Je crois
qu'il y avait eu des tests qui ont été
faits sur Covid aussi. Alors j'imagine
bien les bergers allemandes c'est à
taboyant dessus en 2021 à sortie de la
garde sans
en mode il a le Covid attrapez-le. Bon
euh donc mais bon donc tu peux faire des
dystopies tout à fait glaçantes aussi
euh sympa avec la veste kaki et tout
mais donc ce que je veux dire c'est que
il y a des trucs qui peuvent être un peu
incroyable et moi donc j'ai eu
l'occasion de discuter avec des des
chirurgiens
voilà de de différents types de
chirurgie intéressant parce qu'il
disaient par les robots chirurgiens donc
ils sont en train d'équiper toutes les
cliniques privées et cetera d'abord et
puis ensuite l'hôpital public parce que
l'hôpital public il court après des
cliniques privées aussi bien en fait que
h le rapport coût bénéfice
sur le geste du chirurgien. Alors
peut-être qu'il y a un côté
corporatiste, j'en sais rien, mais quand
même globalement, bah c'était pas du
tout démontré pour dans un certain
nombre de cas bien précis et que du
coup, il y avait un fantasme sur la
machine qui allait vraiment bosser bien
plus précisément que que le chirurgien
et puis en plus tout ça à distance avec
le chirurgien qui est en en maillot de
bain en Californie en train de opérer
dans la banlieue de Lyon quoi. Donc donc
c'est pas par contre ce que ça fait ce
que ça fait c'est que du coup on équipe
on suréquipe de plus en plus avec des
équipements qui sont extrêmement chers
avec des business models de sociétés qui
sont pas des petites sociétés on parle
de de grosses de de grosses
multinationales
et qui ont ben un business lié à la
maintenance lié au au aux pièces
détachées lié à plein de choses comme ça
au consommable et cetera, un peu comme
Xerox je caricature mais il y a un peu
de ça et en fait plus tu mets de
l'argent dans les machines
et ben moins tu en as untre pour les
êtres humains, c'est-à-dire des
infirmiers, des infirmières, du
personnel, de l'accompagnement et
cetera. Et en fait pour moi ça ressemble
un peu à ce qui se passe un peu partout
finalement aussi dans l'industrie aussi
dans l'agriculture tu auras des machines
l'agriculture 3.0 4.0 ce sont des
machines de plus en plus complexes des
GPS des machins, des drones qui vont
vérifier et à la fin tu payes de moins
en moins de personnes qui arrivent à
peine à se payer au SMIC sur des
étendues de plus en plus grandes. Donc
on est vraiment dans un dans une course
comme ça qui en fait dont le rapport
coût bénéfice est loin d'être évident.
simplement, il y a des un système
d'innovation
et de de de soutien à l'innovation aussi
parce que c'est bien, ça fait des
startup, ça crée des emplois et cetera
qui en fait et puis finalement un peu la
course du monde globalement de la
destruction créatrice chétérienne avec
par l'innovation qui fait que du coup on
est un système où on s'arrête pas mais
même quand finalement on est en train
peut-être de passer dans beaucoup de
domaines et bien un pic là aussi
finalement de de d'intérêt à à autant
machiniser et autant complexifier bah
tout ce qui fait notre notre
consommation, notre confort quoi.
Alors avant de passer à l'uranium,
la production énergétique à base
d'uranium et lion Mus qu' aller dans
l'espace les astéroïdes et de voyager un
peu dans la BD.
Ah ouais ? Bah ouais et la pub page de
pub là tu fais pas
non pas page de pub ça fait que 1h 16
qu'on nous somme internet
vous avez peut-être cru sur le service
public ici
déconcentration ça remonte à quand la
dernière fois que vous avez discuté avec
la upper upper classe de milliardaires
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu une
discussion à bâton rompu avec des
milliardaires concernant leur perception
de la vie leur perception des choses,
leur perception de la société
moi jamais
jamais cette j'ai j'ai
Oui, mais je ne pense pas que ça aurait
pu être une discussion sincère.
Pourquoi ?
Euh parce que je pense que ce sont des
gens qui sont méfiants euh
et que il enfin en tout cas mon
sentiment que c'est des gens en tout cas
les quelques-uns que j'ai croisé, c'est
c'était plutôt des gens qui se protègent
euh et j'ai pas l'impression que
protège de quoi ? Ben c'est des c'est
toujours un peu euh
bah c'est des personnages un peu
publics.
Euh c'est des personnages qui ont euh
c'est je pense que c'est compliqué pour
eux euh de rentrer dans un rapport euh
totalement sincère et honnête avec des
gens qui font pas partie de leur milieu.
Mais c'est l'idée que je m'en fais si ça
chose je me trompe.
Philippe
B non, j'ai pas fait des milliardaires.
J'ai j'ai fait fugacement une ou deux
fois des des trucs genre family office
je pas tu vois ce que c'est. Oui,
donc plutôt là c'est c'est les employés,
c'est pas le milliardaire lui-même.
Euh al non, de toute façon, ils sont pas
milliardaires, ils sont plutôt euh
multimillionnaires, je sais pas trop. Et
puis
ou des gens des gens comme ça, moi j'en
ai croisé
effectivement et qui se posent des
questions sur la
les petites gens.
Ouais. Qui se posent des questions un
peu sur la pérénité d'une certaine
manière de de là où ils ont placé un peu
leur sous en fait hein. Il y a un peu de
ça derrière ça hein. Donc
euh donc ça s'arrête à peu près là.
Après oui, j'ai la même un peu la même
opinion. Je pense qu'ils sont prudents.
Bah parce que ils doivent passer leur
temps à croiser des champs qui ont des
trucs à leur vendre ou des supers
investisses pour leur proposer ou je
sais pas quoi. Ça doit être pas facile
effectivement de Ils sont peut-être pas
heureux en fait. J'en sais rien.
Alors des des dizaines de millionnaires,
moi j'en ai croisé quelques-uns. Enfin
des gens qui sont qui ont des dizaines
de millions en patrimoine, ça j'en ai
croisé quelques-uns.
Fiscalisé ou pas fiscalisé ?
Je leur ai pas posé la question. C'est
mon ordre de grandeur. Voilà. C'est des
Mais ça là-dedans, on trouve des gens
qui se livrent. Donc, on trouve des gens
qui ont des états d'âmes, des et cetera,
euh des voilà
au-dessus,
j'ai l'impression enfin j'ai le
sentiment que j'ai, c'est que c'est des
gens qui se mettent à se protéger parce
que en fait, ils sont montés tellement
haut et euh enfin voilà, ça c'est c'est
plus compliqué,
difficile de savoir ce qu'il pensent.
Et vous avez jamais entendu parler d'une
vision complètement surréaliste de
transfert de conscience pour devenir
immortel grâce Génial.
Ah bah génial. Euh dans un roman de
science-fiction, on est ce qu'on veut.
Non,
non, mais non, mais cela dit, tu disais
tout à l'heure qu'est-ce qui leur manque
? Bah, il leur manque effectivement
l'immortalité. Donc donc oui, il y a
quand même des investissements dans des
dans des sociétés et je pense que c'est
un coup de centaine de millions sans
problème
pour alors j'en sais rien. Il y en a qui
bossent sur le sang et il faut se
transfuser des trucs. Il y en a qui
bossent sur des cellules souches, il y
en a qui bossent Alors le téléchargement
sur ordinateur, je suis pas sûr que ça
soit tout à fait mur. Euh donc là, je
sais pas s'il y a vraiment ils ont ils
ont foutu quelques dizaines de millions
pour voir dans des trucs comme ça. Ça
m'étonnerait mais euh mais ouais, c'est
normal. Je pense que euh c'est normal
d'avoir envie de de durer, tu vois,
quand tu quand tu as une vie de la beur
avec un métier un peu manuel à pas
savoir si tu finis la fin du mois, tu
arrives sur les genoux à 65 ans et
peut-être que tu vis le truc. Enfin, je
parle pas forcément d'acc français, tu
vois, je prends l'échelle mondiale, tu
arrives peut-être à la retraite et puis
euh et puis tu tu meurs assez vite
soulagé, je sais pas quoi. Quand tu es
milliardaire, tu dois ça doit vraiment
t'embêter de renoncer à tout ce que tout
ce que tout ce que tu vis. Donc, tu dois
avoir envie de repousser l'âge de la
mort encore plus que le pékin moyen que
que nous sommes.
Donc nous, nous on n'est pas sponsorisé,
on est déjà plus des pékin moyens.
Oui. En plus,
vous êtes des vieux. Nous, on n'est pas
sponsorisé par des par rapport à la
moyenne. On est vieux, on est riche, on
est privilégié.
Mais on est désolé de t'avoir coupé la
parole.
On est bon là. Ouais.
Alors donc nous on n'est pas sponsorisé
par des milliard, on est sponsorisé par
notre communauté. Donc n'oubliez pas de
nous financer sur Tipi, c'est notre
indépendance et c'est grâce à vous qu'on
continue. On va parler uranium et
géopolitique avant de parler astéroïd et
musques et des trucs un peu délirants.
Jean-Marc, si on est en train de voir le
monde basculer vers l'ultra électrique,
l'ultra uranium que c'est vachement
bien, que tout le monde veut s'y mettre,
on a encore vu les déclarations que les
États-Unis veulent 200 GW ou 300 GW en
uranium, est-ce que tu penses pas que
quand tout ce petit beau monde va
vouloir se basculer sur l'uranium, il y
aura plus de combustible pour tout le
monde ou à des prix complètement
déconnants ou si Si s'il y a plus de
combustible, il y en aura. Mais les
filières d'approvisionnement iront
d'Australie jusqu'en Chine court, du
Canada jusqu'aux États-Unis court. Et le
de la farce, c'est l'Europe.
On a le Kajakstan pas loin.
Non, tu le Kazakhstan, ils ont pas l'air
très Je vois Philippe a bien raison. Euh
ça ça a l'air d'être compliqué là.
Est-ce que tu peux un peu me délayer
tout ça ? Je dis pas que c'est simple,
je dis c'est pas très loin. Euh
alors
mais le monde va pas être simple. Non
mais il faut de toute façon il faut
qu'on se fasse à l'idée que le monde va
pas être simple hein.
Euh
ça a pas l'air d'être le cas, j'ai
l'impression.
Bah pour le moment pas encore. Non
l'idée.
Bah non quand on voit ce qui s'est passé
avec les Russes et le Gaz il y a pas si
longtemps que ça en fait par
de qui là ? De Bruno Lemire qui qui
je parle je parle de je parle du du
réflexe qu' ont eu les Européens de
penser que la situation pouvait se gérer
de manière simple.
Mais c'est des crétins finis. C'est
tout.
Alors ça c'est ton opinion. Mais je moi
moi je dis juste ils ont mais c'est ça
c'est le reflet de ce que j'ai dit tout
à l'heure sur le fait que la rareté à
l'amont est quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas dans la cervelle
ou la possibilité d'une rareté à la
montelle
des décideurs européens. Ça ça ça ça
n'existe pas. Ils sont comme par
ailleurs, ils sont bibronnés à l'idée du
libre échange qui facilite la
circulation des marchandises que
l'énergie est un bien comme tous les
autres puisque c'est pour ça qu'on a
libéralisé les marché de l'électricité
et cetera. Tout ça circule, c'est fluide
et cetera et il y en a plus en Russie,
c'est pas grave, il y en aura ailleurs.
Euh voilà. Euh
et ben non.
Alors sauf que donc voilà donc ça voilà
une idée qui paraissait simple et de bon
goût et en fait c'est pas du tout comme
ça que les choses se passent. Donc euh
le monde n'est déjà euh plus gérable
aujourd'hui de manière simple et en fait
demain ça sera encore moins le cas.
C'est-à-dire que il faut que et ça c'est
quelque chose que je dis souvent aussi,
il faut que nos plans pour l'avenir, ils
soient eux-mêmes résilients à un monde
en proie au sousbreau. Euh parce que si
on a des plans qui ne flottent que par
beau temps et grand soleil, de toute
façon, nos plans, ils iront pas à terme.
C'est absolument évident. Euh le monde
va connaître des chaos, le monde va
connaître des sous-bressaux euh de façon
malheureusement plutôt croissante. Euh
et il va falloir que les plans qu'on
fait qu'on fait flottent là-dedans. Euh
voilà. Alors pour en revenir à la
question de l'uranium, déjà aujourd'hui,
il faut voir quand même que euh on n'est
pas en train d'assister à un rush
mondial sur du nucléaire. C'est pas
vraiment ça qui se passe. Euh le
nucléaire, c'est aujourd'hui 10 % de la
production électricité mondiale.
450 combien de réacteurs dans le monde ?
Euh de l'ordre de l'ordre de 450.
Voilà. 453. Non
alors j'ai pas le j'ai pas le chiffre.
Voilà. Et par ailleurs, les sorts du
nucléaire aujourd'hui c'est
essentiellement chinois et russe.
D'accord. C'est les les les deux pays
aujourd'hui la la moitié la moitié si ce
n'est plus des réacteurs en construction
dans le monde. Il me semble que c'est la
moitié. Donc là, il y a 443 réacteurs en
fonctionnement dans le monde.
Euh et il y en a il y en a euh alors je
voudrais pas dire de connerie, il doit y
en avoir entre 15 et 20 en construction
en Chine en ce moment sur quelques
dizaines en construction dans le monde,
je sais plus c'est 30 40 enfin on est
dans ces
pour un total de capacité.
Bon ben un réacteur unitaire c'est de
l'ordre de 1000 MW.
D'accord. C'est ça se balade entre 500
et 1500 mais enfin on va dire que en
ordre de grandeur c'est plutôt 1000.
Et euh donc si aujourd'hui renouveau
entre guillemets du nucléaire il y a
pour le moment il est essentiellement
asiatique. Euh d'accord, il est il est
enfin ou à l'est à l'est de l'Europe.
Aux États-Unis pour le moment il y en a
pas de renouveau du nucléaire. C'est il
y a très peu. Il doit y avoir un
réacteur en construction je crois aux
États-Unis en ce moment. Euh et les
États-Unis c'est quand même le royaume
du marché.
Donc en fait le nucléaire aura beaucoup
de mal à renaître parce que c'est quand
même un réacteur, c'est 100 ans, quoi.
Je veux dire entre le construction, sa
gestion et son démantellement. Voilà.
Euh il faut avoir une idée des prix de
l'électricité sur le siècle qui vient.
C'est quand même un peu compliqué. Euh
et donc en fait comme c'est un peu
compliqué, la manière dont les êtres
humains raisonnent en général c'est
qu'ils se calent sur les prix actuels.
Donc à partir du moment où ils savent
pas ce qui va se passer dans un siècle,
ils se disent "Si le prix actuel est
élevé, bon c'est qu'on peut
raisonnablement penser que et voilà
c'est comme ça que ça marche." Euh c'est
pour ça qu'il y a eu une grande vague de
construction de réacteurs nucléaire
après les chocs pétroliers.
Exactement pour cette raison. C'est
parce que à ce moment-là les prix
étaient élevés. Donc on s'est dit on y
va.
Euh donc le le nucléaire aujourd'hui, on
peut pas vraiment dire que ce soit
quelque chose qui qui fasse l'objet de
d'un développement absolument absolument
figulant. Maintenant, on peut faire une
école de pensée. On peut se dire
imaginons que la production électrique
actuelle, on a envie de la remplacer. On
va faire comme les Chinois, moitié
nucléaire, moitié UNR, d'accord ? On
faire un truc comme ça, une école de
pensée. Un système comme ça ne tient pas
pendant des siècles avec juste
l'exploitation de l'uranium 235 des
ressources inventoriées aujourd'hui.
Voilà, c'est ça le c'est ça le la
conclusion grosso modo qu'on peut tirer.
Donc si on veut un nucléaire qui tienne
des siècles, il faut absolument passer à
ce qu'on appelle la 4e génération qui
est capable d'exploiter la totalité des
noyaux d'uranium présent dans la nature
et pas juste l'isotope 235 qui est un
isotope très minoritaire.
Pour les gens qui sont pas familiers du
mot isotope, en fait un isotope c'est
une variante d'un même élément chimique.
C'est toujours du fer, c'est toujours de
l'uranium, c'est toujours du carbone,
c'est toujours de l'iode. Mais le nombre
de ne donc le nombre de protons qui
caractérisent l'élément chimique est
toujours le même. Voilà, par exemple,
dans l'hydrogène, c'est 1, dans l'hélium
c'est 2, voilà, dans le carbone c'est 6.
Mais par contre, le nombre de neutrons
dans le noyau varie. Et quand on a un
nombre de neutrons qui varie dans un
noyau, s'appelle un isotope. C'est
voilà, c'est c'est différent. Et donc
pour l'uranium, il y a deux isotopes
dans la nature. Un avec 235 nucléons,
donc 92 protons et l'autre avec 238. Le
235 peut être utilisé dans nos réacteurs
actuels, mais c'est 0,7 % de l'uranium.
Et le 238 peut pas être utilisé dans les
réacteurs classiques qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui. On pourrait faire des
réacteurs qui s'en servent mais il faut
les faire et il faut les déployer et
c'est long. Et donc, on va retomber sur
le problème qu'on évoque depuis plus
d'une heure, c'est-à-dire quel est le
substrat technologique sous-jacent euh
et le substrat énergétique sous-jacent
qui est nécessaire pour que l'on soit
capable de déployer ce genre de truc
raisonnablement rapidement. Euh mais
même si on les déployait très très vite
jusque dans les rêves les plus faux et
cetera, ça ne représenterait encore
aujourd'hui qu'une fraction de l'énergie
globale qu'on consomme dans le monde.
Donc on peut pas voir le nucléaire comme
un truc qui va résoudre tous nos
problèmes. Ça peut pas marcher comme ça.
C'est pas vrai. Même quand on aime bien
le nucléaire comme moi. Voilà. Donc en
gros, si on se limite à la à la forme
actuelle d'exploitation de l'énergie
nucléaire qu'on connaît, c'est l'uranium
235 dans des réacteurs à haut
pressurisés, on peut pas faire du
nucléaire quelque chose de très durable
très longtemps pour une très grosse
partie de l'énergie qu'on consomme dans
le monde. Ça tient pas. Philippe,
je voulais ajouter quand même dans la
tout à fait d'accord sur la la
description bien sûr. Alors moi en plus
je rajoute ma petite poulin pimpin des
circuits primaires au nickel cobalt et
tout qu'il faut avoir pendant des
siècles parce que évidemment ça se
recycle pas comme des boîtes de
conserve. Donc il faut il faut avoir un
flux matériel suffisant pour
reconstruire tes tes advitam eternam si
je puis dire pendant chaque siècle tes
tes centrales. Mais je voulais juste
ajouter un petit truc sur les
États-Unis. tout à fait d'accord avec
toi sur le le fait que c'est c'est drivé
par le par le marché et donc un peu plus
ça va pas bien avec le le le long
termisme nécessaire y compris sur le
développement de ces nouvelles
générations. Il y a un petit peu quand
même un hype
alors sur la capacité à attirer à cramer
des capitaux sur la question des SMR
donc des small modular reactors donc
voilà qui serait des réacteurs plus
petits al je sais pas de quelques
dizaines à quelques centaines de de mW
c'est quand même quelques centaines ça
commence à être des grosses des belles
bêtes je sais pas si on peut vraiment
les appeler petites et derrière lequel
lesquelles il y a une idée un peu bah
presque à la musque aussi un peu de de
disruption de dire queon va au lieu
d'avoir des de de de stupides ingénieurs
de DF Je plaisante bien sûr hein euh qui
qui sont un peu cher payés, qui sont
avec leur RTT et tout. Bah là on va on
va faire des trucs.
Ils sont pas cher payés. Ils sont
toujours là quand il y a je plaisante
bien sûr mais
ils sont robustes
vu à l'américaine. Vu à l'américaine tu
vois. OK, ils sont pas ils sont pas
efficient, ils sont pas ils sont pas tu
vois, ils sont powerpllet dodge. Non,
les c'est parce que c'est le le Dodge
là, c'est le nouveau truc de of
government efficiency que va prendre
non c'est Dodge ça. C'est marrant, c'est
comme c'est comme c'est comme le Dodge
de Venice quoi, tu vois. Il y a un côté
un peu parce que tu es vieux.
Ah bon ? D'accord. Bon alors donc voilà
donc du coup l'idée c'est de dire il y a
eu de la disruption dans le spatial, on
peut faire de la disruption dans le
nucléaire aussi tout en faisant un truc
sûr. Regardez. Et et donc l'idée c'est
de faire vraiment des petits réacteurs
qui soient quasiment produit de manière
industrielle, presque montés localement
sur une barge éventuellement d'ailleurs
au milieu de l'eau, au milieu de la mer
comme ça même même sous-marine un peu.
Et il y a beaucoup de financement, il y
a beaucoup d'intérêt soit c'est venu un
peu historiquement bah de milliardaire
de type
Bill Gates he qui s'intéresse à ça, il
s'intéresse au vaccin, plein de trucs,
mais lui ça fait longtemps qu' qui qu'
qui qu' qui soutient et qui s'intéresse
à ça. toi qui est en train d'arriver à
travers justement bah ces ces gros
faiseurs de de de du cloud donc Amazon,
Microsoft et cetera qui commence à dire
alors je peux aller me mettre derrière
Graveline en France mais ça pas c'est my
il ve Microsoft Microsoft ve remettre en
service le réacteur non accidenté de
Thre Island
euh justement pour alimenter un data
center
donc mais mais il finance aussi voilà il
finance aussi des startup pour les les
chaudes
Voilà. Donc voilà. Donc du coup
effectivement euh Oui, c'est normal, tu
rejettes, tu c'est le circuit de
refroidissement, c'est il y a pas de
souci. C'est pour ça qu'ils sont au bord
de la mer ou au bord des fleurs. Donc
tout va bien. Enfin, tout va bien, c'est
normal. Euh ça veut pas dire que c'est
l'utricium et tout ça. Euh même s'il
doit y en avoir un peu aussi. Voilà.
Euh mais du coup donc il y a les SMR et
puis en train d'arriver aussi un peu
alors plus prospectif mais pareil hein
dans un mode start-up et tout et qui
lève des centaines de millions aussi
hein. C'est euh la fusion la fusion
nucléaire. Donc l'étape d'après. Et donc
là faut quand même voir le côté un peu
messianique du truc hein puisque bah
Samtman par exemple hein donc on sait
qu'il est très compétent sur la fusion
nucléaire hein euh don je plaisante mais
donc voilà fondateur de cfondateur
d'Open AI donc chat GPT bah qui tweet
sans problème en disant de toute façon
on a besoin de la fusion nucléaire parce
que les besoins en AI vont être tels que
de toute façon on n pas le choix et donc
il y a aussi un peu d'argent qui se
déverse là-dedans. C'est pas en mode
ITER là avec le les Tokamac là, les gros
gros trucs comme on est en train de de
de de tester enfin de pardon de
construire pour faire un petit test de
quelques dizaines de secondes dans le
sud de la France. C'est plutôt des
méthodes de fusion nucléaire un peu
différentes. Alors soit avec des lasers
soit voilà qui sont moins je pense
intensifes en capital quoi pour
construire le premier truc de la proof
of concept quoi comme on aime bien dire
dans les startup. Donc
pour les béoiens avec les lasers tout ça
la fion.
Oui, mais c'est
Oui, la fusion c'est c'est l'énergie du
soleil. Oui, c'est ça. Mais
mais c'est un c'est un pulse. Il faut
bien voir qu'une centrale électrique
aujourd'hui, ça doit fonctionner des
milliers d'heures sans s'arrêter.
Attends, laisse finir Philippe.
Oui. Alors, pas tu seras largement aussi
content que moi. Mais bon, alors donc
Uranium que ça soit 235 238, on pourrait
rajouter la question du torium parce
queil y a aussi les possibilités de
faire des centrales autorium. Les
Indiens sont intéressés par ça parce
qu'ils ont ils ont ils ont un peu de de
torium, de la monasite chez eux. Euh
donc ça c'est c'est c'est ficile. Donc
enfin on on va perdre du poids en
cassant des noyaux. Donc la somme des la
somme des des résidus par rapport au
noyaux d'origine, on perd un peu de
masse. Donc on crée de l'énergie avec ça
qu'on va récupérer avec des échangeurs
de chaleur. Et dans le cadre de la
fusion, on parle plutôt de de d'atomes
très légers, donc des isotopes pour le
coup de de l'hydrogène et qu'on va faire
fusionner. Et en fusionnant, ils perdent
aussi un peu de masse mais ils en
perdent plus. Donc du coup, c'est très
énergie, c'est très énergivore au départ
pour monter en en température parce que
ça se passe sous plusieurs millions de
degrés et par contre ça rapporte pas
mal. Ça pourrait rapporter pas mal. En
tout cas dans le soleil ça marche.
Jean-Marc, petit soleil, tu continues,
tu
Alors, moi je pense queon va devoir
faire 100 si on regarde le si on regarde
le calendrier.
Euh on est en train là de finir de
construire ITER.
Euh ITER c'est n'a pas de dispositif de
production électrique. Donc IER c'est
destiné à montrer que on peut entretenir
une réaction de fusion pendant quelques
minutes, pas des milliers d'heures,
quelques minutes, en libérant au cours
de la fusion plus d'énergie qu'on en a
utilisé pour mettre la matière à
quelques millions ou dizaines de
millions de degrés perfectement droitir
comme l'a évoqué Philippe. Parce que
pourquoi il faut chauffer si fort la
matière ? C'est parce que comme les
noyaux sont chacun chargés positivement
pour les fusionner comme les aimandes,
on narrive pas à rapprocher les faces
les faces de même signe là, il faut que
les noyaux se rapprochent pour devenir
tellement proche que la la
l'interaction, on appelle l'interaction
forte finit par les assembler. Bon et ça
ça demande de les projeter l'un contre
l'autre avec une énergie absolument
considérable et l'énergie, la vitesse de
déplacement c'est la température. Donc
il faut monter le la matière à à des
dizaines de millions de degrés et pour
ça il faut injecter énormément d'énergie
dans la chauffe du plasma. Et ce que va
essayer de démontrer, c'est qu'on peut
retirer plus d'énergie derrière avec la
fusion que ce qu'on a utilisé pour
monter en température. Mais c'est une
fusion qui va durer quelques minutes et
il y aura pas de dispositif de
transformation de l'énergie de fusion en
électricité. Alors, ITER, on va finir de
le construire. Il va falloir 5 à 10 ans
de fonctionnement pour queon comprenne à
peu près ce qu'on est en train de faire
et qu'on en tire les leçons pour
éventuellement l'étape d'après. Donc ça
nous amène en 2035. Euh puis on se
gratte la tête pendant 2 ans pour savoir
ce qu'on fait après. Euh puis on
commence à construire le truc d'après.
Une fois qu'on l'a terminé, ça nous
amène en 2050.
À supposer qu'on ait trouvé la manière
de faire de l'électricité avec l'énergie
de la fusion. C'est beaucoup plus
compliqué qu'avec la fission. Il y a pas
de Il y a pas d'eau qui se balade au
contact de voilà, c'est plus compliqué.
Il y a un confinement il y a un
confinement magnétique.
Il y a un confinement magnétique et il y
a du En fait la fusion a lieu dans un
dans un espace où il y a le vide qui a
été fait. Euh c'est ça qui permet
d'isoler de les quelques dizaines de
millions de degrés et de pas faire
fondre tout ce qui se trouve autour.
Et la fusion, elle fournit des neutrons
de très haute énergie. C'est ça qu'elle
fournit. Et il faut capter ces neutrons
de très haute énergie pour faire de
l'électricité. Et ça c'est plus
compliqué que ce que la manière dont on
fait de l'électricité aujourd'hui avec
la fission qui dégage de la chaleur,
j'ai envie de dire ordinaire. Voilà. Euh
donc le donc on est en 2050 en ayant
éventuellement euh commencé à construire
le successeur d'It qu'on aura terminé de
construire en 2065 dans un monde dans
lequel il y aura moins de matériaux si
j'écoute mon voisin de gauche, moins
d'énergie si je m'écoute moi, plus de
guerre si je t'écoute toi. Enfin bon
bref, donc ça sera un peu plus
compliqué. Euh et puis éventuellement en
on a fini d'avoir le retour d'expérience
pour savoir comment construire une tête
de série. Donc fait en fait on est rendu
à la fin du siècle. si on regarde le le
calendrier avant que la fusion euh ne
puisse faire l'objet d'un déploiement
industriel qui pourrait venir au secours
euh des problèmes de décarbonation, de
goulet d'étranglement sur les ressources
et cetera. Donc personnellement, je
pense queil faut faire 100. Euh à titre
personnel, euh j'aurais pas financé
ITER. euh j'aurais relancé la 4e
génération du nucléaire parce que ça ça
avait une portée pratique à des sur des
horizons de temps beaucoup plus courts.
Euh mais bon euh chacun son gadget donc
voilà donc c'est c'est pas quelque chose
donc c'est quelque chose qui emballe les
physiciens parce que ça va leur
permettre de de découvrir des trucs
nouveaux et cetera. C'est toujours
pareil ça excite la curiosité parce que
c'est c'est de l'inexploré, c'est du
nouveau, c'est machin et cetera. Mais si
on regarde en terme de porté pratique
euh pour que mes enfants de
faire ton amiche.
Ouais.
Non c'est pas les amiches parce que je
suis pas du tout antitechno en disant ça
justement. Je disais, je je viens de
dire, moi j'aurais préféré financer le
développement de la 4e génération. Donc
c'est pas de la micherie, c'est juste
faire des choix. Euh on peut pas tout
faire. Donc la question c'est où est-ce
qu'on met les cervelles des physiciens
qui savent parler d'énergie nucléaire et
où est-ce qu'on met les milliards ?
C'est ça la question. Bon,
où est-ce qu'on les trouve les cerveaux
? On entend Agnè Panag Runaché vouloir
recruter 100000 talents dans le
nucléaire. Oui. Bah si on fait le
programme, c'est ça fait ça ne fait que
10000 personnes par an sur 10 ans. En
fait, si on fait le programme nucléaire
qui est actuellement envisagé là avec 6
+ 8 14 réacteurs plus les deux qu'on a
déjà lancé, il faut effectivement
mobiliser à cette fin à peu près un/art
des ingénieurs qu'on forme chaque année
en France pendant 10 ans. Oui, c'est
l'ordre de grandeur.
Donc oui,
ça fait ça fait Non mais ça fait du
monde. Ça fait du monde. Mais
personnellement, je pense que
aujourd'hui il y en a à peu près un/art,
peut-être pas un/art, mais il y en a
beaucoup qui vont dans la finance
quantitative, l'intelligence
artificielle et tout un tas d'autres
trucs. Donc là, c'est pareil. Est-ce que
on les a vraiment pas ces ingénieurs ou
est-ce qu'on est en train de les allouer
sur des trucs qui sont pas
indispensables ? C'est c'est toujours la
même question.
Philippe ?
Ouais.
Je je sais pas si j'hésitais à dévoiler
un truc un peu perso mais au milieu des
années 2000, je travaillais comme
consultant et on avait répondu à un
appel d'offre pour Areva, ça s'appelait
à l'époque qu'on avait pas gagné
d'ailleurs.
J'ai cru que tu allais nous faire une
autre confession.
Non non. Et que ça s'appelait ça
s'appelait bridge the gap parce queà
l'époque il y avait effectivement déjà
des courbes là pour le coup de nucléaire
mondial tout à fait impressionnante. Et
en fait on savait enfin Arriva avait
fait un business plan de dingue et
allait se positionner un peu partout
dans le dans le monde entier et il avait
besoin de faire vraiment un recrutement
très important. Or, ce recrutement, il
était pas facile parce que il fallait
attirer justement des talents qui
avaient pas forcément envie de venir
chez chez chez chez eux. Bon, finalement
après, il y a eu euh Fukushima en 2011,
c'est ça ? Non. Oui.
2011. Euh
donc bon, ça a un peu bridge the gap. Le
gars a tout de suite été plus besoin.
Ouais, c'était l'inverse quoi. C'était
sans sauvegarde de l'emploi. Mais euh
mais du coup voilà, moi j'ai je pense
que c'est euh bah hélas, oui, c'est
enfin c'est pas que c'est hélas mais
c'est ça me paraît tout à fait
irréaliste et parce que les ingénieurs
vont en avoir besoin dans plein d'autres
endroits.
Alors on a besoin bah dans le le
solaire, l'hydrogène, le voilà toutes
les énergies renouvelables. va avoir
besoin pour faire de la rénovation
thermique de plein de trucs alors que
voilà, on sait que le parc
le on n pas un parc qui est qui est qui
est tout à fait bah carbone quoi. On va
dire ça comme ça en terme de
d'exploitation et de consommation
énergétique. On va avoir toutes les
questions d'adaptation. Ça c'est un truc
de dingue. On a à peine commencé à
soulever le la couverture de qu'est-ce
qu'il va falloir faire pour s'adapter au
coût parties du changement climatique
sur s'adapter trouve un autre mot. bah
se se euh encaisser euh encaisser des
des des problématiques euh technico euh
socio-économique lié euh à un climat qui
sera de plus en plus euh instable,
imprévisible ou au contraire enfin
prévisible sur le fait que et ben les
crues centenales vont devenir décenales
ou je sais pas les crus millénaires
deviendront centenal que il y aura un
moment de la chauffe Enfin, je des
températures qui fait que bah on a des
métaux, ils se dilatent par exemple avec
la température donc tu commences à avoir
des voilà donc que tu as des rails qui
commencent à se faire comme ça, des
caténaires qui commencent à se mettre
comme ça pour ne prendre qu'un exemple
ferroviaire. Voilà, donc tu as besoin et
donc aujourd'hui qui commence à faire
aujourd'hui ouais enfin donc il y a
plein il y a plein de de choses et je
parle pas là de l'aspect purement social
et organisationnel qui est la question
parle de la canicule 2003 où c'était on
s'est pas bien occupé des personnes
seules et cetera. Là, je parle bien de
de sujets qui vont être aussi physiques
et techniques, quoi. Et
et biologique et agronomique. Euh, enfin
oui, en plus dans l'agriculture, enfin
voilà, on peut on peut ouvrir tous les
donc des fronts, ils vont en avoir, ils
vont en avoir beaucoup. Et donc
effectivement de se dire que je mets un
car des ingénieurs sur le nucléaire,
bon, je sais pas. Ouais, ça
pas sûr. Alors, un car des ingénieurs
actuels. Après, on peut aussi se poser
la question de savoir si ce qu'on
appelle un ingénieur
concepteur d'armes.
Euh non, ce que je veux dire par là,
c'est est-ce que par exemple dans les
gens qui actuellement font le métier de
technicien,
est-ce que il y a pas aussi toute une
promotion sur le tas à envisager ? On
est quand même dans un pays en France
qui a conservé une forme de régime
aristocratique dans l'éducation.
C'est-à-dire qu'on est déterminé toute
sa vie durant par le niveau d'éducation
qu'on a reçu au moment de sa formation
initiale. H
je suis pas sûr que ce soit à la fois ni
très sain ni adapté. Alors, il y a des
gens qui arrivent à devenir à passer
technicien ingénieur mais euh peut-être
pas assez. Euh peut-être que ces gens-là
feraient des très bons ingénieurs si on
en faisait plus et peut-être qu'une
partie du problème qu'on est en train
d'évoquer peut se résoudre de cette
manière aussi. Donc ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'on va avoir besoin, je rejoins tout à
fait Philippe sur un point, c'est qu'on
va avoir besoin de de plus en plus de
gens. Il y a une expertise euh cette
expertise peut être de déboucher les
chiottes comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure. Euh ah ben tour de bureau à la
défense où il y a plus de chiot. À
Carbon 4, on travaille sur l'adaptation
et un des trucs qu'on se dit c'est
combien vaut une tour à la défense où
les chiottes ne fonctionneraient plus.
Mais la réponse est zéro.
Pas grand chose.
Et combien vaut une tour à la défense où
les ascenseurs ne fonctionneraient plus
? Par ailleurs, elle vaut zéro aussi.
Donc euh la la donc la question de
l'adaptation, elle va concerner euh
plein de domaines distincts. Euh et on
on peut très bien avoir des gens qui
aujourd'hui détiennent des expertises
qui seront très utiles pour réfléchir à
ce problème, qu'on pourrait très bien
euh après tout dans l'étendur hein, on a
on a on a promu des gens maréchaud sur
le front, on pourrait très bien
promouvoir les circonstances l'exigant
des gens ingénieurs.
Surtout que c'est beaucoup de la gestion
de projet en fait, c'est pas forcément
la conception et le calcul.
Tu parles de toilettes et tu parles
d'ascenseur. Moi je vais te poser une
question. Combien un parking ?
J'ai cru que tu allais me demander qu' d
la dernière fois que je suis allé aux
toilettes dans un ascenseur. Non, c'est
pas ça la question.
Tu es ingénieur toi. Non.
Il parait.
Combien faut un parc immobilier dans une
zone du genre Asie du Sud-Est où le taux
d'humidité plus la chaleur vont devenir
létal ?
Je ne sais pas.
Sans climatisation ?
Tu ne sais pas.
Euh mais par contre vraisemblablement ça
le prix montera pas. Euh ça va devenir
un sujet aussi. Et la question que je me
pose, c'est admettons que ce parc
immobilier
soit dans le portefeuille de quelques
grandes banques ou fond d'investissement
ou fond de retraite ou famil
et qu'est-ce qui se passe s'il y a une
dépréciation de ce type d'actif à
l'échelle mondiale ?
Alors à l'échelle mondiale, ça sera pas
nécessairement le cas parce que le
problème qui vient d'être évoqué est un
problème qui concerne la bande
équatoriale. Bon euh ça concerne pas le
Canada.
ça concerne pas le Canada et cetera. Par
contre, non. Alors, ce qui est sûr,
c'est que ça concerne un milliard de
personnes ce problème là. Euh quand on
regarde dans le dernier rapport du GC,
il y avait de très belles cartes. Enfin,
je pas
Ils se sont autocensurés. Non,
ce Non, je crois pas qu'ils
s'autocensurent. Euh,
c'est parce qu'on t'a pas les bonnes
sources.
C'est quoi ta source ?
Ouais.
Est-ce qu'il y aura un fact checking sur
tes sources ?
T'inquiète pas.
Donc euh
sur ce de première main.
Ah, sûrement. Euh
gauche ou droite,
ça dépend. toujours
bon alors euh la la dans le dernier
rapport du J, il y avait des cartes qui
montraient le nombre de jours par an
pour pour toutes les tous les pays dans
le monde he le nombre de jours par an où
en 2050 et en 2010 en fonction du
scénario de réchauffement qu'on a euh la
température humide euh de la zone
dépasse les 35°gr ma mémoire est bonne.
C'est-à-dire une zone dans laquelle il y
a un risque pour la vie à s'aventurer
dehors, même pour quelqu'un qui est en
bonne santé. Risque pour la vie, ça veut
pas dire que les gens meurent
instantanément. Ça veut dire que voilà,
c'est dangereux, c'est éventuellement
dangereux de le faire. Euh et à
l'horizon 2005, même à l'horizon 2050 et
dans un scénario de réchauffement 2
degrés, euh il y a un il y a de l'ordre
d'un milliard de personnes dans le monde
qui sont concernées par le problème un
jour sur deux ou plus. Bon, donc
effectivement, on n'est pas du tout en
train de parler d'un problème
anecdotique. Alors aujourd'hui,
l'énergie abondante permet de palier le
problème puisque l'énergie abondante,
c'est notamment la climatisation. Il
faut bien voir qu'en fait l'énergie
abondante aujourd'hui permet de répondre
à tous les problèmes quasiment qu'on est
en train de créer, sauf la disparition
des espèces parce que ça c'est pas un
problème énergétique, sauf
éventuellement certains problèmes
sanitaires qui sont en train de
d'apparaître, la pollution, la
contamination par ceci, cela. Mais sinon
l'énergie abondante aujourd'hui permet
de reconstruire les habitations
détruites, permet de permet de faire des
digues, de déplacer les populations,
d'amener l'eau potable si le réseau
fonctionne plus ou s'il y a plus d'eau
dans la rivière ou et cetera. Vous
voyez des fois des fleurs à ta femme
avec un coup de carte bleue.
Donc en fait notre UBIS énergétique
aujourd'hui nous masque l'émergence des
problèmes. Le problème c'est qu'on va se
retrouver à la croisée des chemins.
C'està-dire qu'on va se retrouver un
jour avec moins de moyens de réponse et
un problème qui n'aura cessé d'enfler.
Et alors à ce moment ça ça risque de
commencer à faire mal euh et on s'en
préoccupe pas assez. Euh c'est
absolument euh c'est absolument évident.
Mais donc c'est sûr qu'à ce moment-là,
il y aura des phénomènes physiques et il
y aura aussi des phénomènes économiques.
Donc il va y avoir des craquements
économiques. Mais moi, je suis pas j'ai
pas de boule de cristal, donc je sais
pas dire euh à quel horizon de tens ou
quelle forme et cetera.
On n pas astrologue de plateau télé.
Euh non, un tout petit peu peut-être.
Mais par contre ce je ce que je sais
dire c'est que la probabilité qu'il y
ait pas de craquement peut raisonner
dans l'autre sens. Euh qui a pas de
craquement significatif euh dans le
système à l'horizon de quelques
décennies est extrêmement faible.
Phil, Philippe, tu veux rajouter quelque
chose ? Ouais. Bah juste dire, moi il y
a déjà surpris qu'il y ait pas des trucs
qui craquaient le plus vite quoi. Si je
prends par exemple l'immobilier de
bureau en Île-de-France, je sais pas ce
qu'il y a dans les comptes de chacune
des boîtes qui détiennent cet
immobilier, mais je vois les taux de de
vacances, les prix qui descendent et on
continue quand même à en construire
parce que bah ceux qu'on a déjà fait,
ils sont pas bien, ils sont pas au bon
endroit et donc là on va construire des
super bureaux écoonçus avec je sais pas
quoi, des trucs en bois. Bon euh je suis
étonné. Donc il y a forcément des gens
qui soit font des right off discrets
dans les comptes année après année en
descendant, soit ser un peu les fesses
en laissant les actifs tels qu'ils sont
en disant que ça va repartir. Mais
voilà, il y a les sujets des bureaux, il
y a le sujet je pense certaines zones
commerciales ou supermarché hypermarché.
On voit que là récemment Auchamp a un
petit souci et euh en train d'enfermer
et faire un plan social et pas que mais
donc voilà, il y a quand même aussi des
questions enfin un moment à battre des
records de mètres carrés par personne
disponible de bureaux, de zones
commerciales, de parking, de route, de
je sais pas quoi. Bah oui, ça ça atteint
forcément une une limite. Donc ça ça met
forcément des business models de de
croissance en danger.
J'ouvre une parenthèse, un message à la
communauté. On doit être à peu près 8000
et des patates sur YouTube et quelques
centaines sur notre chat privé. Pour
faites-nous remonter les questions avec
des petits pouces. Là, je vois que vous
êtes en train de faire de l'intelligence
collaborative. Donc on prendra les
questions avec le plus de petits pouces
qui vont bien. Revenons à nos moutons.
L'orbitation d'astéroïdes, euh la
transformation de la Lune en zone
industrielle
habité sur Mars.
Arrêtez de vous marrer, s'il vous plaît.
Alors la première fois qu'on m'a posé la
question,
les ingénieurs, hein.
La première fois qu'on m'a posé la
question, je me suis demandé comment
est-ce que je peux répondre à cette
question avec un calcul d'ingénieur.
Alors, j'ai pas j'ai pas trouvé de
calcul d'ingénieur pour répondre, mais
presque j'ai trouvé un calcul
d'économiste.
C'est encore pire. C'est mais de
microéconomie. Alors la la réponse est
la suivante. Le programme Apollo en
dollar actuel a coûté à peu près 100
milliards de dollars à peu près un peu
plus. Il a permis de ramener 400 kg de
roche de la Lune. Alors évidemment
c'était pas son objet premier.
Non, c'était de gagner la guerre froide,
faire révéler les
mais ça mais ça met quand même la tonne
de minerais ramener de la lune à 250
milliards de dollars.
Alors admettons que dollar de
maintenant. Oui. Alors, admettons
qu'avec euh des procédés modernes et
avec euh une un objectif qui soit
précisément de miner des corps euh
célestes, on arrive à gagner un facteur
1 million d'efficacité. Bon, pas mal 1
million. Bon et bien euh 1 million ça ça
nous met quand même euh encore euh la
tonne de minerais à 250000 à 250000 € et
même si je gagnais un facteur 1
milliard, ça nous mettrait encore la
tonne de enfin voilà donc on est on est
sur des ordres de grandeur qui font que
ça ne sera jamais des flux
d'approvisionnement premier. Euh je vais
prendre quelques ordres de grandeur. Euh
Philippe complètera sur ce sujet qui
connaît beaucoup mieux que moi, mais sur
le fer, par exemple, sur l'acier qui est
qui est le premier pilier métallique de
notre civilisation. Si j'accepte les
combustibles fossiles du côté des
ressources non renouvelables, le premier
pilier de la civilisation, c'est
l'acier.
Euh l'acier aujourd'hui, on en produit 2
milliards de tonnes par an en ordre de
grandeur. Un tout petit peu moins, un
milliard, je sais pas quoi. Pas euh ça
veut dire 4 milliards de tonnes de
minerais de fer extrait d'écrû de
terrestre. Presquon s'imagine qu'on va
aller chercher 4 milliards de tonnes de
fer, 4 milliards de tonnes de minerais
sur les astéroïdes. C'est la dépense
énergétique pour ce trucl est totalement
hors de porté. Je dis totalement ça
n'arrivera jamais.
Et aller chercher de l'hélium 3 sur la
Lune.
Alors déjà faudrait qu'on ait faudrait
qu'il y en ait. Je sais pas s'il y a de
l'hélium 3 sur la Lune. Euh et par
ailleurs, l'hélium 3 sauf erreur de ma
partum.
Et sauf erreur de ma part le tricium est
radioactif avec une demi-vie très
courte. Donc je vois pas pourquoi il y
aurait des stocks accumulés de tricium
sur la Lune qui auraient tenu pendant
des siècles et des millénaires. Parce
que la demie-ville du tricium c'est un
peu plus de 10 ans si ma mémoire est
bonne. Je
tricium tu c'est hydrogène. Là c'est
hélium.
Ah hélium pardon. Hélium 3. Hélium 3 je
sais pas pourquoi. Fa check.
Alors je sais pas pourquoi il y aurait
Oui. Non tu as raison. Je sais pas
pourquoi il y aurait des stocks mais
c'est pareil. L'hélium tout court. Bah
l'hélium tout court en sur terre on on
sait comment il est. Ah c'est l'hélium
solaire qui serait arrivé.
Ouais. Je crois que c'est c'est je crois
que c'est le bombardement solaire sans
atmosphère.
Ah d'accord.
Et que ça servirait dans un des trucs
parce que là le la fusion dans pas tout
à l'heure c'était tricium et là ça
serait hlium 3 avec.
Du coup c'est diffus. Du coup il y en a
partout. Donc ça veut dire que c'est de
l'industrie minière quoi. Il faut
extraire purifier séparer je sais pas
quoi.
Ouais
je je je vois pas ça. La la ce qu'on
envisage aujourd'hui dans l'occupation
lunaire ou dans l'occupation martienne
c'est d'aller faire une prison.
Pour qui ? Pour milliardaire. Bah pour
cel pour l'astronaute enfin je veux dire
il sera dans un endroit dont il pourra
pas sortir sauf en scafandre enfin ça
s'appelle une prison quoi. Je veux dire
qui a envie d'être dans un bâtiment dont
il peut pas sortir ? Euh personne.
On va terraformé Mars. Non je crois je
croyais qu'on allait terraformé Mars.
Enfin je veux dire euh et on peut pas
garder une atmosphère sur Mars parce que
la masse de Mars est trop petite. Euh
donc ça
il y a le champ magnétique qui est
compliqué.
Oui même ça ça se barre. Euh un des
trucs qu'il faut savoir, c'est que sur
Terre, la raison pour laquelle on a
conservé de l'eau, c'est à cause de la
couche d'ozone.
Hm.
Euh parce que en fait, l'ozone
stratosphérique qui absorbe les
ultraviolets du soleil crée ce qu'on
appelle une inversion de température
dans l'atmosphère. C'estàd la
température diminue à mesure qu'on
s'élève tant qu'on est dans la plus
basse couche, ce qu'on appelle la
troposphère, celle qui perd du sol. Et
quand on arrive dans la stratosphère,
c'est l'inverse. La température se met à
augmenter avec l'altitude à cause de la
présence d'ozone. Or, ça
thermodynamiquement, ça a une importance
capitale, c'est que ça limite la
convexion atmosphérique à la séparation
entre la troposphère et la stratosphère.
La détente diabtique permet de monter
au-dessus quand ça se réchauffe. Ça
marche tant que la température se
refroidit avec l'altitude. Euh et donc
et donc ça empêche la vapeur d'eau
d'être exposé au rayonnement ultraviolet
du soleil, ce qui la conduirait à être
dissocié et l'hydrogène à s'échapper
vers l'espace parce que la l'attraction
de la Terre est pas suffisante pour
retenir l'hydrogène dans l'atmosphère.
Donc euh le fait que
j' vu un autre exemple mais c'est sans
doute trop vieux. Moi je mais ce qui
ressemble non c'était qu'il y avait bien
il y avait dissociation mais je pense
qu'en fait les deux marches mais la
tienne doit être plus vraie euh qu'il y
avait dissociation mais que le
l'hydrogène libre du coup qui
effectivement partirait se recombinait
avec l'ozone qui lui-même est recréé
également du coup ça redescendait sous
for dissociation parce que la convection
se passe sous la couche sous
l'absorption des ultraviolets. Donc euh
donc euh
voilà mais euh on sera sera not
bon ben ça ça rien que ça. Bon il m'a
taquiné. Il a eu raison du reste
corrigé.
Allez pas vous mettre à table tous les
deux à côté hein.
Euh donc il a il a donc euh qu'est-ce
que dire ?
Je sais pas. Bah l'eau l'eau qui a sur
terre tu en a pas sur Mars. Donc l'eau.
Donc donc l'eau reste donc l'eau est
restée sur terre alors que euh sans
atmosphère en fait elle serait pas
restée. Euh voilà. Donc sur Mars, euh il
y a il y a enfin, je veux dire, on peut
terraformer Mars, c'est pas possible euh
à cause de plein de pour plein de
raisons. Euh voilà euh quoi que Musk en
pense. Euh
alors pourquoi pourquoi il buz ça à fond
?
Bah parce qu'il buz n'importe quoi.
Enfin, je veux dire euh le problème de
Mosque c'est de buzzer.
Philippe.
Ouais. Alors du coup euh quand on
revient un peu sur leur sur les rêves et
ce qu'ils nous vendent euh
il vend des fusées quand même.
Oui. Oui. Mais alors il paraît que c'est
pas si rentable que ça euh que que le
tourisme spatial aujourd'hui par exle
serait pas euh serait pas euh serait pas
rentable. Donc en fait ça serait
vraiment que une manière d'afficher et
puis de d'avoir un peu de gagner en
influence quoi. Peut-être je sais pas.
Euh alors ils sont pas tout à fait sur
le même truc hein. Donc effectivement
Musk il est sur Mars. Bessos il est sur
il est plutôt sur la Lune et sur
l'espace dans des sans partagé
le système solaire. station orbitale qui
qui tourne sur elle-même pour assurer la
la pesanteur qui en fait sont des trucs
sont un prof qu'il a eu à Prinstone dans
les années 70 s'appelle Jéronil pour les
amateurs avait avait développé c'est
assez marrant parce qu'il y a une petite
battle hein parce que tu sens par
exemple Bos dit c'est complètement
stupide pardon ouais une petite mais du
coup c'est un américaine donc c'est la
batt battle euh entre les deux euh parce
qu'en fait Bos dit et c'est pas tout à
fait idiot d'ailleurs ça il le tient de
au nail justement que c'est stupide
d'aller s'installer sur sur Mars.
Parce qu'en fait pour décoller et
atterrir, tu tu subis quand même une
gravité très importante, certes moin que
la terre mais c'est c'est vraiment
énergivor en fait de de te poser et de
repartir. Et donc d'un point de vue
logistique, c'est un peu stupide parce
que si tu restes dans l'espace là pour
le coup c'est génial, tu as plus de
gravité et le coût du transport devient
presque nul. J'exagère mais ils disent
je vais à la ceinture d'astéroïde, je
vais chercher des trucs là-bas, du
mineret de fer, du manganaise et tout
ça, du molibden, je pousse un peu, c'est
gratuit, ça revient. J'ai j'ai juste
besoin de
la ceinture d'ailleurs
hein.
La ceinture de comment elle s'appelle ?
D'astéroïde, c'est un nom ? Non.
Hm, je crois pas. Là, tu confonds pas
avec Creeper qui est plus loin que le
système solaire. H tu de
Ah non, nuage de et tout, c'est plus
loin. Non, tu es tu es au-delà de Pluton
et tout. Non, pour moi c'est la
ceinture, moi j'ai toujours entendu dire
ce
qui se balade entre Mars et Jupiter ou
c'est la ceinture d'astéroïde
le périphérique.
Ouais, c'est ça. Pas très donc en fait
donc du coup dans le en gros voilà dans
l'espace libre et ben en fait voilà tu
as pas de frottement quasiment pas et
donc du coup tu peux faire plein de
choses avec très peu d'énergie. Donc
donc du coup l'idée de Nail et donc a
été reprise par Bessos, c'est ça, c'est
de dire finalement on se met dans
l'espace alors soit au point de la
grange, c'estàdire un endroit où on
dérive pas trop entre la Lune et le et
le et le et la Terre, soit voilà, il y a
plusieurs possibilités et puis en fait
on industrialise l'espace effectivement
en disant on va mettre toutes les
industries polvantes là-haut et puis en
bas sur terre, ça sera super. On aura
que des villes, tu vois, des smart city
sympas avec les robots tout à l'heure
qui nous servent des coch qui est
relativement pragmatique.
Et effectivement le sujet c'est de de
dire alors en fait tu
faut quand même faire rentrer tout ça
dans l'atmosphère hein.
Alors exactement faut le faire rentrer.
Il faut sortir une dotation initiale qui
était celle que tu disais tout à l'heure
donc au kilot de matériel pour envoyer
pour commencer une exploitation. Tu as
un truc à faire. C'est pour ça qu'en
général dans la science-fiction il
commence par mettre au point l'ascenseur
spatial
hein. Tu vois ce que c'est l'ascenseur
spatial ? Donc c'est un truc avec des
câbles qui sont quand même assez solides
parce que ça fait quelques dizaines de
kilomètres de
toi
euh d'asimov tu veux dire ça se regarde
ça se lit non
ouais ça se regarde ça se lit j'ai pas
regardé j'ai lu il y a longtemps
regarde regarde sur je crois que c'est
on va faire un peu de pub on fait de la
pub non paramo plus non Apple TV pardon
d'accord ok pas v
regarde à un moment fondation c'est une
très b très belle série ça se passe bien
bon ce genre de technologie d'ailleurs
la
voilà donc l'idée c'est de trucs avec
des fibres de je sais pas quoi, des
machins en poil d'araignée, tout ça,
hop, hyper solide et donc tu as 100 km
et en fait le poids de ton câble fait
que tu tiens en fait grâce à juste la
force centrifuge et donc après tu peux
monter, descendre des trucs, c'est
beaucoup moins compliqué que d'envoyer
une fusée.
Et donc avec ça, alors il y a des gens
qui bossent là-dessus hein. Alors c'est
pas des start-up et tout mais je pense
au CNRS et tout, tu peux trouver des
gens qui essayent de faire des calculs
sur quelle serait la taille du câble, la
section et en quoi il faudrait qu'il
soit fait et cetera. On y est pas, on y
trouvé la bonne araignée. On y est pas
encore ça va être compliqué. Donc je
pense qu'effectivement c'est juste pas
possible. Mais effectivement il y a pour
moi tout simplement c'est que ça ça on
se vend un peu un rêve de conquête de
l'espace. Bah parce que d'abord c'est ça
c'estz sympa, tu vois. Il y a cette
idée, ça fait un siècle que ça traîne
au moins. On dit bah le c'est le la
terre c'est le berceau de l'humanité
mais on reste pas toute sa vie dans un
berceau hein. On sort du berceau après.
Donc c'est normal, on va faire la
conquête. Puis on a tous été bibonné à
la science-fiction euh y compris Jeff
Bessos. Il avait je sais pas 14 15 ans
quand Star Wars est sorti. Euh bon ben
voilà quoi, on a tous été marqué euh
dans cette génération-là.
Ça ça paraît presque naturel et c'est
vrai que du coup il y a des percés on
pourrait dire un peu technologiques.
Alors j'ai entendu dire c'est le le bon
mot n'est pas de moi, mais je trouve le
mot tellement bien que je je le répète
mais euh avec la récupération par
exemple du premier étage là ou enfin de
la fusée qu' a eu récemment là par tu
fais bien la récupération de fusée fer
refait avec tes petits bras
comme ça. Vo
voilà c'est récupéré et donc et donc la
question c'est en fait c'est à quoi ça
sert en fait parce que oui c'est c'est
une prouesse technique il y a pas de
problème. On sent tous les calculs qu'il
y a derrière et tout.
Je suis même pas sûr qu'il réutilise et
tout mais et donc j'ai le bon mot que
j'ai entendu c'était que c'était du
porno pour ingénieur. Je trouve ça assez
assez mignon. C'est c'est vrai que c'est
tous les je pense que tous les gens qui
imaginent pardon je je fais mal le le
truc mais le qui imagine tout ce qui
peut comme calcul et comme complexité
technique derrière se disent "Ah ouais
c'est vraiment waouh quelle prouesse
effectivement." Alors Jean-Marc porno
ingénieur raconte un peu.
C'est c'est Philippe qui parle du porno
pour ingénieur. Moi je
Bon ça sera la punchline utiliser tout
on verra. Ça fera des haters en fait, tu
vois, tous les gens qui trouvent que
c'est vraiment génial la disruption dans
le spatial et qu'on va faire pareil dans
les SMR et tout parce qu'en fait voilà
et dans la fusion nucléaire parce qu'en
fait il y a pas que Ier, on va faire des
trucs, vous allez voir ce que vous allez
voir parce qu'évidemment les les les
start-ups qui sont lancés dans la fusion
nucléaire, ils ont pas des business
plans en 2090 hein. Ils promettent pas
18 mois non plus hein, comme dans la
salle des CONVallet, mais ils sont à 10
ans 15 ans, 20 ans maxi pour un peu
attirer quand même des capitaux privés
ou ou semi-privés quoi. Donc pour moi en
fait c'est quand ils sont juste dans un
univers effectivement. Alors, j'ai
appelé Cornucopien dans un truc dont tu
feras la pub après là euh qui donc
Cornucopien donc c'est ton voisin qui
qui fera la pub. Moi je fais pas de pub.
Et donc le le cette idée que que en fait
on va de toujours plus et que
l'innovation technologique en fait elle
va nous permettre de continuer quelque
part à consommer toujours plus que de
toute façon on en a besoin. C'est
inéluctable et et donc ça sera avec
l'énergie, les matériaux. Donc l'énergie
bah ça sera ça sera des panneaux
photovoltaïques, pourquoi pas dans
l'espace, j'en sais rien avec des rayons
lasers qui redescendront l'énergie sur
terre et puis ça
pour des trucs comme ça. C'est ça. Géo
ingénierie, ça en fait partie un peu au
miroir pour éclairer.
Non non, le panneau des panneaux des
grandes centrales solaires dans l'espace
avec l'énergie qui redescend sur terre
sous forme de rayonnement là enfin sous
forme d'onde. Ça c'est des choses, c'est
des projets. Il y a des gens qui
travaillent dessus. H
c'est pas déconnant.
C'est pas déconnant dans son principe.
Après, ce qui peut être éventuellement
déconnant, c'est les ordres de grandeur
associé. C'estàd qu'on peut se dire ce
trucl va nous permettre de remplacer la
moitié du charbon plus les deux tiers du
gaz plus un/art du bois et cetera. Et
là, ça devient déconnant parce que les
ordres de grandeur n'y seront pas. Une
quantité envoyé. Philippe, tu parlais de
berceau ?
Ouais.
Berceau de l'humanité, berceau de
machin. Question. Euh, on est sur on est
naufragé,
on arrive sur une petite île déserte.
Déjà faut la trouver sans sans morceaux
de plastique, sans rien. C'est difficile
hein aujourd'hui
commence pas à compliquer les choses
s'il te plaît.
Il y a que trois cocotiers.
Hm
hm. On est tous les trois. Bon
Jean-Marc, c'est le plus petit. On le
mange au bout de la première semaine.
C'est surtout le plus vieux.
Je suis le plus vieux et le plus corias
aussi. Faut bien voir ça. Tu es
peut-être le moin con. Tu vas trouver
des moyens de nous empoisonner, ça c'est
sûr.
Et donc trêve de plaisanterie. On arrive
sur cette île. Il y a trois cocotiers.
On a le choix, on fait de l'élevage de
coco puis on mange plus que des noix de
coco ou sinon on coupe tous les cocotis,
on fait un radeau et on tente
de filer
de filer. Est-ce que vous voyez le
parallèle avec notre monde
h
et notre île déserte,
est-ce qu'il faut se barrer de la terre
ou est-ce qu'on va pas pouvoir se barrer
de la terre ?
Ah bah à 8 milliards, on va pas pouvoir
se barrer de la terre. C'est absolument
évident. Non mais on va laisser les guux
comme dirait Bruno le même les guux ils
sont mais sauf que les guux sont
nécessaires aux milliardaires. C'est la
fameuse de tout à l'heure
l'instant.
Ben mais tout le temps euh tout le temps
parce que aujourd'hui je veux dire dans
une fois qu'on est sur Mars là comment
on bouffe ?
Comment on fait un champ de carotte sur
Mars ou sur la Lune ?
Mais mais d'ailleurs Musk en fait même
Musk pourtant dit pas que qu'il faut
aller sur Mars pour se barrer de la
terre qui serait trop pollué je sais pas
quoi en fait. Mosque, il est sur un truc
un peu messianique de dire il faut un
plan B s'il y a un astéroïde qui se
pointe euh ou alors peut-être une guerre
nucléaire, j'en sais rien. Mais je crois
que c'est à limite prenons juste un
facteur exogène quoi. Tous les 60
millions d'années, il y a un truc qui
tombe un peu gros, ça fait de la
poussière pendant quelques années, c'est
pas sympa. Bon donc lui il dit bah comme
ça on a ensemancé quelque part à l'autre
endroit puis après on peut peut-être
revenir quoi. Je pense c'est plutôt
c'est ça l'idée. Il y a pas l'idée de se
se tirer en disant c'est tellement
pollué ici qu' faut aller tout à l'heure
tout su tout le temps.
Oui. Ah bah ça
donc sur la Lune ou sur la Mars la base
il y a des machines qui vont fuser
logistiquement. Faudra
et la logistique qui permet de les
renouveler aujourd'hui les terrestres.
L'enfer. Mais bien sûr. Mais oui
je veux dire ça n'a pas de sens. L'idée
queon va pouvoir faire une quelque chose
de totalement indépendant de ce qui se
passe sur terre.
Je veux dire dans cette base il y aura
quelques puces. H
ces puces auront été fondues par notre
fondeur taïwanais de enfin je veux dire
qui qui qui qu'est-ce que tu on va pas
mettre un fondeur de semiconducteur sur
Mars. Enfin je donc
il a une échelle à partir de laquelle tu
peux pas tout faire
donc mais on peut rien faire tu fais
rien
en fait c'est c'est un pseudopode. Ce
trucl ne pourra jamais rester rien
d'autre qu'un pseudopode de la
civilisation terrestre. C'est juste
impossible qu'il en soit autrement. H
on est d'accord.
Question internet.
Si nous que je découvre en même temps
que vous, si nous avions une énergie
infinie, pratiquement gratuite, ne
serait-ce fin plutôt que la solution ?
Que ferions-nous de cette énergie ? Ne
serait-ce pas un ticket pour transformer
notre environnement en parking de
supermarché ?
Alors, on ferait bien pire que ça dans
le premier bouquin que j'avais écrit il
y a fort longtemps
en 1852. Euh non, un tout petit peu
après ça quand même
euh qui s'appelait l'avenir climatique,
euh j'avais eu cette réflexion justement
en disant l'énergie infinie serait une
calamité euh parce qu'on aurait un
pouvoir de destruction infini chacun et
comme on changerait pas la nature
humaine euh on s'en servirait notamment
pour ce qui maintenant occupe
les gens dans les guerres de Titan là ou
voilà. Donc c'est évident. Donc ah
l'immeuble dans lequel on on est me
plaît pas. J'ai une énergie infinie,
pouf, je te le détruis. Et puis toi tu
dis bah tiens, tu m'as fait ça. Bah
tiens, tu vas voir. Et moi la forêt qui
est à côté de chez toi, pouf, je te la
crame. Enfin bref, c'est c'est ça serait
une absolue catastrophe si on avait une
énergie infinie. Donc la solution à nos
problèmes, c'est pas du tout de rêver
d'infini. C'est une forme de stoïisme
quelque part. C'est-à-dire la solution,
elle est dans nos cervelles. Il faut
arriver à à à à trouver de l'espoir et
du bonheur dans un monde avec des
limites. C'est ça notre notre sujet
aujourd'hui. C'est pas tellement de
rêver d'infini. Rêver d'infini, c'est la
frustration perpétuelle. On va jamais
être heureux si on fait ça. F
Ouais, ouais, pas mieux. Ouais, mais
bien sûr. Bah, tu le dis souvent que
l'énergie c'est la capacité à
transformer le monde, à transformer les
matières, à bouger des roches, à faire
des terrassement, je sais pas quoi. Donc
c'est sûr qu'une énergie infinie
appliquée à la finitude terrestre, on se
retrouverait, je sais pas moi, avec des
autoroutes sur piloti qui traverseraiit
l'Atlantique avec des hyper
instantanément.
Donc c'est sans doute pas souhaitable.
Par contre, par contre, il y a un peu
cette idée quand même ce fantasme là,
c'est c'est William Nordous qui est
quand même, c'est pas un il a été pris
prix Nobel, enfin pris de la Banque
Royale de Suède d'économie en 2018, je
crois avec Paul Romer, un spécialiste de
de l'innovation, un autre économiste et
qui écrit dans les années 70 en réponse
au rapport Midos, au rapport au club de
Rome qui donc qui énerve beaucoup
d'économistes he parce que ils sont sur
cette logique de la croissance infinie
va pas être possible. et il écrit un
long papier et dans lequel il y a la
backstop technologie, la la technologie
filet de sécurité euh qui est en fait la
fusion hein, il la nomme pas mais c'est
ça l'idée. et dit bah on va avoir une
énergie infinie. Et grâce à ça, mais en
fait l'équipe Midos se trompe quoi parce
que on va avoir l'énergie infinie donc
on va pouvoir continuer la croissance
habitable éternalable ce qui évidemment
complètement stupide et ça se montre
assez facilement avec une pauvre courbe
exponentielle un tableau Excel vous
faites 1,02 puissance 1000 c'est-à-dire
un taux de croissance de 2 % par an
pendant 1000 ans et ça fait 400 millions
un peu de choses près. Donc ça veut dire
que vous on va pas multiplier le PIB de
la terre par 400 millions en faisant 2 %
de croissance par an du PIB mondial
pendant le prochain millénaire. Est-ce
que effectivement on aura du mal à
dématérialiser même avec des supers
ingénieurs. Donc c'est stupide. Donc il
y a donc effectivement cette courbe de
croissance
qui a aussi fait la courbe de croissance
énergétique ou qui alors je sais pas si
l'un est précurseur de l'autre. Je sais
que tuas tu as une opinion là-dessus
mais le cette croissance matérielle et
cetera et bien c'est une espèce de
parenthèse quelque part pour moi de de
l'humanité. Et après alors comment ça
redescend et sous quelle forme on peut
réfléchir mais ça peut pas continuer
dans une courbe de croissance
euh sur laquelle assise tout notre
système économique et la civilisation
industrielle quoi.
En fait en Europe on est déjà en
décroissance. Tout à l'heure on parlait
des lubrifiants. Euh moi, il y a deux
indicateurs
ou après le porno d'ingénieur
bah en même temps, c'est mieux
euh il vaut mieux. Et donc
la les deux moi il y a deux indicateurs
que je regarde depuis longtemps
maintenant qui me semblent caractériser
qui me semblent être des agrégat ou des
proxis intéressants de l'économie
physique. Le premier indicateur que je
regarde c'est les tonnes chargées dans
les camions dans l'année.
Euh parce que en gros à peu près tout ce
qui s'achète et se vend sera passé par
un camion.
À peu près tout hein. Nos vêtements, nos
bues, nos ordinateurs, la bouffe et
cetera, les sacs de ciment pour rénover
la pièce, enfin tout. Non,
je peux compéter un truc.
Tu regardes le flux dans les camions,
regarde ce flux aussi le flux dans les
bateaux.
Alors pour le moment, je regarde les
Harpix
Harpex et le Baltic. OK. Dry index.
Alors ça ça pour le moment je parle des
camions parce que de toute façon tout ce
qui sera déchargé en France ingénieur
toi. Non les petites voitures camion
tout ce qui sera Non mais tout ce qui
sera déchargé en France et en Europe et
qui n'est pas du vrac liquide donc du
pétrole en gros qui va passer par des
oléoduc passera aussi en gros à un
moment par un camion. D'accord le
conteneur ira sur un camion c'est très
peu de marchandises vont sur le train en
internçir un peu quand même
en arrièrepl et ça finira aussi.
Il se trouve que je faire une vanne
faire une vanne le transport ferroviaire
son est où ? On a pas dégagé faire une
émission fera la blague après. Laisse
terminer.
Et donc cet indicateur en France comme
en Europe baisse depuis 2007 en
tendance. D'accord. Donc depuis depuis
2007 moi pour moi ce marqueur de
l'économie physique parce qu'il agrége
la quantité de voitures qu'on produit,
d'appareils photo qu'on produit,
d'oranges qu'on consomme de enfin et
cetera baisse depuis 2007. Et le
deuxième indicateur que je regarde
depuis très longtemps, c'est les mètres
carrés construits dans l'année. Chacun
connaît quand le bâtiment va tout. C'est
pareil, l'index de la construction en
Europe baisse depuis 2007. D'accord ?
Donc c'est pas c'est pas il y a pas
juste un problème conjoncturel sur la
promotion, je sais pas quoi. C'est un
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en 2007 en
Europe ? On est passé par le maximum de
l'approvisionnement énergétique
européen. Bon donc pour moi la
décroissance en Europe, elle a déjà
commencé physiquement.
Les gens qui sont pas complètement cons
le ressentent.
Euh et euh c'est un c'est une
explication pour moi directe de ce qu'on
est en train d'observer euh en monté des
mouvements protestataires euh parce que
les gens pas totalement cons
parce que les gens sont pas complètement
idiots euh ressentent une forme de
réalité. En fait même sur le revenu
disponible des ménages en France, il y a
quasiment plus de croissance depuis
2010. Il y avait une éion légère jusqu'à
il y a quelques années. C'est un tout
petit peu remonté mais enfin en gros
c'est stable quoi. Donc il y a plus de
croissance non plus. et le taux des
dépenses contraintes a augmenté. Donc du
coup le sentiment de de de d'inconfort
augmente. Euh rajoutons à ça que en plus
la population est en train de se séparer
entre les gagnants de la mondialisation
et les autres. euh les gagnants de la
mondialisation gagnant de plus en plus.
Donc parce que eux en fait ils
bénéficient de la croissance qui
continue ailleurs. Euh et donc on est on
est on est directement pour moi en train
de décrire ce qui est en train de se
passer dans le pays. Et c'est pas le
fait de jeter l'anathème sur les gens
qui en profitent électoralement qui va
changer quoi que ce soit. On peut dire
que c'est des abrutis, ça ne changera
strictement rien. Du reste, ça fait 40
ans que les gens d'en face disent que
c'est des abrutis et ça fait 40 ans que
ça ne change rien. Bon, euh ce qui
changera quelque chose, c'est de
comprendre la réalité physique
sous-jacente qui est déjà à l'œuvre et
qui est celle que je décris,
c'est-à-dire des flux physiques qui sont
déjà en train de baisser et donc une
réalité physique qui est déjà un peu
plus inconfortable. Alors, on n'est pas
encore totalement à poil, hein. On reste
une nation très industrialisée avec 40
m² habitable par personne en moyen et
cetera. Reste quand même du gras, hein.
Mais quand même, globalement, la
dynamique est pas dans le bon sens. Euh
et les chiffres du PIB masquent cette
réalité physique parce que il y a des
artefacts comptables dans tous les sens
et qu'en fait on sait et qu'on Non non
non non, même le pays, on sait plus trop
ce qu'on compte en fait. Euh bon,
j'avais fait un autre petit calcul
d'ordre de grandeur rigolo un jour parce
que je c'est passe mon temps à faire ça
de temps en temps. On a à peu près un
qu'est-ce que je m'emmerde absolument.
On a à peu près 1 milliard d'objets
disponibles à la consommation finale en
France. Il y a 10 personnes à l'INC pour
faire la correction de l'inflation.
Donc, j'avais calculé que en imaginant
que ces gens-là ne mangent pas, ne
dorment pas, ne prennent jamais de
vacances et cetera, ça faisait moins
d'une seconde par objet à déflatter.
Bon, c'est donc c'est évident que ils
peuvent pas faire comme ça. Donc c'est
évident qu'ils choisissent des
conventions, des proxy. En fait, même la
correction de l'inflation est une
convention. Euh à ça que tu as tu as
pardon tu as tu as l'inflation mais tu
as en plus les prix ce qu'on appelle je
sais pas quoi les prix héonistes ou un
truc comme ça. Le fait de dire si ton
forfait internet était à 30 € pour 1 Go
ça devient un forfait internet 30 € pour
2 Go. Ben on fait comme si tu payais
moins cher mais tu payes toujours 30 €.
Oui oui mais ça ça fait partie des ça
fait partie des conventions parce que
dans le même temps la qualité la
résolution de l'image fait que peut-être
avec 2 G tu vas quand même consommer
moins de minutes de film. Enfin donc en
fait on peut toutes les
conventions qu'on veut dans tous les
sens. Aujourd'hui, la correction de
l'inflation est devenue un truc
conventionnel. C'est ça que je voulais
dire. Donc en fait, on sait plus trop ce
qu'on mesure. On ne sait plus. D'accord
? Moi le le message que je envoyé, c'est
"On croit qu'on sait parce queon fait
des trucs par habitude, mais on confond
l'habitude et la compréhension de ce
qu'on fait." Bon euh et donc mon s moi
pour regarder des indicateurs physiques
parce que la physique elle ment pas. 1 m
cou 1 m c une tonne, c'est toujours une
tonne. Euh
cm toujours
1 cm toujours 1 cm. Je vois qu'on
revient après des lubrifiants. Euh et
donc euh chass naturel hein. Et donc euh
le le si on regarde l'économie physique,
ne te fait pas ton malin. Ouais, c'est
pas moi qui fait le malin en ce moment.
Bon euh parce que les auditeurs ne
peuvent pas voir le sourire narquis des
gens du type qui nous interrogent, c'est
dommage mais bon. Euh et donc si on
regarde l'économie physique, en fait,
cette économie physique qui ment pas
trop, j'ai envie de dire, elle elle
raconte une histoire qui n'est pas du
tout l'histoire que racontent
aujourd'hui les indicateurs économiques
conventionnels. Donc tout ça pour dire
que quand on parle de décroissance
future, parce que mon ami de gauche
parle de décroissance future, moi je dis
eux méfions-nous du mot futur. Euh moi
je pense que c'est pas du tout sûr queon
parle de futur. Et il y a même des pays
dans lesquels il y a des indicateurs
comme par exemple l'Espérance de vie ou
par exemple les États-Unis, ils sont sur
de ce point de vue aussi
alors je sais pas si c'est pérenne mais
en tout cas ils ont inversé la courbe il
y a maintenant quelques années. Euh
voilà, donc je je pense qu'il y a une
réalité euh aujourd'hui que nos
instruments conventionnels perçoivent de
moins en moins bien. Et je pense que
cette notion de c'est pour plus tard les
emmerdements,
je pense que non. Je pense que
malheureusement c'est pour il ils ont
commencé maintenant et on envoie la
traduction politique maintenant et si on
ne comprend pas ce qui est en train de
se passer euh et si on prend pas le
problème à la racine c'estàd pas en
jetant l'anathème sur les gens qui en
profitent mais en allant s'intéresser au
truc à la racine euh je vois pas de
raison pour laquelle euh tout d'un coup
la situation à la tête s'améliorerait
significativement.
Jean-Marc Philippe la situation à la
tête tu parles de ceux qui nous dirigent
? Oui, enfin je parle de ce qu'on
appelle typiquement la classe politique.
Bon, non, mais la classe politique,
est-ce qu'il faudrait pas que les
ingénieurs reprennent le pouvoir ?
Enfin, reprennent pourquoi reprennent ?
Ils l'ont jamais eu. Si. Euh,
je dirais des vrais intellectuels, pas
des des faussets.
Alors, ils l'ont un peu plus eu à
l'époque de la monarchie. Euh parce que
si tu veux parler, tuites pas.
Non, non, mais parce que est à enfin sur
la fin de la monarchie en France, il y a
quand même eu Louis XIV, Louis XV. et
cetera. Ils ont ils ont quand même bah
ils ont eu tout un corps d'ingénieur euh
certains d'entre eux étant devenu très
célèbre, Voban et cetera, euh qui est
qui était le bras armé du pouvoir.
C'est-à-dire que à cette époque-là euh
le le pouvoir était effectivement royal
euh mais les corps d'ingénieur
exerçaient de fait un pouvoir euh de
d'exécution de de mise en œuvre qui
était un pouvoir euh cit mais c'était
très lié à l'armée de jusqu'à jusqu'à la
fin du 18e. Oui. Peut-être l'ingénieur
c'est ingéné en balatin ou en italien
c'est le c'est celui qui maîtrise les
engins de guerre hein. D'ailleurs,
engine engineer en anglais c'est resté
plus proche. En fait le l'étymologie les
mots sont moins déformés. Donc c'est
effectivement va banc en fait c'est
c'est l'art c'est la pollucétique c'est
mot compliqué mais voilà comme ça
j'apprends.
C'est combien de points scrabble ?
Écoute, il y a pas de il y a pas de il y
a pas de il y a pas de Y dedans. C'est
l'art de prendre les villes. L'art de
prendre les villes et l'art de les
défendre. Voilà.
Euh donc il y avait des traités de
polyur citiqu voilà qui où tu devais
faire des tu avais des canons avec une
certaine portée et en face de ça fallait
faire des des fortifications qui étaient
un peu avec des angles et tout ça par
rapport à où tu pouvais placer les
canons. Enfin c'était une science très
complexe. Et donc effectivement c'était
ça les ingénieurs et puis après ça sera
ça va devenir assez vite des ingénieurs
de la révolution industrielle. Donc des
mines, des routes, des ch des des ponts,
des chaussées et euh mais après ouais
assez vite
non, il y a une il y a une influence
enfin je crois qu'il y a des des des
beaux textes d'historien sur par exemple
au début du sous Napoléon, début du 19e,
sur finalement le le rapport par la
question de la pollution industrielle
qu'on vont se développer des des des
sous des sousères, des trucs de
production d'acide sulfurique qui vont
abîmer les champs des paysans autour et
cetera. des lois qui sont passées à ce
moment-là, la loi le chapelier et tout
où il y a eu effectivement des
allers-retours un peu entre des des
grands chimistes, ingénieurs et cetera,
un peu les gars de la rue quoi de du
début du 19e et puis effectivement le
pouvoir politique qui était à l'écoute
de ça pour développer et sucer la roue
quelque part de de de l'Angleterre qui
elle avait un peu démarré sa révolution
industrielle. Mais depuis là, bon si
après sous de Gaulle et tout sans doute
un peu aussi
non ? Ce que je voulais dire c'est
qu'ils ont été proches du pouvoir et au
service du pouvoir. Moi, je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui ils en sont plutôt plus
distants.
Euh mais ils n'ont jamais eu le pouvoir.
Et en fait, depuis qu'on est en
démocratie, c'est pas à eux qu'on qu'on
fit le pouvoir. Il le revendiquent pas,
enfin, je veux dire, il revendiquent
d'être au service du pouvoir, ça oui,
mais il revendique pas d'avoir le
pouvoir.
Un ingénieur qui se penche sur la
situation actuelle, il perd ses cheveux.
pas que les ingénieurs du reste. Enfin,
je veux dire euh
il y a il y a plein de gens qui sont pas
ingénieurs. Euh j'ai envie de dire qui
juste en prenant le temps de regarder
d'un peu près et en prenant le temps de
décortiquer un peu et a et avec un
capacité à avoir un peu une vue
d'ensemble, mais bon, j'ai une affaire
de temps beaucoup euh qui sont
parfaitement capables de de se rendre
compte de la même chose. H
question Philippe, tu veux rajouter
quelque chose ?
H non, c'est c'est bon.
Question internet
que je découvre en même temps que vous.
Est-ce qu'il est-ce qu'il ne vaut pas
mieux tenter notre chance avec un musque
qui tourne sa tête vers les étoiles et
se rêve d'une civilisation galactique
sur du long terme que d'une que d'une
humanité sobre mais qui infiné finira
par mourir par la vieillesse de notre
étoile ? La sobrineté n'est-elle pas ?
Comment
on a le temps ?
Ouais. La arrête,
je peux proposer un
Attends, attends, laisse-moi terminer
s'il te plaît. Respecte celui qui pose
la question.
La sobriété n'est-elle donc pas un
accélérateur de notre déclin ?
Ah
non, pas que le chemin actuel ne soit
vertueux. Philippe ?
Non non mais question très intéressante
sur finalement les récits les
imaginaires parce que c'est ça qui nous
qui qui peut porter et qui on voit bien
d'ailleurs dans le dans l'élection
américaine ça va être un je vais pas
faire le super analyste he mais bon
voilà il y a un peu un côté du récit mec
américain grugen on retourne sur la lune
et cetera donc on voit bien que c'est
important mais alors d'abord on n pas
tant de temps que ça parce qu'en fait
c'est pas tellement quand l'étoile va
mourir c'est elle va passer par une
phase d'abord d'expansion un peu pénible
qui fait que normalement tous les font
sont vaporisés Tout ça dans je crois que
c'est dans 4 500 millions d'années hein.
Donc
c'est un peu moins que milliards il va
faire vraiment très chaud.
Donc bon voilà on peut faire des
simulations et tout ça. Moi j'avais
trouvé un papier scientifique à
l'époque. Peut-être il y en a eu
d'autres décrits depuis qu' il reste
quelques bactéries pendant quelques
centaines de millions d'années puis
après il y a plus personne. Faut faut
s'éloigner. Mais mais même sans aller
aussi loin euh tu pourrais te poser la
question disant "Mais attends, mais tu
as quand même des dangers qui peuvent
venir par exemple bah un anastéroïde, tu
vois." Donc euh
pas que dans les films avec Bruce Willis
hein, là ils ont lancé la mission d'art
pour voir s'ils arrivaient à décaler un
peu la la trajectoire, enfin l'orbite
d'un d'un petit astéroïde.
Donc cette idée que on n pas trop le
choix maintenant pour même quelque part
gérer le monde qu'on a installé
finalement avec des questions de
pollution généralisé qui donc obligent à
avoir des systèmes sanitaires très très
très puissants, des des systèmes de
dépollution de l'eau et cetera que tout
voilà tous les coûts parties finalement
nous obligent à continuer dans une
civilisation en accélération. Il y a un
peu cette idée là et donc de dire
"Attendez, on va pas revenir juste avec
l'attraction animale et puis se
débrouiller parce qu'en fait il peut
arriver des trucs tellement incroyables
climatique ou autrees que finalement
heureusement que qu'on doit gérer donc
on a pas trop le choix." Donc c'est
c'est une question assez intéressante
hein. On pourrait se dire est-ce qu'il
faut essayer d'aller vers une sorte de
civilisation un peu de hal où il y
aurait je sais pas quoi, des des
justement des ingénieurs, des
techniciens, des chercheurs qui sera un
peu comme les comme les les moines ou je
sais pas quoi dans les monastères du
Moyen-Âge et qui conserveraient en fait
une capacité technique bah pour gérer
les déchets nucléaires sur le très long
terme pour et cetera et puis qu'on
aurait par d'autres gens qui au
contraire travailleraient plutôt la
question de la résilience et et qui
iraient sur des effectivement des
systèmes techniques et technologiques de
production agricole ou de production de
de voilà de de bien de matériel de
consommation un peu standard, des
chaussures, je sais pas quoi, on a pas
besoin qu'elle clignote dans la nuit
quoi. Donc ça ça c'est une question très
ouverte en fait. Il y a pas c'est pas du
tout évident. Par contre, ce que ça
ouvre, c'est le récit. Il faut un récit.
Remarque, tu veux amander un peu
en complément à ce que disait Philippe,
il y a aussi la question de est-ce qu'on
s'intéresse à la photo une fois qu'on
est arrivé ou est-ce qu'on s'intéresse
au chemin qu'on doit prendre demain ? Ce
qui est ce qui est alors moi c'est
peut-être parce que je suis euh
cl
non non non c'est c'est important c'est
pas la destination c'est le chemin c'est
ça ?
Oui enfin c'est une pour réflexion
surtout très pragmatique parce que
finalement on sort de cette pièce
qu'est-ce qu'on fait demain matin quoi.
Bon et ça c'est
à part prendre une tasse de café.
Euh mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
on a on a on a le le récit est important
parce que ça ça c'est quelque chose qui
peut emporter une motivation, qui peut
emporter une cohésion globale, qui peut
emporter et cetera. Mais il y a aussi
des questions de choix au quotidien.
Et dans les choix au quotidien, il y a
des domaines dans lesquels ça vaut le
coup d'arbitrer ou de faire le pari de
la technologie. Il y a des choix dans
lesquels ça vaut le coup de plutôt miser
sur la sobriété. Euh, on parlait tout à
l'heure des véhicules électriques. Les
véhicules électriques, je pense que
c'est un exemple emblématique dans
lequel il faut marier les deux. Euh
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut à la fois marier
la technologie parce que il faut avoir
des véhicules électriques qui
fonctionnent bien et en même temps il
faut le faire de manière sobre parce que
euh plus on est sobre un véhicule donné,
plus vite on va diffuser la technologie
à tout le monde. Donc il y a un côté de
démocratisation de la technologie qui va
avec la sobriété dans l'usage. C'est
plus facile avec de quoi faire une
batterie de voiture, on fait 100
batteries de vélo. Bon euh donc euh donc
c'est si si on veut de la mobilité
individuelle euh pour pas cher et
rapidement et ben c'est plus social de
faire des petits véhicules euh que de
faire des gros.
Ça déjà été en Inde ?
Euh non jamais été en Inde.
C'est pas mal. Euh et donc et donc voilà
donc il y a donc la la question de
l'arbitrage entre sobriété et
technologie en fait c'est pas blanc et
noir pour l'ensemble du monde. Euh ça se
moi je moi j'aime bien regarder les
choses au cas par cas de façon un peu
pragmatique en se disant dans ce tru-là
euh qu qu quelle est la part comment
est-ce qu'on arbitre entre
éventuellement une part de renoncement
parce que finalement on s'en portera pas
plus mal. J'ai porté parlé du sucre tout
à l'heure. Si on mange moins de sucre
d'un renoncement pur, on s'intéresse pas
à savoir si on va faire le sucre de
manière plus propre. On s'en fout un
peu.
Euh et on se dit globalement on s'en
portera pas plus mal.
Tu connais la la fin du renoncement de
Saint-Pierre ?
Non, je connais rien. Moi, je suis un Il
faut faire il faut faire attention aux
gens que t'invitent ici parce que
vraiment il y a moi qui
continue quoi.
Euh la il y a des domaines dans lesquels
en fait on s'en sortira pas sans une
zone de technologie. On parlait tout à
l'heure de l'électricité qu' s'agisse de
l'éolien, des panneaux solaires ou du
nucléaire. De toute façon, il y a une
dose de technologie dans ces trucs-là.
Et si on est incapable de maintenir la
moindre technologie, de toute façon, on
n'aura pas ces trucs-là.
Euh et puis il y a des il y a des cas de
figures dans lesquelles il faut vraiment
aller à fond sur la sobriété,
c'est-à-dire on renonce pas à l'usage
mais on essaie de de de minimiser le ce
que ça mobilise comme ressources, comme
matériaux, comme et cetera et en se
disant que on sera pas plus malheureux
si on s'organise bien. Voilà. Et je
pense pas qu'il faille nécessairement
toujours se dire je choisis qu'une voix
et puis c'est celle-là la bonne dans
tous les cas de figure.
Ça t'intéresse pas le renoncement de
Saint-Pierre ?
Ça m'intéresse beaucoup. Tu m'as demandé
si je connaissais. Quant à moi, je
sortirai de ce monde où l'action n'est
pas sœur du rêve. Ah !
Question internet. Comment espérer que
la population occidentale s'empare des
problèmes écologiques quand elle vit
dans le confort de ces 600 esclaves
énergétiques et qu'elle a pas la
nécessité que ça change ?
Alors, je pense qu'elle a la nécessité
que ça change. C'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure parce que la
décroissance, elle a déjà commencé. Euh
donc en fait, les 600, ils sont déjà en
train de donir 550. Euh et donc euh on a
tout à fait la mais c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure en fait, on on ne
on ne s'en rend pas compte parce que
c'est pas ça fait pas partie de truc
qu'on monitore au quotidien. Euh au
quotidien on monitore que des
conventions économiques. Euh on ne
regarde pas les la physique
sous-jacente. Euh et avant que ça se
passe à large échelle, il va se passer
du temps parce que ça veut dire que le
système médiatique dans son ensemble
doit devenir acculturé à manipuler des
indicateurs qui sont différents de ceux
qui manipulent. Euh ça veut dire que les
gens qui écrivent des bouquins doivent
se mettre à écrire des bouquins avec euh
des thèmes sous-jacents qui sont pas les
mêmes. Ça va et cetera. Donc euh c'est
Non mais malheureusement ça sera long
euh ou en tout cas ça peut pas être très
rapide. Euh mais voilà. question
bah oui si c'est on voit toujours un peu
ce qu'on ce qu'on risque de perdre mais
pas ce qu'on peut regagner aussi hein
enfin une civilisation de la sortie où
tu sors de la voiture généralisée pour
tout le monde je sais pas quoi, bah tu
as moins d'embouteillage, tu as moins de
bruit, tu as moins de stress, tuas les
enfants qui jouent dans la rue, tu as
les parkings où tu mets des tables de
ping-pong à la place, enfin je sais pas,
tu peux imaginer 1000 choses. On va dire
"Ah, c'est un bobo de métropole qui
raconte ça, mais moi dans la campagne,
non, mais dans la campagne aussi, tu
peux imaginer plein de systèmes de de de
mobilité et puis d'ailleurs beaucoup
plus peut-être de centralité et de et et
de de de venir réinvestir aussi tout le
le vacant qu'on peut avoir, des
logements vides, des des villages qui se
sont vidés et cetera. Alors queon manque
de logement d'un côté, on a un/ers de
tous les logements en France qui sont
soit vides, soit sous-occupés dans la
définition de l'INC." Donc je veux dire,
il y a aussi dans l'histoire de la
contraction, je suis d'accord avec toi
sur le fait de dire je compte les tonnes
et donc finalement c'est en train de se
de de se contraindre mais en même temps
finalement on dire flu moi je parlais
des flux
exactement mais du coup il y a
finalement quand même dans ce qui nous
entoure et ce qui fait que voilà on a
effectivement notre petite vid
occidentale alors avec tous les tous les
inégalités qui peut y avoir bien sûr
mais
il y a quand même il y a du il y a des
sujets qui sont plutôt des sujets de
stock et d'autres des sujets de flux.
C'est-à-dire que le l'habitat, c'est
quand même d'abord et avant tout un
sujet de stock. Euh et imaginons queon
aurait une population stable euh et
qu'il y aurait pas les le puissant
phénomène de décohabitation et de
métropolisation qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
euh on vide d'un côté et on construit de
l'autre. Et ben la population stable
avec un stock, tu as juste à maintenir
quelque part et tu peux réduire les flux
quelque part qui qui aujourd'hui sont
nécessaires pour faire de la
construction neuve. Et puis à l'inverse,
tu as des choses qui sont des flux.
toute la nourriture, euh tout ce qui est
euh je sais pas équipements médicaux,
euh tout ce qui est euh chaussures,
fringues et cetera. Donc donc je pense
que on peut très bien vivre un monde en
relative contraction d'un certain nombre
de flux en jouant justement sur le fait
qu'il y a quelque part plutôt de des
endroits où on a un un un patrimoine
existant incroyable qui peut être du
patrimoine bâti, qui peut être du
patrimoine d'objets, qui peut être du
patrimoine de ressources qu'on a extrait
de de du sous-sol et cetera et que il y
a un terrain de jeu et et puis il y a
aussi un gâchi. C'est j'étais content,
je t'écoutais sur la la sobriété en
fait. L'idée que la sobriété, c'est pas
juste de l'austérité ou de la frugalité
personnelle. Bien sûr, il peut y avoir
des choix personnels, mais il y a c'est
aussi d'abord un sujet d'organisation
collective et que il y a des façons sans
doute de de de venir changer un certain
nombre de paramètres qui peuvent être
économiques, fiscaux, réglementaires ou
autres ou même d'exemplarité, on
pourrait dire pour réduire le gâchi
immense que représente quand même un/ers
de la nourriture foutue en l'air à la
poubelle en Europe,
2 tonnes pour transporter 100 kg dans
les voitures, les logements vides, le le
gâchi qui représente tous les emballages
et le le consommé mais jeté. Donc il y a
il y a quand même voilà, on a des marges
de manœuvre en fait de de dingue et
c'est pas juste une histoire de se
contraindre. C'est pour ça que je dis
que il y a il y a des nouveaux modèles à
inventer, à expérimenter, à développer
et il y a quand même des marges de
manœuvre avant de se retrouver à l'âge
des cavernes en train de greloter quoi.
Quel regard vous portez sur la capacité
de l'Allemagne à ne pas
s'éclater par terre ?
Un peu le même que le que sur la
capacité de la France à pas s'éclater
par terre. Euh non, mais je veux dire,
on a quand même beaucoup de points
commun avec l'Allemagne. C'est-à-dire
que c'est on
les centrales nucléaires.
Non, mais ce que je veux dire, c'est que
on est quand même des civilisations
européennes ancienne, s'étant
industrialisé il y a maintenant un
certain temps, ayant trouvé un temps
notre place dans la mondialisation,
l'Allemagne plus longtemps que nous ou
pas sur la même chose exactement. Ils
ont expé à main. C'est ça.
Euh et des camber et des Mercedes et des
BMW
le camember c'est meilleur à manger que
la machine d'outil. Euh ah bah oui quand
même. Et donc c'est c'est mais mais on a
des on a des points communs et on est
tous les deux rattrapés par la
décroissance physique dont je parlais
tout à l'heure qu'on ne comprend pas.
Alors l'Allemagne plus tard que nous
parce que ils pendant longtemps ils ont
bénéficié d'une exportation beaucoup
plus forte que la nôtre.
Euh et euh dans danses physiques, j'ai
envie de dire des deux côtés également,
une forme de décru démographique ou en
tout cas du décru naté. Bref, donc il y
a beaucoup de similitude entre
l'Allemagne et nous et on a des régimes
politiques qui sont des régimes de beau
temps euh qui son qui et qui par
ailleurs, j'imagine en Allemagne comme
chez nous ont tendance à raconter à la
population des histoires qui ne sont pas
possibles à matérialiser, donc avec une
forme de crise de confiance dans les
institutions et dans la classe
politique. Et donc je pense qu'on vit
des histoires qui sont pas si
différentes que ça entre la France et
l'Allemagne. Voilà.
Question tu veux
Non. Min effet prè, c'est que je pense
qu'ils ont une une pratique démocratique
un petit peu différente de notre pays
jacobin.
Oui.
Et donc voilà, ça ça peut ouvrir plus
des des des capacités de coalition, de
discussion
voilà plus peut-être plus consensuell
que que chez nous. Mais bon, ça
sur les déterminants de fond, je pense
qu'on est très proche.
Question internet. À quel point le
développement de l'éolien causera une
demande en acier ? Quels sont les
impacts miniers ?
Est-ce soutenable ?
C'est pas un problème pour l'acier. Un
développement d'éolien.
Ouais.
Depuis 1970, on sait qu'il y a un
problème. L'humain est-il capable de
changement sans contrainte ? N'est-il
pas préférable d'essayer de prendre les
reennes plutôt que de faire du lobbying
? les reines,
les reines
politiquo dire. Ça ça semble être
politique, c'estàd imposer euh
les choses.
Ah moi je le vois plus comme un risque
que comme une opportunité cette
histoire. C'est-à-dire que l'histoire
nous a montré que quand les
civilisations étaient stressées, en
général
dictateur qui seaient
bah ouais les les les régimes
totalitaire étaient pas loin. Et quand
il y a un régime totalitaire en général,
on trouve pas ça super sympa, quoi.
Enfin pour une bonne partie de la
population.
Il vaudrait mieux, il vaudrait mieux
tenter euh d'y arriver. Alors,
démocratie, ça veut pas dire laxisme.
Euh, on est en démocratie et pourtant
j'ai pas le droit de tuer Philippe s'il
m'énerve. Il y a tout un tas de trucs
qu'on a pas le droit de faire. Si tu as
le droit,
j'ai le droit. Ah euh,
je mourrais en martyr.
Donc, en fait,
tu as le droit aussi si tu veux.
Et et maintenant, on n pas le droit de
fumer dans les trains. Donc, je veux
dire, c'est pas parce qu'on est en
démocratie qu'on a le droit de faire.
absolument n'importe quoi. Moi, j'espère
quand même qu'on va réussir à régler ce
problème en ne sortant pas trop de la
démocratie. Voilà. Mais ma crainte,
c'est plutôt qu'on y arrive pas euh et
que et que à un moment le système craque
et qu'on passe par une phase totalitaire
que personnellement j'ai pas tellement
envie de vivre.
Alors là, il y a une question mais c'est
c'est un roman donc on va essayer de s'y
atteler ensemble. Je la découvre en même
temps. Jean Covici se présente avant
tout comme un scientifique qui étudie
des faits et tire des conclusions
irréfutables. Pourtant, la majorité des
questions sur lesquelles il s'expriment
sont d'ordre économique. Déjà, lorsque
ces conférences à l'école des mines, il
convertissait l'énergie en monnaie, la
calorie en dollars quit du fait que les
monnaies est une conversion fixée par
une organisation sociale, une
organisation aujourd'hui basée sur
l'accumulation de richesse par les plus
riches. une convention de plus en de
plus en plus biaisée. Comment
justifie-t-il ce saut méthodologique
permanent ? Point interrogation, ces
conclusions sont-elles toujours
irréfutables lorsqu'il s'agit de
discuter de l'organisation des êtres
humains sans prendre en compte certains
facteurs, notamment sans discuter du
simulacre de la monnaie pour
interrogation et faites-moi des des
questions plus courtes.
Ouais, ça a été vraiment beaucoup liké
ça. Tu es sûr de sa question ? Je me
présente pas comme un scientifique, mais
j'ai mis sur mon site personnel il y a
très longtemps que je n'étais pas un
scientifique.
Donc voilà euh
d'ù je voilà je d'autres d'autres
peuvent éventuellement me coller cette
étiquette sur le front, mais je suis pas
comptable de ce que les autres racontent
sur moi. Euh en ce qui concerne la
conversion de l'énergie en monnaie, je
ne l'ai je n'ai jamais converti
l'énergie en monnaie. J'ai dit que euh
l'énergie était une manière de mesurer
les flux sur le plan physique et que
quand ces flux s'appliquaient à
l'appareil productif, l'argent était une
manière de comptabiliser ces flux de
façon économique. Voilà ce que j'ai dit.
Euh mais j'ai jamais tenu un tableau de
change avec 1 kWh égal tant de dollars.
Alors ce que j'ai déjà fait c'est que
j'ai déjà regardé la quantité de dollars
de valeur ajoutée qu'on pouvait euh dont
on pouvait disposer par kilowh d'énergie
mobilisée. Ça oui. Mais ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle un ratio et ça c'est pas
une conversion. Si je regarde la
quantité de chouffleurs à l'hectare, je
convertis pas des des chouffleurs en
hectare. Je je dis juste je fais un
ratio. Voilà. Bon euh donc alors je je
sais pas si la question a été posée avec
quelqu'un qui a directement écouté ce
que j'ai dit ou qui
voilà mais personnellement j'insiste
encore une fois je me suis jamais
présenté comme un scientifique euh parce
que je fais pas partie d'une institution
académique. Je voilà je et je j'ai j'ai
jamais fait une table de conversion.
J'ai juste dit que c'était deux angles
de vue euh l'argent et l'énergie qu'on
pouvait prendre sur la même réalité
physique qui était notre appareil
productif.
Question Philippe.
Oui, ça fait penser à l'équation de
Kaill en fait. C'est ça, c'est le de
dire euh
Oui.
de travailler euh finalement le contenu
en PIB euh PIB dollar. Euh, ça permet
notamment ça permet notamment l'équation
de Kaya. Oui, absolument.
Question internet. Si la population
diminue, c'est une c'est une catastrophe
pour la dette retraite. Si la population
augmente, c'est une catastrophe pour
l'environnement, le climat et cetera.
Quelle est la meilleure situation ?
Un avis, mais comme j'ai déjà répondu à
deux questions,
Ouais. Alors ou là là. Oui. Donc ça
c'est une question quoi de de maltusien
de de cryptousien un peu non ? En fait,
oui, effectivement
c'est pas juste une histoire de de
population et nombre, c'est aussi la
structure de cette population, le nombre
de personnes actives, le nombre de
personnes pas actives. C'est une
histoire de productivité de la
population active, c'est-à-dire du coup
combien de machines effectivement et de
systèmes automatisés et de robots
Optimus on met pour remplacer ceux qui
bossent pas.
Euh mais c'est vrai que aujourd'hui euh
c'est un souci euh pour tout État euh de
de d'avoir son PIB qui croit et son PIB,
il croit mieux s'il y a un peu plus de
naissance ou un peu d'immigration ou un
peu pour compenser le manque de
naissance ou les départs en
expatriation. Euh c'est c'est une
réalité et que et et c'est pas seulement
d'ailleurs pour des questions
économiques et pour faire des ratios sur
euh le taux d'endettement et être sûr
que la note de FIT ou de Standart Bourse
se dégrade pas. C'est c'est aussi même
pour des questions quasiment
géopolitiques.
Des pays qui feraient un choix de
maltusien de de décroissance de leur
population et bien se se mettent quelque
part de plus en plus à risque
probablement par rapport à des pays qui
eux feraient le choix de de au contraire
d'être un pays d'accueil comme les
États-Unis euh se développant beaucoup.
Question internet. Comment savoir que le
métier que j'étudie aujourd'hui servira
encore dans 10 ans ou dans 20 ans au vu
de la baisse énergétique ?
Euh la je pense que la la une des
meilleures références qu'on puisse
donner
euh enfin non pardon d'abord il y a il y
a il y a un côté boule de cristal dans
cette affaire parce que comme je le
disais tout à l'heure il y a deux
réalités aujourd'hui qui s'opposent. Euh
il y a la réalité des besoins primaires
et il y a la il y a la réalité des
gagnants de la mondialisation. Euh et
c'est pas la même. Donc aujourd'hui, les
deux catégories de métiers qui gagnent,
j'ai envie de dire, c'est ceux qui se
rapprochent des besoins primaires mais
qui sont plutôt des métiers pas très
bien payés. Euh donc ils sont des
métiers dont on est sûr qu'on aura
toujours besoin, sauf qu'ils sont pas
très bien payés. Donc c'est agriculteur
une part alors bâtiment, ils sont pas
tous mal payés, j'allais dire une partie
de l'artisanat du bâtiment. euh des gens
qui font du transport, des gens et
cetera. Donc en fait des besoins
imprimaires quoi. Et puis à tout à fait
à l'autre extrémité du spectre des gens
extrêmement bien payé euh qui gens qui
tout à l'heure qui font de
l'intelligence artificielle, de la
finance quantitative, du je sais pas
quoi. Enfin bon bref. Euh et donc la
question c'est à 10 ou 20 ans, si on
raisonne juste en terme de paris
personnel,
qu'est-ce qui va est-ce que il restera
toujours un espace significatif pour ce
que j'appelle les gagnants de la
mondialisation euh qui s'occupe de
choses qui sont don dont on pourrait
discuter de l'utilité sociale euh versus
les gens dont on est sûr que ça
correspondra toujours à un besoin
primaire, mais on n'est pas sûr que dans
le rapport de force du moment, ça sera
quand même eux qui vont rafler la mise
en terme de rémunération. Voilà. Donc la
aujourd'hui la question de l'utilité
sociale des métiers, elle ne rencontre
pas la question de la rémunération.
Et et donc si on est en train de
raisonner sur un paril personnel, du
coup la vraie question c'est qui qui
dans cet équilibre entre les deux,
qu'est-ce qu'on pense qu'il va gagner
d'ici 10 à 20 ans ? Personnellement,
j'en sais rien.
Ouais. Mais à ça que là, tu tu présentes
ça comme le truc un peu monocritaire de
dire quelle est la somme des salaires
que je vais faire sur 20 ans dans tel et
tel métier. Or en fait, tu peux pas
passer 20 ans à choisir un métier pour
passer 20 ans en disant c'est super
parceir
la haute hein. Le chemin est plus
important que la cible et tu vas passer
20 ans, choisis un métier qui te plaît
quoi. Déjà aussi et et qui a du sens
effectivement et dans lequel tu trouves
du sens.
Et donc ça sera sans doute lié,
espérons-le, si vous avez bien compris
ce qu'on a dit. à la question aussi du
coup de l'utilité commune
peut-être ou peut-être pas justement
c'est ce que je viens de dire
c'est pas sûr mais par contre je suis
d'accord avec toi que si c'est un métier
qui plaît
c'est toute de toute façon toujours ça
de gagner
et tuar pas
je vais je vais on va parler de vos BD
parce que
vous avez fait chacun une BD
moi j'ai fait la moitié d'une BD
tu as fait la moitié d'une BD et je
trouve que Philippe graphiquement la
tienne c'est un bijou
alors c'est Vincent qu'il faut Vincent
Per qu'
qu'il faut saluer. Je lui fais coucou
parce que à mon avis il est en train de
nous regarder parce que
c'est c'est un bijou, c'est
comme les équipes de Casterman en mode
ouais c'est SVW.
Donc le ça tombe bien, c'est bientôt les
périodes de Noël. Si vous voulez offrir
quelque chose d'intelligent, de sympa,
de 7 à 77 ans pour se sensibiliser à à
ce type de question, je vais vous passer
la BD de chacun et vous allez faire la
promo et du pourquoi pourquoi c'est
sympa. D'accord. Donc Jean-Marc, chaud
Jean-Marc, je te passe celle de
Philippe,
c'est chaud.
Et si tu peux être gentil, tu peux
passer ça. Merci bien à ton petit
voisin.
Merci.
Donc Jean-Marc, je voudrais que tu
fasses euh la promo. Tu tu as besoin de
tes lunettes
? Non non parce que je sais à peu près
ce qu'il y a dedans.
Bien joué. Je voudrais que tu montres à
la caméra euh ça. Tu prends n'importe
quelle Tu prends la première page
d'ailleurs qui a été dédicacée avec une
super dédicace.
Si oui ça ça ça donne le tweet
énigmatique de l'après-midi. C'est ça
avec un très beau dinosaur de
résolution.
Si tu peux montrer ça à notre caméraman,
notre caméra girl préféré.
Tu peux zoomer un petit peu.
Voilà. Et ensuite reste là. Reste là. Et
si je remarque, tu peux prendre
n'importe quelle page au milieu de la BD
pour montrer
le type de graphisme.
Comment c'est classe.
Ouais. Ouais. Vas-y.
Ça c'est une double page. Alors c'est
peut-être pas c'est peut-être pas la
meilleure.
Vas-y vas-y prends une autre corne pas
les pages s'il te plaît.
Je m'en fous. C'est pas mon exemplaire
d'addication ou qu'il a le aussi en fait
des pages si je veux.
Il a son dinosaure aussi.
C'est c'est quand même c'est quand même
si alors fais-moi l'article. Ça parle de
quoi ? Et bien euh ça parle de recette
de Babaor Rome. Non, ça ça parle
évidemment
parce qu'il il a la tienne dans la main.
Oui. Euh donc ça parle de ça parle de
ressources comme son nom l'indique
puisque c'est écrit sur le titre.
Euh et ça essaie d'expliquer comment
est-ce que notre monde actuel
n'existerait pas sans les ressources
qu'on va puiser dans la nature et les
problèmes que ça pose pour leur
disponibilité future ou parfois
actuelle.
Euh et ça traite d'un certain nombre de
questions qui correspondent, j'ai envie
de dire, à des questions que tout le
monde se pose, c'est-à-dire où est-ce
que ça se trouve ? Est-ce queon en a
beaucoup ? Est-ce qu'on en a pas
beaucoup ? Est-ce que ça se recycle
facilement une fois terme de scénario ?
en terme de scénario.
Alors, c'est une espèce de voyage un peu
un peu fantasmatique
de de science-fiction parce que en fait
le Philippe qui est représenté dans la
dans la BD se fait accompagner,
j'imagine que c'est le dessinateur.
Il est moins beau gosse que ça dans la
vraie vie mais
il s il s'est un peu amélioré. Il s'est
un peu amélioré. Ça sera
ça sera ça sera dit répéter et déformé.
Non mais ça ça au frè Noël ça au frère à
Noël c'est quand même vos béd
c'est c'est quand même euh autre chose.
Voilà et donc et donc on sent que le on
sent que le dessinateur il a été euh
comment tu dis pibroné à Star Wars.
Ouais ouais il était qu'une fois
l'espace.
Il a il a une il a une fascination pour
le pour le la science-fiction je pense.
Il son ses derniers projets Ouais.
Negaliot était était un peu autour de la
science. ça sent passionné quand même à
à se mettre dans le dans dans le titre
du bouquin.
Sent ça ça se sent. Et donc
tu es jaloux Jean-Marc ?
Non pas du tout. Pourquoi je serais
jaloux ?
Parce que c'est quand même super beau.
Bah bien sûr mais moi de toute façon je
suis pas dessinateur du monde sans fin
donc je vois pas pourquoi je serais
jaloux. Fais gae Christophe va le
regarder. Tu vas te faire
donc il faut demander à Christophe s'il
serait jaloux. Moi je sais pas je peux
lui demander hein. Je peux lui poser la
question. Ça m'étonnerait parce que bon
euh et puis euh moi je trouve ça très
bien queil y ait des bouquins comme ça
qui permettent de rendre le le un propos
accessible. Euh parce que si j'ai bien
entendu les chiffres de vente euh au
bout de quelques semaines, il y en a
déjà quoi 7 8000.
Ouais. Ouais. Quelques millier.
Moi mon premier bouquin, je sais pas
c'est ton premier bouquin ? Non c'est
pas ton premier bouquin. Les essais que
tu as fait avant, tu les
les essais que j'ai fait alors l'otchc
qui était mon deuxème essai le preriew.
Ouais. en 2014, je me souviens encore de
l'anecdote, donc c'est au seuil et je
crois qu'on en avait vendu 2000 la
première année et et le et l'éditeur
avait dit "Ah, ben c'est super, tu en as
vendu 2000, tu auras le droit d'en faire
un autre." Parce que effectivement les
essais dans l'environnement et tout,
c'est quelques milliers d'exemplaires,
on n'est pas en train de parler. Donc
là, de toute façon, ce livre là va se
vendre un ordre de grandeur au-dessus de
de l'essai. Donc en fait, c'est une
forme qui permet de démocratiser l'accès
à la connaissance de façon beaucoup plus
significative. Moi, c'est pareil, mon
premier bouquin, j'en ai vendu 5000 4500
exemplaires.
Fais-moi plaisir. Remontre une page à la
caméra.
Euh, que tu veux ? Ouais. Alors, après,
on en trouve pas mal sur internet des
pages. Voilà. Hop.
Voilà. Donc c'est donc c'est un c'est un
livre qui parle encore une fois de cette
réalité matérielle qui nous saute pas
nécessairement aux yeux parce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui dans des univers urbains qui
sont loin des mines, loin des usines,
loin de la transformation
dans des pays qui sont souvent eux-mêmes
enfin en France en tout cas qui est le
pays de la BD he parce que en dehors de
la France on vend pas beaucoup de BD
euh et bien c'est un c'est dans on est
loin de toute cette réalité matérielle
et donc ça nous ça nous ramène ça sous
les sous les yeux puis par ailleur on
vit dans l'instant présent et donc on
est détaché de ce qui s'est passé avant
et de ce qui pourrait se passer après.
Enfin, ce qui est normal hein et ce
livre nous raconte tout ça. Donc c'est
combien ça coûte ?
Très beaucoup trop cher.
Ouais, trop cher, c'est clair. 28 €.
Tu as combien toi ?
Je dois être pareil. Non,
je sais pas. Il y a code prix. Il y a
pas écrit. Il y a pas écrit. Je sais
pas. Je
Philippe, je voudrais que tu me fasses
la promo
de celle de Jean-Marc.
Bah ouais. Alors, comment faire la promo
d'un truc qui s'est vendu à à un million
d'exemplaires, hein. Donc, c'est
évidemment une référence. Je sais pas
combien tu es de traduction maintenant
des des dizaines littéralement
euh
bah je pense que alors moi euh moi mon
éditeur m'a dit un truc comme ça ça
arrive une fois par siècle dans dans mon
édition enfin je pense que ça a été une
même Dargo nous a dit c'est un
phénomène.
C'est c'est une voilà donc de toute
façon il s'agit pas de de là non plus de
faire une battle
euh ou de reproduire quoi que ce soit.
C'est c'est je pense qu'effectivement
d'ailleurs j'ai souvenir que à l'automne
2021, il y avait eu des petites ruptures
de stock. Oui, parce qu'on était on
était dans la période post Covid et donc
tout le carton avait été bouffé par les
gens du commerce en ligne d'où on
reparle de Bezos. Euh et donc le le
l'éditeur d'Argot avait dû batailler
pour trouver du carton pour faire les
couvertures. C'est été ça leur problème
?
C'était la couverture qui était le qui
était le le maillon faible. Vous avez un
problème de ressources, tu vois, de
papier pour imprimer, de carton pour
faire les couvertures et euh voilà.
Alors bon, donc que dire ensuite ? Alors
effectivement, on pourrait dire il y a
un point commun, bah c'est que il y a un
ingénieur qui raconte des trucs avec un
dessinateur qui finalement devient
aguéri assez vite.
Alors lui, il sent les dit, c'est
l'inverse parce qu'il se met il se met
un grand nez.
Ah oui. Tu as raison. Oui,
effectivement.
Philippe, Philippe, tu peux montrer à la
camé s'il te plaît ? Alors, je sais pas,
il faud choisir une sympa. Il y en a
plein.
Une avec une avec un grand nez.
Oui. Ah oui. Alors là, faut que j'en
trouve un où il est plus grand.
Euh bah tiens là, il a un super grand
nez là par exemple. Et puis Iron Man a
un super grand nez partout.
Iron Man Iron Man, c'est lui. Donc il a
un grand nez aussi partout. Absolument.
Donc du coup bah là on est sur voilà sur
la question de l'énergie climat. Donc
voilà c'est il y a énergie climat, il y
a ressources. Faudrait qu' il y a
peut-être biodiversité qui existe ou qui
est en train de se faire, je ne sais
pas. En tout cas, euh bah cette BD, elle
a marqué, je pense euh l'histoire parce
qu'elle a elle a ouvert aussi quelque
part une ligne de produit chez les
éditeurs. Elle a donné envie à de plus
en plus de gens, je pense, de faire de
faire de la de la BD documentaire ou du
roman graphique sur ces sujets-là. Je
pense qu'avant, il y avait peut-être
quelques trucs qui passaient en BD qui
étaient des trucs avaient cartonnés en
livre. C'était un peu un mode un peu
différent. je sais pas la Sapience ou
j'en sais rien, je sais pas de quand ça
date mais enfin ou peut-être avant mais
euh mais là voilà c'est vraiment l'idée
de de dire que et ben il y a plein de
gens qui vont pas effectivement se lire
le soir un essai écolo même très bien
euh on le sait nous voilà les ch de
vente cumulé c'est plutôt en dizaine de
milliers que que qu'en centaines de
milliers c'est clair. Euh et pourtant on
a plus que jamais besoin de bah de de
convaincre, d'expliquer, de discuter. On
et puis il y a pas toutes les solution
miracle, hein, je veux dire ni là ni là,
c'est on on mais mais on est sur des
voilà de une matérialité, euh un truc
physique en disant et après il faut
trouver le chemin ensemble démocratique
pour y aller. Mais au moins ça pose les
bases. Donc
il y a des tes 2 de prévu.
Alors euh il y en a il y en a un de
souhaité euh de notre côté, je crois
avoir trouvé le la bonne idée cet cet
été. Euh voilà, donc maintenant il faut
que Christophe sorte de ses projets en
cours parce que là il est sur 2 BD en
parallèle. Euh donc il faut qu'il émerge
de tout ça avant qu'on recommence à
travailler.
Philippe
Al c'est un peu prématuré. Euh
alors Vincent c'est plutôt un auteur de
fiction. Alors tu diras Christophe aussi
c'est c'est c'est dingo et on s'est on
s'est éclaté. Ça magnifie le propos. Il
y a pas de souci. mais il a d'autres
projets et tout ça. Donc il faut
vraiment qu'on passe un certain seuil de
vente, je dis pas lequel, pour le
convaincre de dire "Ah ouais, peut-être
qu'on fait un tome 2 et avant d'avoir
l'idée." Mais euh voilà, c'est pas tout
est possible tous les deux euh ce genre
de d'œuvre,
merci, c'est c'est nécessaire. Comment
expliquer à table, à des gamins ou à des
vieux boomers ? Là, ça permet de laisser
ça comme un petit piège dans les
toilettes.
Oui. Alors ça ça
a été le coup de génie de Christophe,
c'est que lui savait dès le début qu'il
fallait faire un livre qui était un
livre qui allait s'offrir
parce que en fait offrir un essai, on
n'est jamais sûr que les gens vont le
lire. Euh offrir un bouquin militant euh
ça peut être pris comme une agression.
euh offrir un une BD, ça reste dans le
domaine du cadeau sympa, quoi. Je veux
dire, ça rappelle les Astérix et les
Luciluc qu'on a reçu quand on était
gamin euh ou les BD euh qu'on se voit
offrir adulte mais qui sont des des des
toujours des objets de plaisir quand
même quelque part. Euh donc on tapait
dans un genre qui était un genre plutôt
euh et puis en plus nous on a mis pas
mal mais là aussi dans il y a des
blagues enfin on se tourne un peu en
dérision. Nous on se fout de notre
gueule enfin
comme d'habitude. Exactement. Euh on
n'est pas des gaulois pour rien. Même si
moi je suis pas gaulois du tout mais
c'est pas grave. Euh donc on a on a
qu'est-ce que je veux dire ? On a on on
a on est dans les canons du genre j'ai
j'ai envie de dire. Et donc du coup
c'est pas c'est pas du tout un don
agressif. Euh et puis une BD, je veux
dire, autant un essai, faut faire
l'effort intellectuel BD, on ouvre une
page puis on dit "A tiens, quand même le
dessin est sympa." On lit trois bulles.
Euh tu sais, c'est souvent comme ça
qu'on fait. On lit deux pages, "Ah, ça
ça a l'air marrant et puis du coup, on
repart du début." Bon, un essai, on peut
pas faire un truc comme ça. C'est quand
même beaucoup plus compliqué quoi.
Euh donc, c'est clair que ça ça enfin
moi je pense que c'est un genre qui
démocratise, ça c'est une espèce de
cours illustré quoi. Ça ça une vertu
pédagogique forte. en cadeau de Noël.
Franchement c'est ça c'est super idée.
Question Philippe, est-ce que tu as
trois bouquins à conseiller à notre
communauté ? Alors j'ai Alors moi j'ai
j'ai Ouais alors ouais déjà ouais c'est
ça 1 2 et du coup j'en prends quatre
parce que non mais moi j'étais hyper
stressé de ça c'était le truc qui me
faisait stresser ce soir c'était dire il
faut que j'aille réviser les six
précédents pour voir un peu ce que
j'avais pour pas répéter quoi. Bon alors
du coup j'ai trouvé là en live tout à
l'heure on parlait d'argent il y a un
truc vraiment génial à lire qui a pas
pris une ride. John Kenneth Galbrety,
l'argent en anglais monnaie, en français
l'argent c'est un truc incroyable qui
raconte le système monétaire, l'histoire
du système monétaire en particulier aux
États-Unis qui raconte que il troquait
des coquillages avec les Indiens, que le
la banque centrale c'était des pots de
castor en fait parce que à la fin les
coquillages étaient transformable en pot
de castor qui ensuite était monétisable
pour l'export.
montrer aussi que c'était en fait le
pouvoir de la banque privée. En fait là,
tu parlais tout à l'heure de de
fédéralisme et qu'en fait la banque
centrale fédérale américaine, elle est
arrivée un peu sur le tard et que
c'était plein de banques qui passaient
leur temps à faire faillite et cetera.
C'est passionnant. Ça date des années 60
mais et John KBR pour le coup c'est il
aurait fallu qu'il ait un un dessinateur
de de bandes dessinées parce que c'est
c'est un vulgarisateur et un pédagogue
incroyable, vraiment génial. Donc voilà
ce truclà. Et deuxième peut-être, mais
c'est la
on la cite dans la dans dans la BD parce
qu'on a on a pas mal de voilà de de de
personnes invité et cetera qu'on qu'on
fait parler. Euh c'est euh elle écrit
dans les années 30, c'est Gina Lambroso.
Euh c'était une médecin essayiste euh
italienne et elle a écrit notamment un
bouquin qui en français a été traduit
par la rançon du machinisme et qui parle
en fait de ce que l'industrialisation et
le le le travail à la chaîne, la
transformation industrielle un peu dans
les années 20, dans les années 30
provoquait finalement d'un point de vue
anthropologique et c'est et c'est
passionnant. Un petit exemple, c'est
voilà la question un peu de la rivalité
entre êtres humains sur la sur euh le
elle disait avant dans les villages et
cetera, on avait plein chacun était
artisan et fabriquait des trucs. C'était
entre guillemets à la main alors ça
allait pas très vite et on avait moins
de d'objets bien sûr, mais finalement
chacun mettait un peu une âme dans
l'objet et cetera de l'artigianaat. Puis
une fois que tu passes truc à la chaîne,
bah en fait ça existe plus. et elle
parle un peu de toutes ces des petites
arènes. Elle utilise ce mot-là, que
avant il y avait plein de petites arènes
dans tous les villes et les villages et
puis qu'à un moment c'est devenu une
grande arène. Le monde. Ça date des
années 30 he avant les réseaux sociaux.
Et tu imagines maintenant évidemment tu
appliques ça à la question numérique où
tout le monde essaie de briller sur un
star et d'apparaître et de faire plus de
live que les autres. Et et là encore
avec le recul, ce qui est écrit dès les
années 30, c'est un peu stressant parce
que ça a été déjà écrit puis ça nous a
pas empêché la trajectoire qu'on a eu
mais c'est vraiment hyper intéressant.
Jean-Marc. Alors euh je vais en citer
quatre mais il y en a deux qui sont du
même hauteur et qui sont sur ils sont
sur un thème un thème commun.
Les deux premiers que je vais te citer
sont d'un biologiste de l'ONF qui
s'appelle Laurentillon euh et qui a
écrit deux livres qui sont
successivement Être un chou
et euh les fantômes de la nuit. Alors
Être un chè parle d'un chîn. Le
personnage central est un chîn qui a
l'âge vénérable sauf erreur de ma part
de 260 ans. Je suis encore jeune pour un
chîn.
Et alors à travers l'histoire de ce
chîn, l'auteur nous fait découvrir ce
que c'est qu'un écosystème forestier. Il
explique comment le chîn est défendu par
les prédateurs des chenis qui lui
boulotte ses feuilles. Comment est-ce
que quand la feuille commence à être
boulottée, elle émet des tout un tas de
molécules euh qui font que le reste de
la feuille devient un peu plus indigeste
pour les chenill qui la boulotent. de
comment est-ce que le chaîne communique,
le chaîne parents communique avec les
chaînes enfants via le mycélium des
champignons qui les enfin les aliments
et enfin c'est passionnant, c'est
génial, super poétique et il a écrit un
bouquin sur les chauves-souris qui
s'appelle les fantômes de la nuit, euh
même même éditeur, acte sud, même même
auteur et cetera. C'est super sympa à
lire.
Euh un deuxième livre qui n'a
strictement rien à voir, que j'ai lu il
y a pas très longtemps. Euh bah deuxème
parce que là les deux premiers, j'ai dit
que c'était un
on suit on suit. C'est féminicèine euh
d'une autrice qui s'appelle Vera
Nikolski euh alors qui est une féministe
qui irrite les féministes. C'est assez
rigolo mais ça moi j'e j'adore parce que
j'aime beaucoup les gens qui prennent
des contrepieds. Euh dans lequel en gros
son grand thème c'est l'émancipation des
femmes n'a pas n'a pas résulté
principalement de revendication. Elle a
résulté principalement de conditions
matérielles qui ont permis la
réalisation de cette émancipation. et
elle au premier chef d'entre elles, elle
cite l'anthropocène, c'est-à-dire
l'accès à des ressources en masse et à
de l'énergie en masse parce que ça a
permis de diminuer la mortalité
infantile. Or euh moins de grossesse et
moins d'allaitement, c'est fatalement un
facteur de différence entre les hommes
et les femmes qui s'estompent. Euh la
terciarisation de l'emploi qui a été
permise par l'anthropocène est un
facteur également d'émancipation parce
que la force physique ne compte plus
pour occuper un travail. Euh les tâches
domestiques ont été considérablement
réduites, même quand elles sont encore
exercées par les femmes à cause de la
mécanisation du lavage du linge, de la
préparation de la nourriture et cetera.
Et donc en fait, elle cite tous les
exemples dans lequel cette émancipation
a été rendue possible par les acquis de
l'entropocèe. Alors évidemment, ça pose
une question centrale qui est que
subsiste-t-il des acquis des femmes dans
un monde dans lequel l'entropocène
s'estompe et où les ressources
deviennent moins abondantes. Et elle dit
"Artung, ça c'est un danger pour nous."
Et donc aujourd'hui, être féministe, ça
veut dire aller nous investir nous-mêmes
des postes de responsabilité où on
décide de l'allocation des ressources.
Et je trouve que c'est génial comme
conclusion parce qu'elle dit pas faut
défiler dans la rue et manifester. Elle
dit faut faire des sciences et aller
occuper des postes où on va gérer la
location des ressources. C'est très
intéressant.
Euh et enfin le dernier bouquin que j'ai
lu il y a pas longtemps et que j'ai
trouvé très éclairant, c'est un bouquin
de Jarette Diamond qui s'appelle de
l'inégalité parmi les sociétés qui en
anglais c'est Guns Germs et Steer euh
qui est un bouquin formidable beaucoup
plus intéressant qu'effondrement très
largement plus intéressant qui en plus
effondrement est un peu discutable. Moi
je trouve que il généralise des cas de
figures qui sont très particuliers
et ça a été un peu contesté l'île de
pâqu et tout.
Î de pack, c'est quand même pas la
civilisation dans son alors que là il
traite de la civilisation dans son
ensemble. Euh et il explique notamment
ce que je trouve génial mais je vais pas
donner l'explication ce soir parce qu'il
faut quand même que les gens lisent un
peu et se fatiguent. Euh il explique
comment est-ce que la domestication
d'espèces animale en Europe
pas fatigant de lire.
Pardon ?
C'est pas fatiguant de lire.
Non mais c'est c'est il est un peu épais
quand même. Il fait quelques centaines
de il fait 600 pages ou un truc comme
ça.
Mais c'est pas fatigant. Il est
passionnant de toute façon. Il est
passionnant. Il a il a un style un peu
lent quand même he Diamond. Euh mais le
le fond du bouquin est passionnant et il
explique comment les espèces sauvages
domesticables qui étaient disponibles
sur les divers continents expliquent des
milliers d'années après pourquoi est-ce
qu'une poignée de conquistador espagnole
a réussi à venir à bout de dizaines de
milliers d'art. Voilà. Je vais pas
expliquer le raisonnement parce que
mais c'est c'est c'est lumineux. Oui,
bien sûr. En anglais, ça s'appelle Gun
Germsel. Donc il y a Jorms. Bon mais
c'est super intéressant comme bouquin et
en fait c'est un bouquin qui théorise de
façon un peu structurée le déterminisme
géographique de l'évolution des
civilisations. Et ça se rapproche un peu
aussi pour moi de pourquoi est-ce que
les peuples du nord sont venus enquiner
les peuples du sud en Europe au moment
de ce qu'on a appelé les invasions
barbares. Tout ça tout ça se rapproche
du du même voilà
de de même de mêmes explications qui
sont à la base
physico, géographico biologique et c'est
super intéressant.
Jean-Marc, un conseil pour les jeunes
générations et le mot de la fin pour
Philippe avec son conseil pour les
jeunes générations.
Je voulais juste faire un mini truc en
disant on rajoute un 7e bouquin ou un
8e, je sais plus à combien on est si tu
as pas encore lu. C'est le troisème
chimpanzé du même jaret diamond.
Ah non, je l'ai pas. C'est c'est sur du
même niveau que que de l'inégalité parmi
les sociétés et qui est bien mieux aussi
qu'effondrement. Donc le troisème
jeimpanz c'est tu as le chimpanzé, le
bonobo et puis l'être humain. Voilà et
qui raconte en fait ce qui fait la
spécificité d'être humain par rapport à
plein de sociétés animales. Et c'est
passionnant aussi.
D'accord. Parce que quand j'étais quand
j'étais jeune, j'avais lu un autre
bouquin de d'un auteur qui s'appelait
Desmond Moris qui est le bouquin
s'appelait le singe nu. Oui.
Euh et là, ça expliquait plutôt les
similarités entre l'homme et tout un tas
d'espèces de singes.
Jean-Marc, un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Euh garder espoir. Non, enfin non mais
euh soyez lucide mais profitez de la
vie.
Tu es sûr que Oui
oui oui. Enfin, je veux dire, faut pas
être on a on a quand même beaucoup parlé
ce soir de raison de sombrer dans
l'amorosité. Euh donc moi, j'ai envie de
dire aux jeunes générations, soyez
lucides, donc ne prenez pas des paris
non gagnables, mais mais prenez des
paris quand même, c'est-à-dire baissez
pas les bras, euh vous dites pas tout
est foutu, euh on va on va écouter du
rap et se shooter euh et
oh mais le rap
c'est une musique,
ça y est, tu vas te faire des nouveaux
haters.
Non non non non. Moi, je trouve que les
musiques sont le reflet de les des
civilisations.
Respecte le rap.
Non, c'est pas ce que je veux dire.
C'est pas de l'irrespect. Et ce que je
veux dire, c'est que il y a des des
musiques sont enfin les musiques des des
époques où tout allait bien sont des
musiques où il y a beaucoup de mélodies
très entraînantes. C'est des musiques
gay, c'est des musiques et cetera. Les
musiques sont quand même toujours un peu
le reflet du du d'une époque. Euh et je
trouve
rap c'est quoi ?
Bah le rap c'est quand même né après les
chocs pétroliers au moment des début des
crises économiques et je trouve que
c'est des musiques qui te qui te qui te
les yeux en face des trous.
Ouais, enfin c'est ça. Les paroles
peuvent être super hein. C'est pas ce
que je dis, mais je dis que la la
mélodie elle-même, elle est elle est
c'est c'est c'est pas c'est le le le ce
qui ce qui en ce qui en ressort, c'est
pas de la joie, tu vois. C'est pas c'est
pas le sentiment que tu as le plus envie
d'associer quand tu écoutes du rap.
C'est tu as pas envie de te dire ça
c'est joyeux, tu vois. Voilà. C'était ça
que c'était ça que je voulais dire. Euh
et euh le voilà. Donc il faut il faut
j'ai j'ai j'ai envie de dire il faut y
croire quand même. Alors
c'est d'autant plus important pour les
jeunes que ils sont dans une phase où la
vie devant eux c'est un projet. Non mais
c'est un projet, c'est une construction.
C'est pas juste voilà. Et aujourd'hui,
on voit ce qu'il en le danger vers
lequel on est entraîné
euh avec une si on a une jeunesse qui
commence à à être sans espoir euh et du
reste c'est un danger y compris pour les
vieux. Donc les vieux ferait bien de
s'en soucier un peu aussi.
Philippe, un conseil pour les jeunes
générations, un mot de la fin.
Ouais. Bah on parlait on parlait de la
haute tout à l'heure, on a cité
plusieurs fois. Bah ouais, c'est donc
c'est tout à fait en ligne avec ce que
ce que dit Jean-Marc, c'est le chemin
est plus important que la cible où la
cible c'est le chemin. Donc il va y
avoir des très beaux trajets de vie au
21e siècle qui va être compliqué mais le
20e l'a été aussi, le 19e l'a été aussi.
En 18e, c'est vrai qu'il y avait Mozart
et puis au 19e il y avait Verdi. Donc
ouais et ça peut être aussi écouter un
écouter un un Chanté ou un truc comme
ça, c'est quand même pas mal si vous
connaissez pas. Euh écoutez-les deux
fois mais dès la deuxième fois vous
serez accroché. Euh normalement euh ça a
marché pendant des siècles, il y a pas
de raison que ça marche plus. Euh non,
donc voilà, il va y avoir euh allez-y,
on l'être humain se réalise dans
l'action. Donc voilà, agissez. Euh, il y
a 1000 manières de le faire. Soyez
tenace, soyez enthousiastes, il y a pas
de souci. Les marges de manœuvre sont en
réalité considérables aussi. Bien sûr
que c'est tout ça est compliqué mais il
y a de quoi faire. Et je rajoute merci à
notre communauté de nous soutenir sur
Tipi, de nous financer. Ça nous permet
vraiment de pouvoir faire des
expériences de pensée, aller chasser de
l'info. Grâce à eux, on est indépendant.
Messieurs, merci d'être venu ce soir et
à bientôt.
Merci.
[Musique]